This is the 99% of us will breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kaelin. So today we are finishing part 6, The Lust for Power, and finally beginning part 7, The Loss of Power. That's chapters 39-41, pages 895-983. Later on in this episode, our special guest is Clara Jeffrey. Clara is the editor-in-chief of Mother Jones and the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the fantastic radio show and podcast Reveal. You should definitely subscribe to Reveal.
This is the 99% of us will breakdown of the power broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kaelin. So today we are finishing part 6, The Lust for Power, and finally beginning part 7, The Loss of Power. That's chapters 39-41, pages 895-983. Later on in this episode, our special guest is Clara Jeffrey. Clara is the editor-in-chief of Mother Jones and the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the fantastic radio show and podcast Reveal. You should definitely subscribe to Reveal.|||这是《权力的经纪人》99%用户分析节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·凯林。今天我们将结束第六部分《权力欲》，并最终开始第七部分《权力的丧失》。也就是第39到41章，第895到983页。在本集稍后的节目中，我们的特邀嘉宾是克拉拉·杰弗里。克拉拉是《琼斯母亲》杂志和调查报道中心的总编辑，该中心制作了出色的广播节目和播客《揭秘》（Reveal）。你绝对应该订阅《揭秘》。
It's fantastic. She had a long and storied career editing works of investigative journalism that speaks truth to power and afflicts the comfortable, all the good stuff. So she brings that perspective to her understanding of the Power Broker. What is especially fun to me is that I've known Clara for a long time. She hadn't read the Power Broker before and this podcast inspired her to pick it up and read it along with us. So she is truly one of us. And a special thanks to everyone who came out to our live event with Robert Caro in
It's fantastic. She had a long and storied career editing works of investigative journalism that speaks truth to power and afflicts the comfortable, all the good stuff. So she brings that perspective to her understanding of the Power Broker. What is especially fun to me is that I've known Clara for a long time. She hadn't read the Power Broker before and this podcast inspired her to pick it up and read it along with us. So she is truly one of us. And a special thanks to everyone who came out to our live event with Robert Caro in|||太棒了。她有着长期而丰富的职业生涯，编辑过许多向强权说真话、让特权阶层坐立不安的调查新闻作品，全都是好东西。因此她将这种视角带到了她对《权力的经纪人》的理解中。对我来说特别有趣的是，我认识克拉拉很久了。她以前没读过《权力的经纪人》，而这个播客激励她拿起这本书并和我们一起阅读。所以她真的是我们的一员。特别感谢所有参加我们在纽约与罗伯特·卡罗的现场活动的人
New York, the New York Historical Society. What an amazing thing. What a dream come true. I felt so grateful and excited to be on that stage with him. And it would made it even more exciting was that you were there too. Thank you for bringing your excitement and your energy and your interest and yourselves. We had a great time. I hope you did too. So on the last episode of the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Caro
New York, the New York Historical Society. What an amazing thing. What a dream come true. I felt so grateful and excited to be on that stage with him. And it would made it even more exciting was that you were there too. Thank you for bringing your excitement and your energy and your interest and yourselves. We had a great time. I hope you did too. So on the last episode of the 99% visible breakdown of the power broker, Robert Caro|||纽约，纽约历史协会。多么了不起的事。简直是梦想成真。能和他在那个舞台上，我感到无比感激和兴奋。更让人兴奋的是，你们也在场。感谢你们带来的热情、活力、兴趣以及你们自己。我们度过了一段美好的时光。希望你们也是。所以在上集《权力的经纪人》99%可见度分析节目中，罗伯特·卡罗
took us on a lavish, luxurious trip to Jones Beach so we could see what it was like to be wined and dined by Robert Moses. And then we watched him ram one mile of expressway through a Bronx neighborhood, needlessly destroying it and bringing misery to the many lives of its occupants in the process. It was a real roller coaster of an episode. It was a real, here's the good news, here's the bad news about Robert Moses. Truly. And today we'll be covering chapters 39 through 41,
took us on a lavish, luxurious trip to Jones Beach so we could see what it was like to be wined and dined by Robert Moses. And then we watched him ram one mile of expressway through a Bronx neighborhood, needlessly destroying it and bringing misery to the many lives of its occupants in the process. It was a real roller coaster of an episode. It was a real, here's the good news, here's the bad news about Robert Moses. Truly. And today we'll be covering chapters 39 through 41,|||带我们进行了一次奢华的琼斯海滩之旅，让我们见识了罗伯特·摩西盛情款待是怎样的体验。然后我们看着他将一英里长的高速公路强行穿过布朗克斯的一个社区，无端地摧毁了它，并在过程中给那里的许多居民带来了苦难。这真是一集充满起伏的节目。这真的是一集关于罗伯特·摩西的好消息和坏消息的节目。确实如此。而今天我们将涵盖第39到41章，
that's pages 895 through 983 in my copy of the book. At this point in the story, Robert Moses is at the height of his power and control, but that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. We're gonna be finishing part six, the lust for power and beginning to move into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived. Not quite Roman, we've still gotta get through this episode.
that's pages 895 through 983 in my copy of the book. At this point in the story, Robert Moses is at the height of his power and control, but that doesn't mean it's always going to be that way. We're gonna be finishing part six, the lust for power and beginning to move into part seven, the loss of power. We have arrived. Not quite Roman, we've still gotta get through this episode.|||在我手里的书中，也就是第895到第983页。在故事的这个阶段，罗伯特·摩西正处于其权力和控制的巅峰，但这并不意味着情况永远会这样。我们将完成第六部分《权力欲》，并开始进入第七部分《权力的丧失》。我们到了。还没完全到，罗曼，我们还得熬过这一集。
That's right, that's right. Midway through this, we're gonna turn the corner. Yes, power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly to turn the corner. Yes. Power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly as you might want it. But keep in mind, this also happened a long time ago. It's all over. So it did happen.
That's right, that's right. Midway through this, we're gonna turn the corner. Yes, power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly to turn the corner. Yes. Power will begin to be lost. Not as quickly as we might like it. No, not as quickly as you might want it. But keep in mind, this also happened a long time ago. It's all over. So it did happen.|||没错，没错。在这中间，我们将迎来转折。是的，权力将开始流失。可能没有我们希望的那么快。不，转折没那么快。是的。权力将开始流失。可能没有我们希望的那么快。不，没有你想象的那么快。但请记住，这也是很久以前发生的事了。一切都结束了。所以它确实发生了。
That's right. Okay, so we're going to start with Chapter 39, The Highwayman. What are we going to cover in The Highwayman? So in The Highwayman, we're starting the first of a duology of chapters. We saw that trilogy of chapters in the last episode that were centered around specifically East Tremont, the neighborhood in the Bronx where the cross Bronx Expressway is just being shoved right through against all reason and rationality. These two chapters, they're going to build beautifully yet frighteningly off of those previous two, going from this microcosm of one mile of the Bronx, and now he's going to widen out his focus,
That's right. Okay, so we're going to start with Chapter 39, The Highwayman. What are we going to cover in The Highwayman? So in The Highwayman, we're starting the first of a duology of chapters. We saw that trilogy of chapters in the last episode that were centered around specifically East Tremont, the neighborhood in the Bronx where the cross Bronx Expressway is just being shoved right through against all reason and rationality. These two chapters, they're going to build beautifully yet frighteningly off of those previous two, going from this microcosm of one mile of the Bronx, and now he's going to widen out his focus,|||没。好的，那么我们将从第39章《江洋大盗》（The Highwayman）开始。我们在《江洋大盗》里要讲什么？所以在《江洋大盗》中，我们开始了一组两章中的第一章。我们在上一集中看到了围绕东特雷蒙特（East Tremont）的那三章，那是布朗克斯的一个社区，横跨布朗克斯的高速公路不顾一切理智和理性硬生生地穿过了那里。这两章将在前两章的基础上以美妙而又可怕的方式展开，从布朗克斯一英里的这个微观世界出发，现在他将扩大他的焦点，
Caro is, to show how that is just one part of a larger Moses plan, which will, deliberately or not, foreclose the future comfort, convenience, and quality of life for generations of New Yorkers and Long Islanders. He's like, oh, it's terrible how the, you know, 1500 families got really hurt by this. Now it's everybody. It's such a, such a sudden jump to a wider scale. And I have to assume that the title of this chapter, it's never made explicitly clear, but I have to assume it's reference to the double meaning of highwayman, not just a man devoted to highways, but literally a highwayman, the old fashioned sense of a robber who stops people on the road
Caro is, to show how that is just one part of a larger Moses plan, which will, deliberately or not, foreclose the future comfort, convenience, and quality of life for generations of New Yorkers and Long Islanders. He's like, oh, it's terrible how the, you know, 1500 families got really hurt by this. Now it's everybody. It's such a, such a sudden jump to a wider scale. And I have to assume that the title of this chapter, it's never made explicitly clear, but I have to assume it's reference to the double meaning of highwayman, not just a man devoted to highways, but literally a highwayman, the old fashioned sense of a robber who stops people on the road|||卡罗意在展示，这只是摩西宏大计划的一部分，该计划无论是否出于故意，都将剥夺几代纽约人和长岛人未来的舒适、便利和生活质量。他就像是在说，哦，你知道，1.5万个家庭因此受到真正的伤害，这太可怕了。现在是所有人了。这是一个如此突兀、如此迅速地扩大到更大范围的跳跃。我不得不假设这一章的标题——虽然从未明确解释过——但我必须假设它是指“highwayman”的双重含义，不仅仅是一个致力于公路的人，而字面上的意思就是一个江洋大盗，即老式意义上的在路上拦截行人
and steals their valuables. And he is here showing Moses to be someone who is stealing time, enjoyment, quality of life from the lives of commuters and stealing the future from as yet unborn generations of New York metropolitan residents. Yeah, it's not only a widening in scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time
and steals their valuables. And he is here showing Moses to be someone who is stealing time, enjoyment, quality of life from the lives of commuters and stealing the future from as yet unborn generations of New York metropolitan residents. Yeah, it's not only a widening in scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time|||并偷走他们财物的人。他在这里展示了摩西是一个偷走通勤者的生活时间、享受和生活质量，并从尚未出生的几代纽约都会区居民手中偷走未来的人。是的，这不仅是地理范围的扩大，它真的是时间范围的扩大
that he is going to fuck up New York so much Yeah, it's not only a widening scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time that he is going to fuck up New York so much and that you cannot unfuck it. You know what I mean? Like it really is like it's going to last forever for decades, maybe forever. And that's the scope of these two chapters. So where in time are we starting here? So we start by jumping back in time to July 3rd, 1945, when the first new civilian car made in the United States since February of 1942 rolls off the
that he is going to fuck up New York so much Yeah, it's not only a widening scope of geography, it's really a widening scope of time that he is going to fuck up New York so much and that you cannot unfuck it. You know what I mean? Like it really is like it's going to last forever for decades, maybe forever. And that's the scope of these two chapters. So where in time are we starting here? So we start by jumping back in time to July 3rd, 1945, when the first new civilian car made in the United States since February of 1942 rolls off the|||他将把纽约搞得一团糟，是的，这不仅是地理范围的扩大，它真的是时间范围的扩大，他将把纽约搞得一团糟，而且你无法恢复原状。你知道我的意思吗？就像它真的会永远持续下去，持续几十年，也许是永远。这就是这两章的范围。那么我们在这里从时间的哪个节点开始呢？因此，我们首先将时间倒回至1945年7月3日，当时自1942年2月以来美国制造的第一辆新的民用汽车驶下了
Ford assembly line. We're all so, and this is this not to get off the point almost immediately, but I was astounded seeing this again. It's just such a sign of how single-minded and goal-oriented the United States was during World War II that for three years there were no new cars basically. All auto plants were making military armaments for three years and the idea that the country could ever be that devoted to its single goal is astonishing and inspiring to me and someday maybe we'll have that sense
Ford assembly line. We're all so, and this is this not to get off the point almost immediately, but I was astounded seeing this again. It's just such a sign of how single-minded and goal-oriented the United States was during World War II that for three years there were no new cars basically. All auto plants were making military armaments for three years and the idea that the country could ever be that devoted to its single goal is astonishing and inspiring to me and someday maybe we'll have that sense|||福特装配线。我们都感到非常——这并不是要马上偏离主题，但我再次看到这个时感到震惊。这真是二战期间美国如何专一和目标导向的标志，整整三年里基本上没有新车。所有汽车厂都在制造三年军火，国家能够如此致力于单一目标的想法对我和激励着我，也许有一天我们会拥有那种
of purpose again. Maybe we don't won't have to fight the worst war in the history of the world. That's not great. Yeah, and hopefully not eat organ meat. I mean, I'm fine with that part. I mean, it's as long as it's prepared well, but we can talk about that later. But now it's 1945, the war's over, gas rationing is over. People wanna buy cars, they wanna drive cars.
of purpose again. Maybe we don't won't have to fight the worst war in the history of the world. That's not great. Yeah, and hopefully not eat organ meat. I mean, I'm fine with that part. I mean, it's as long as it's prepared well, but we can talk about that later. But now it's 1945, the war's over, gas rationing is over. People wanna buy cars, they wanna drive cars.|||目标感。也许我们不必经历世界历史上最糟糕的战争。那倒不赖。是的，希望不用吃内脏。我的意思是，那部分我没问题。我的意思是，只要做好了就行，但我们可以稍后再谈。但现在是1945年，战争结束了，汽油配给制取消了。人们想买车，想开车。
They wanna do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to, Roman? Within weeks, what is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them, they want to do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to Roman within weeks? What is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them all the time? That there is street congestion, just streets filled with cars, not moving. Yeah. It's that old law we've talked about a lot. If people have the opportunity to drive cars on roads, too many of them will decide to do that and the roads will not be able to handle it.
They wanna do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to, Roman? Within weeks, what is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them, they want to do it as much as they want. And what does that lead to Roman within weeks? What is the result of people wanting cars and wanting to drive them all the time? That there is street congestion, just streets filled with cars, not moving. Yeah. It's that old law we've talked about a lot. If people have the opportunity to drive cars on roads, too many of them will decide to do that and the roads will not be able to handle it.|||他们想怎么开就怎么开。罗曼，这会导致什么结果？在几个星期内，人们想要汽车并想开着它们，他们想怎么开就怎么开，这会带来什么结果？罗曼，在几周内这会导致什么？人们想要汽车并一直想开着它们的后果是什么？那就是街道拥堵，街道上挤满了汽车，一动不动。是的。这就是我们经常谈论的那条老定律。如果人们有机会在道路上开车，他们中就会有太多人决定这样做，而道路将无法承受。
And the Herald Tribune, it runs an editorial asking why the city government isn't doing enough to solve this traffic. And Robert Moses responds with a letter that is such, it's such classic Robert Moses writing, but I just wanted to read a little bit of it just for fun. Cause I just, I'm enjoying his style. And he says, what has New York done about street congestion? Bless your little journalistic hearts, a hell of a lot. And why sit we idly by without further plans
And the Herald Tribune, it runs an editorial asking why the city government isn't doing enough to solve this traffic. And Robert Moses responds with a letter that is such, it's such classic Robert Moses writing, but I just wanted to read a little bit of it just for fun. Cause I just, I'm enjoying his style. And he says, what has New York done about street congestion? Bless your little journalistic hearts, a hell of a lot. And why sit we idly by without further plans|||《先驱论坛报》发表了一篇社论，质问为什么市政府在解决这一交通问题上做得还不够。罗伯特·摩西回复了一封信，这真是典型的罗伯特·摩西式的文风，但我只想读一小段图个乐。因为我只是很欣赏他的风格。他说，纽约为街道拥堵做了什么？保佑你们这些小小的新闻记者心肠，做了老鼻子多了。为什么我们坐视不管，却没有针对
for the big jam, singing who threw the whiskey in the well while up in the roaring forties, editors are cutting up tires into rubber heels. Tush, tush, the blueprints are oozing from our files and spilling over the floors. And I just wanna say, I love this. Everyone in the forties, when they're writing stuff, they turn into Stanley.
for the big jam, singing who threw the whiskey in the well while up in the roaring forties, editors are cutting up tires into rubber heels. Tush, tush, the blueprints are oozing from our files and spilling over the floors. And I just wanna say, I love this. Everyone in the forties, when they're writing stuff, they turn into Stanley.|||大塞车的进一步计划，唱着“是谁把威士忌扔进了井里”，而在喧嚣的四十年代，编辑们正把轮胎剪成橡胶鞋跟。啧，啧，蓝图从我们的档案里渗出来，溢到了地板上。我只想说，我太喜欢这个了。四十年代的每个人在写东西时，都变成了斯坦利。
Like they just like Stanley at his most trying to be poetic yet also irreverent at the same time. This is, I love it. It's so of the time and it's like Robert Moses should have been like a columnist. That's what he should have been doing. Totally, not dot penning those racy novels, but it's just been replying to.
Like they just like Stanley at his most trying to be poetic yet also irreverent at the same time. This is, I love it. It's so of the time and it's like Robert Moses should have been like a columnist. That's what he should have been doing. Totally, not dot penning those racy novels, but it's just been replying to.|||就像他们一样，就像斯坦利极力想要具有诗意却又同时放荡不羁的时候。这太棒了，我喜欢。这太符合那个时代了，感觉罗伯特·摩西本该当个专栏作家。那才是他该干的事。完全如此，而不是去写那些低俗的小说，而只是在回复。
It makes you wanna read that romance novel he wrote so badly just to see what crazy turns of phrase were in there. And his solution to everything is just building more roads, that's it. Yes. And maybe more parking garages, that's it. Yeah, and the parking garages are the new aspect.
It makes you wanna read that romance novel he wrote so badly just to see what crazy turns of phrase were in there. And his solution to everything is just building more roads, that's it. Yes. And maybe more parking garages, that's it. Yeah, and the parking garages are the new aspect.|||这让你太想读他写的那部浪漫小说了，只想看看里面有什么疯狂的词句转折。而他对一切问题的解决办法就是修建更多的路，仅此而已。是的。也许还有更多停车场，就这样。是的，停车场是新的方面。
He's like, hey, get this, we're not only gonna build more roads for cars, we're gonna build more places just to stuff cars. And he keeps announcing these huge plans. He's going to expand the roads he already has. He's got this project that involves at least 200 miles more worth of roads. And Tara talks about how in each decade, the 20s, the 30s, the 40s, Moses has announced a plan that seems unthinkably large. And then the next decade, he announces a plan that makes the last plan seem like a small plan.
He's like, hey, get this, we're not only gonna build more roads for cars, we're gonna build more places just to stuff cars. And he keeps announcing these huge plans. He's going to expand the roads he already has. He's got this project that involves at least 200 miles more worth of roads. And Tara talks about how in each decade, the 20s, the 30s, the 40s, Moses has announced a plan that seems unthinkably large. And then the next decade, he announces a plan that makes the last plan seem like a small plan.|||他就像是说，嘿，听着，我们不仅要为汽车修建更多的道路，我们还要建立更多专门用来塞满汽车的地方。他不断宣布这些庞大的计划。他打算扩建他已有的道路。他有一个项目涉及至少200英里以上的新道路。塔拉谈到，在每个十年里——20年代、30年代、40年代——摩西都曾宣布过一个大得不可思议的计划。而在接下来的十年里，他又宣布了一个让上一个计划看起来像个小计划的计划。
And I was recently reading Ursula K. Le Guin's book, The Lathe of Heaven, and she has a passage in it that I couldn't help but think about Robert Moses when I read it. And she says, the quality of the will to power is precisely growth. Achievement is its cancellation. To be the will to power must increase
And I was recently reading Ursula K. Le Guin's book, The Lathe of Heaven, and she has a passage in it that I couldn't help but think about Robert Moses when I read it. And she says, the quality of the will to power is precisely growth. Achievement is its cancellation. To be the will to power must increase|||我最近在读厄休拉·K·勒古恩的书《天国之轮》（The Lathe of Heaven），她在其中有一段话，让我在阅读时不禁想起了罗伯特·摩西。她说，权力意志的品质正是增长。成就即是对它的取消。作为权力意志必须不断增加
with each fulfillment, making the fulfillment only a step to a further one. The vaster the power gained, the vaster the appetite for more." And while I was reading it, I was like, I wonder if she read The Power Broker when she was writing the science fiction novel. Or really, Ozymandias is really, that's the same principle there. You know, just like, you know, just like weeping because there's no more worlds to conquer. You just have to get bigger and bigger and bigger or this guy doesn't exist, you know. Yes. And so, and it feels like Robert Moses answers always is we need more roads, bigger roads, partly to ease traffic, but also partly because
with each fulfillment, making the fulfillment only a step to a further one. The vaster the power gained, the vaster the appetite for more." And while I was reading it, I was like, I wonder if she read The Power Broker when she was writing the science fiction novel. Or really, Ozymandias is really, that's the same principle there. You know, just like, you know, just like weeping because there's no more worlds to conquer. You just have to get bigger and bigger and bigger or this guy doesn't exist, you know. Yes. And so, and feels like Robert Moses answers always is we need more roads, bigger roads, partly to ease traffic, but also partly because|||随着每一次的实现，使实现本身仅仅通往进一步实现的台阶。获得的权力越大，对更多权力的胃口就越大。”当我在阅读时，我在想，不知道她在写这本科幻小说时是否读过《权力的经纪人》。或者实际上，奥齐曼迪亚斯（Ozymandias）真的就是那个同样的原则。你知道，就像，你知道，就像因为没有更多的世界可征服而哭泣。你必须变得越来越大，否则这家伙就不存在了，你知道的。是的。因此，并且感觉罗伯特·摩西的回答永远是我们需要更多的道路，更大的道路，部分是为了缓解交通，但也部分是因为
what's he gonna do if he stops building roads? Like what does his life mean if he stops building roads? Where does his power go? And in the 1920s and 1930s, Caro says people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, 1930s, Caro says, people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, the response is getting slightly more muted. And this is partly because urban planners have started to say with increasing urgency that you need a balance of transportation. You can't just rely on roads. You've also got to have mass transit to balance out the fact that when you build roads, there's going to be more roads. But Moses, he doesn't like mass transit. He doesn't wanna build it. He's not interested in it.
what's he gonna do if he stops building roads? Like what does his life mean if he stops building roads? Where does his power go? And in the 1920s and 1930s, Caro says people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, 1930s, Caro says, people were really excited to see these programs completed. Now in the 40s, the response is getting slightly more muted. And this is partly because urban planners have started to say with increasing urgency that you need a balance of transportation. You can't just rely on roads. You've also got to have mass transit to balance out the fact that when you build roads, there's more roads. But Moses, he doesn't like mass transit. He doesn't wanna build it. He's not interested in it.|||如果他停止修路，他要做什么？比如如果他停止修路，他的生活意味着什么？他的权力去哪了？在20世纪20年代和30年代，卡罗说人们对看到这些项目完成感到非常兴奋。现在在40年代，30年代，卡罗说，人们对看到这些计划的完成感到非常兴奋。现在在40年代，反应变得稍微微弱了一些。这部分是因为城市规划者开始越来越紧迫地指出，你需要交通平衡。你不能只依赖道路。你还必须有公共交通来平衡这样一个事实：当你修建道路时，会有更多的道路。但是摩西，他不喜欢公共交通。他不想建设它。他对此不感兴趣。
And he monopolizes the construction money in the city so much that even if people were like, well, we'll build it without you, they couldn't do it. All the money is being poured into roads. And that's something that we're gonna see again and again throughout these couple of chapters is just how much he is taking from the potential of mass transit
And he monopolizes the construction money in the city so much that even if people were like, well, we'll build it without you, they couldn't do it. All the money is being poured into roads. And that's something that we're gonna see again and again throughout these couple of chapters is just how much he is taking from the potential of mass transit|||他垄断了城市的建设资金，以至于即使人们说，好吧，没有你我们自己建，他们也做不到。所有的资金都倾注到了道路上。这是我们在接下来的几章中会一再看到的事情，那就是他从公共交通的潜力中拿走了多少资源
so that you can put it into roads. Yeah. And this is really just points out again, more of Robert Moses's weakness is like, you know, Carol talks about him having a certain genius for seeing a city and carving up a city and drawing lines, but he has almost just like, I mean, rudimentary, like just a backwards notion of how systems work together. Like I think it's partly his bias towards not wanting mass transit and thinking cars are great and not realizing how cars
so that you can put it into roads. Yeah, and this is really just points out again, more of Robert Moses's weakness is like, you know, Carol talks about him having a certain genius for seeing a city and carving up a city and drawing lines, but he has almost just like, I mean, rudimentary, like just a backwards notion of how systems work together. Like I think it's partly his bias towards not wanting mass transit and thinking cars are great and not realizing how cars|||以便你可以把它投入到道路中。是的，这实际上再次指出了罗伯特·摩西的更多弱点，就像卡罗谈到他有一种看待城市、分割城市和划线的某种天才，但他几乎只是，我的意思是，很粗浅，就像对系统如何协同工作有着落后的观念。比如我认为这部分是因为他偏向于不想要公共交通，认为汽车很棒，却没意识到汽车是如何
just become functional things in people's lives through the 40s, 50s, and 60s. But I actually wonder if he's like particularly stupid in this area. You know, like because, because it just would willfully stupid because it's not that the buses or subways or light rail or trains would be good in and of themselves. They would actually make the roads he made better. If he thought more holistically about them,
just become functional things in people's lives through the 40s, 50s, and 60s. But I actually wonder if he's like particularly stupid in this area. You know, like because, because it just would willfully stupid because it's not that the buses or subways or light rail or trains would be good in and of themselves. They would actually make the roads he made better. If he thought more holistically about them,|||在40年代、50年代和60年代成为人们生活中的功能性事物的。但我其实在想他在这个领域是否特别愚蠢。你知道，就像因为，因为这简直是故意装傻，因为并不是说公共汽车、地铁、轻轨或火车本身有多好。它们实际上会让他建造的道路更好。如果他对它们进行更全面的思考，
they would perform better for the people who wanted to be on them and, you know, siphon off some of the excess. And I find that particularly like interesting or kind of galling, but also just like strange that he didn't see any upside in making these things just for the benefit of Rhodes. Like you could make a case that for the benefit of just his Rhodes, you could have done these other things and made them better. I think there's, I think you're exactly, I mean, you're exactly right. And this is part of Caro's argument
they would perform better for the people who wanted to be on them and, you'd know, siphon off some of the excess. And I find that particularly like interesting or kind of galling, but also just like strange that he didn't see any upside in making these things just for the benefit of Rhodes. Like you could make a case that for the benefit of just his Rhodes, you could have done these other things and made them better. I think there's, I think you're exactly, I mean, you're exactly right. And this is part of Caro's argument|||它们会为那些想在上面行驶的人表现得更好，并且，你知道的，分流掉一些过剩的流量。我发现这特别有趣，或者有点气人，但也只是觉得奇怪，他竟然没看到做这些事情对罗兹（Rhodes）有什么好处。就像你可以提出这样一个观点：仅仅为了他的道路的利益，你本可以做这些其他的事情并把它们做得更好。我认为，我认为你完全，我的意思是，你完全正确。这也是卡罗论点的一部分
that like the roads would function better if you had these mass transit systems working with them. I think I have two answers that as someone who has not studied Robert Moses as much as anyone except, I mean, as much as Robert Caro has, is I think one of them is because I don't think he really cares that much how the roads function.
that like the roads would function better if you had these mass transit systems working with them. I think I have two answers that as someone who has not studied Robert Moses as much as anyone except, I mean, as much as Robert Caro has, is I think one of them is because I don't think he really cares that much how the roads function.|||即如果你有这些公共交通系统与它们配合，道路的运转会更好。作为一个没有像罗伯特·卡罗那样深入研究过罗伯特·摩西的人，我想我有两个答案。其中一个原因是，我认为他其实并不那么关心道路是如何运作的。
He cares about building them. And once it he really cares that much how the roads function. He cares about building them. And once it's built, he's onto the next project. Like I was saying with that lead of heaven thing, and this would be a much better place for me to put that quotation, but I already said it, is that he likes building. He doesn't like road management.
He cares about building them. And once it he really cares that much how the roads function. He cares about building them. And once it's built, he's onto the next project. Like I was saying with that lead of heaven thing, and this would be a much better place for me to put that quotation, but I already said it, is that he likes building. He doesn't like road management.|||他关心的是建造它们。一旦它——他真的那么关心道路如何运作吗？他关心的是建造它们。一旦建好，他就开始下一个项目了。就像我刚才说的那个“天国之轮”的事，这本来是我放那段引文的绝佳地方，但我已经说过了，那就是他喜欢建设。他不喜欢道路管理。
You know, other people would have been fine with overseeing these enormous bridge projects and then not building other things. Like that's my monument is this bridge, but he just has to keep building. And once it's done, it's just a revenue machine for him. He doesn't really care if it's working well. He just cares about the driving numbers. But the other thing is I think we have to remember, because it gets thrown
You know, other people would have been fine with overseeing these enormous bridge projects and then not building other things. Like that's my monument is this bridge, but he just has to keep building. And once it's done, it's just a revenue machine for him. He doesn't really care if it's working well. He just cares about the driving numbers. But the other thing is I think we have to remember, because it gets thrown|||你知道，其他人监督完这些巨大的桥梁项目，然后不再建造别的东西，也会觉得很好。就像“我的纪念碑就是这座桥”，但他就是得不停地建下去。一旦建成，对来说它只是一台印钞机。他并不真正在乎它运作得是否良好。他只在乎驾驶流量。但另一件事是，我认为我们必须记住，因为这经常被提及
around a lot this, in the last episode, I think we made the mistake too. And we corrected ourselves in calling Moses an engineer that like, he's not an engineer, like his education is in civil service. Like understanding how a civil service system works and how to reform it. And a civil service is built out of people. And it's a system that's flexible because people can change. Whereas a road is not flexible.
around a lot this, in the last episode, I think we made the mistake too. And we corrected ourselves in calling Moses an engineer that like, he's not an engineer, like his education is in civil service. Like understanding how a civil service system works and how to reform it. And a civil service is built out of people. And it's a system that's flexible because people can change. Whereas a road is not flexible.|||在上一集中，我想我们也犯了这个错误。我们纠正了把摩西称为工程师的说法，比如他不是工程师，他的教育背景是公务员制度。比如了解公务员系统是如何运作的以及如何对其进行改革。而公务员制度是由人组成的。这是一个灵活的系统，因为人是可以改变的。而道路则是不灵活的。
Once it's built, it's there. You can expand it or you can move it with great effort, but you're not dealing with people who are adaptable. And I think that's part of it. I wonder if he might be approaching construction infrastructure from the point of view of someone who thinks that it has the flexibility of a human-based system.
Once it's built, it's there. You can expand it or you can move it with great effort, but you're not dealing with people who are adaptable. And I think that's part of it. I wonder if he might be approaching construction infrastructure from the point of view of someone who thinks that it has the flexibility of a human-based system.|||一旦建好，它就在那里。你可以扩建它，或者你可以花很大力气移开它，但你打交道的可不是懂得适应的人。我想这也是原因之一。我在想，他是不是以一个认为基础设施拥有以人为本系统的灵活性的人的视角来对待建设基础设施的？
Yeah, well, but he also takes advantage of the fact that that is inflexible at a certain point, like he does steak driving later on that sort of limits any criticisms or changes that can come later on. So he counts on both sides of it. But it's just, I think that's really interesting. Like that part, like he builds it, he's done.
Yeah, well, but he also takes advantage of the fact that that is inflexible at a certain point, like he does steak driving later on that sort of limits any criticisms or changes that can come later on. So he counts on both sides of it. But it's just, I think that's really interesting. Like that part, like he builds it, he's done.|||是的，不过他也利用了它在某种程度上是不灵活的事实，比如他后来所做的钉桩行为（stake driving），这在某种程度上限制了以后可能出现的任何批评或修改。所以他两边的好处都占了。但这只是，我认为这非常有趣。就像那部分，比如他建好了，他就完事了。
And then the only sort of value of that road is how it induces demands for more roads later on. Not that they do the thing that they're supposed to do. I mean, it's very similar to the way consumer technology works now, where a piece of electronics that you buy, it's not intended to do that job as well as possible.
And then the only sort of value of that road is how it induces demands for more roads later on. Not that they do the thing that they're supposed to do. I mean, it's very similar to the way consumer technology works now, where a piece of electronics that you buy, it's not intended to do that job as well as possible.|||然后那条路的唯一价值在于它如何引发了日后对更多道路的需求。而不是说它们做了它们理应做的事情。我的意思是，这非常类似于现在消费科技的工作方式，你买的一件电子产品，它的目的并不是尽可能好地完成那项工作。
It's intended to do it fine until it breaks and then you get the next version of it. There's that built in obsolescence and it's like, it's like the opposite end of not delivering a great product where on one end everything breaks down super fast and you have to replace it. On the other end, it doesn't work great but you can never replace it.
It's intended to do it fine until it breaks and then you get the next version of it. There's that built in obsolescence and it's like, it's like the opposite end of not delivering a great product where on one end everything breaks down super fast and you have to replace it. On the other end, it doesn't work great but you can never replace it.|||它的设计目的是让它正常工作到坏掉，然后你再去买它的下一个版本。这里存在着内置的过时性，这就像，这就像是没有交付伟大产品的对立面，一端是所有东西都坏得超快，你不得不替换它。另一端是它运作得不是很好，但你永远无法替换它。
You know, it's just, it's permanent and immortal. And he, I think he just doesn't, he doesn't care. I don't think he cares if it does a great job, partly because he's not gonna have to use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him and he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him. And he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the backseat.
You know, it's just, it's permanent and immortal. And he, I think he just doesn't, he doesn't care. I don't care if it does a great job, partly because he's not gonna have to use it, you know, or if he does, he'll be in his office car that where someone else is driving him and he can, I would say he's gonna kick back, but he's just gonna do a lot of work in the backseat.|||你知道，它就是永久的、不朽的。而他，我想他只是不在乎，他不在乎它是否能做到最好，部分是因为他不需要使用它，你知道，或者如果他真的用了，他也会坐在他的办公专车里，由别人开车，他可以——我会说他会放松一下，但他只是会在后座上处理大量的工作。
So it's not only that he's just not building or considering mass transit in his plans. He is actively destroying mass transit in the process of building these roads. Like he's pulling up tracks. He's really just like, he's starving it of money, and he's taking advantage of this idea that this really is a system, but he's hogging up all the resources and sort of thought and leadership of this system of transit, you know, to the benefit
So it's not only that he's just not building or considering mass transit in his plans. He is actively destroying mass transit in the process of building these roads. Like he's pulling up tracks. He's really just like, he's starving it of money, and he's taking advantage of this idea that this really is a system, but he's hogging up all the resources and sort of thought and leadership of this system of transit, you know, to the benefit|||因此，不仅是他的计划中没有建设或考虑公共交通。他在修建这些道路的过程中，还在积极地摧毁公共交通。比如他在拔掉铁轨。他真的就像是，他在让它资金枯竭，他利用了“这确实是一个系统”的想法，但他却独占了这个交通系统的所有资源以及某种思想和领导权，你知道的，为了
of just building bridges and roads. And there's ripples that lead out from that, and that's what a lot of this chapter is about about is it's not just transportation, but about the way a city is built around that transportation. And Carol started talking about how this road-based system is affecting the development of the outlying neighborhoods in New York and in Long Island, because a neighborhood developed around a subway line is going to be developing for foot traffic.
of just building bridges and roads. And there's ripples that lead out from that, and that's what a lot of this chapter is about about is it's not just transportation, but about the way a city is built around that transportation. And Carol started talking about how this road-based system is affecting the development of the outlying neighborhoods in New York and in Long Island, because a neighborhood developed around a subway line is going to be developing for foot traffic.|||仅仅修建桥梁和道路的利益。由此引发了一系列连锁反应，这也是本章很大一部分所要讲述的内容，即它不仅关乎交通，还关乎围绕这种交通建造城市的方式。卡罗开始谈到这种基于道路的系统是如何影响纽约和长岛外围社区发展的，因为围绕地铁线路发展的社区将是为了步行交通而发展的。
It's going to be much higher density because people need to be able to walk from the station to their homes. It's, living in Los Angeles, people are like, you should take the rail to work. And I'm like, so I drive to a parking lot and then get out at the train station and then take the train the rest of the way, come on.
It's going to be much higher density because people need to be able to walk from the station to their homes. It's, living in Los Angeles, people are like, you should take the rail to work. And I'm like, so I drive to a parking lot and then get out at the train station and then take the train the rest of the way, come on.|||它的密度会高得多，因为人们需要能够从车站步行到他们的家。住在洛杉矶的人会说，你应该坐轻轨去上班。而我就想，所以我得先开车去停车场，然后在火车站下车，然后坐剩下的路的火车，拜托。
I just don't, I wanna take the whole way. But if you are building around roads, then people are gonna need cars and the neighborhoods are gonna be zoned and developed in a way that is low density because people already have the cars. And it wouldn't be so bad if the people living in those kind of lower density,
I just don't, I wanna take the whole way. But if you are building around roads, then people are gonna need cars and the neighborhoods are gonna be zoned and developed in a way that is low density because people already have the cars. And it wouldn't be so bad if the people living in those kind of lower density,|||我只是不想，我想一路坐到底。但如果你围绕着道路建设，那么人们就需要汽车，而社区的规划和开发方式将会是低密度的，因为人们已经有了汽车。如果住在那些较低密度的人，
more suburban parts of the city had access to jobs near where they lived. Maybe if they could walk or take a local transit to their jobs. But Moses is such an influence on how the land around his parkways is zoned and controlled. And he wants them to look beautiful and pristine. So he discourages industry from expanding out to those areas,
more suburban parts of the city had access to jobs near where they lived. Maybe if they could walk or take a local transit to their jobs. But Moses is such an influence on how the land around his parkways is zoned and controlled. And he wants them to look beautiful and pristine. So he discourages industry from expanding out to those areas,|||城市中更偏向郊区的部分的人能够找到离他们住处近的工作，那倒也还好。也许如果他们能步行或乘坐当地的交通工具去上班的话。但摩西对他的公园大道周围的土地如何规划和控制有着巨大的影响。他希望它们看起来美丽而原始。因此他阻止工业向这些地区扩展，
which means the vast majority of these new residents in the outlying areas have to drive back into the city every day for work or take the rickety Long Island railroad. And we'll talk later about why nobody wants to do that, but he's, he's basically, uh, using his road building as a way, deliberately or not, to control how these parts of the city are developed and built
which means the vast majority of these new residents in the outlying areas have to drive back into the city every day for work or take the rickety Long Island railroad. And we'll talk later about why nobody wants to do that, but he's, he's basically, uh, using his road building as a way, deliberately or not, to control how these parts of the city are developed and built|||这意味着这些偏远地区绝大多数新居民每天都必须开车回城里上班，或者乘坐摇摇晃晃的长岛铁路。我们稍后会讨论为什么没有人愿意那样做，但他基本上是，呃，利用他修路的方式，无论是否出于故意，来控制城市的这些部分是如何被开发和建设的
and how the people there are gonna have to live their lives. Yeah, and it really is this positive feedback loop. And what I mean by positive feedback loop is the action amplifies the next action that amplifies the next action. And either that happens in a positive direction or negative direction. The positive part is just the amplification.
and how the people there are gonna have to live their lives. Yeah, and it really is this positive feedback loop. And what I mean by positive feedback loop is the action amplifies the next action that amplifies the next action. And either that happens in a positive direction or negative direction. The positive part is just the amplification.|||以及那里的人们将如何度过他们的生活。是的，这确实是一个正反馈循环。我所说的正反馈循环是指一个行动放大了下一个行动，进而放大再下一个行动。无论是向积极的方向发生还是向消极的方向发生。积极的部分只是放大作用。
It's the sort of death spiral. Yeah, it feels like it rarely happens with positive outcomes for anybody. But it isn't that a negative feedback loop will be one where the next action stops the previous action. But so this is like everything just sort of spirals away. Because of this choice, there's roads, therefore it makes low density housing,
It's the sort of death spiral. Yeah, it feels like it rarely happens with positive outcomes for anybody. But it isn't that a negative feedback loop will be one where the next action stops the previous action. But so this is like everything just sort of spirals away. Because of this choice, there's roads, therefore it makes low density housing,|||这是一种死亡螺旋。是的，感觉它很少会给任何人带来积极的结果。但负反馈循环并非是指下一个行动会阻止前一个行动。所以这就好象一切都在螺旋式失控。因为这个选择，有了道路，因此它制造了低密度的住房，
that means more roads and more and more of an idealized form of what could be a higher density, better, you know, served communities along Long Island are just denied. And it starts from the very beginning and just kind of builds and builds and builds on itself. Yeah, the other thing, here's the other thing about cars. All right, Roman, I'm gonna lay this on you. This might be a big shock to you.
that means more roads and more and more of an idealized form of what could be a higher density, better, you know, served communities along Long Island are just denied. And it starts from the very beginning and just kind of builds and builds and builds on itself. Yeah, the other thing, here's the other thing about cars. All right, Roman, I'm gonna lay this on you. This might be a big shock to you.|||这意味着更多的道路，而长岛沿线本来可以成为更高密度、更好、你知道的、服务更完善的社区的理想形式，就这样被剥夺了。这一切从一开始就开始，并不断地在其自身基础上积累、积累、再积累。是的，还有一件事，关于汽车的另一件事。好吧，罗曼，我要跟你谈谈这个。这可能会对你是一个巨大的打击。
So you live in Long Island, your office is back in Manhattan, you gotta drive in to work. When you get to work, you gotta do something with that car. Yeah. You can't just put it in your pocket and then go into the office with it.
So you live in Long Island, your office is back in Manhattan, you gotta drive in to work. When you get to work, you gotta do something with that car. Yeah. You can't just put it in your pocket and then go into the office with it.|||所以你住在长岛，你的办公室在曼哈顿，你得开车去上班。当你到达公司时，你得把那辆车安顿好。是的。你不能把它放进兜里然后带着它走进办公室。
You gotta put it somewhere. You gotta find parking. And Moses is pouring all these new cars into the city and people are like, where are we gonna put these cars? And he says, don't worry, we're gonna build these multi-story parking garages. He doesn't say this, but the implication whenever I read this part is the most beautiful thing
You gotta put it somewhere. You gotta find parking. And Moses is pouring all these new cars into the city and people are like, where are we gonna put these cars? And he says, don't worry, we're gonna build these multi-story parking garages. He doesn't say this, but the implication whenever I read this part is the most beautiful thing|||你得把它放在某个地方。你得找个停车位。而摩西把所有这些新车倾倒进城市，人们就在想，我们要把这些车停在哪里？他说，别担心，我们要建这些多层停车场。他没有明说，但每当我读到这一段时，其暗示的意思是，这是你可以给一个生机勃勃的城市增加的最美丽的风景
you can add to a living city, just multi-story parking garages above ground. And aside from the fact that they're hideously ugly, I apologize to anyone who owns or designs parking garages. They're just the ugliest thing you can put in a city, I imagine. The planners start to notice the city can never really park more than a fraction of the cars coming in.
you can add to a living city, just multi-story parking garages above ground. And aside from the fact that they're hideously ugly, I apologize to anyone who owns or designs parking garages. They're just the ugliest thing you can put in a city, I imagine. The planners start to notice the city can never really park more than a fraction of the cars coming in.|||——地面上的多层停车场。除了它们丑得吓人之外——我向任何拥有或设计停车场的人道歉。我想它们简直是你可以放进城市里的最丑的东西。规划者开始注意到，这座城市永远无法真正停放下涌入的汽车的哪怕一小部分。
There isn't the space, there isn't the money to build those spots. At a certain point, you're just building a city made out of parking spots. Like there's no room for the people anymore. And this is something that is also kind of affecting and unfair for average New Yorkers. In 1945, and I think this is still the case, Carol says most New Yorkers didn't own cars. And now I think in many cases, it's a lifestyle
There isn't the space, there isn't the money to build those spots. At a certain point, you're just building a city made out of parking spots. Like there's no room for the people anymore. And this is something that is also kind of affecting and unfair for average New Yorkers. In 1945, and I think this is still the case, Carol says most New Yorkers didn't own cars. And now I think in many cases, it's a lifestyle|||没有足够的空间，也没有足够的资金来建造那些车位。在某个特定时刻，你建出的只是一座由停车位组成的城市。就好像再也没有空间留给人类了。这也是一件对普通纽约人来说既有影响又不公平的事情。在1945年，我认为现在依然如此，卡罗说大多数纽约人都没有汽车。现在我认为在很多情况下，这是一种生活方式
choice. Certainly when I lived in New York, I did not want the hassle of owning a car. So that's why I didn't have one. But back then, most New Yorkers could not afford to own a car. And Moses is diverting all this funding into roads and away from mass transit, leading, as we were saying, like mass transit fares rise, less people are using it, so the fares have to rise again to cover that shortfall. And money is being spent to help the few in the city who can afford to drive or from outside the city who can afford to drive and not the many who can't. And the result of that is not just that mass transit stays the same and or deteriorates slightly, but that new mass transit is not being built.
choice. Certainly when I lived in New York, I did not want the hassle of owning a car. So that's why I didn't have one. But back then, most New Yorkers could not afford to own a car. And Moses is diverting all this funding into roads and away from mass transit, leading, as we were saying, like mass transit fares rise, less people are using it, so the fares have to rise again to cover that shortfall. And money is being spent to help the few in the city who can afford to drive or from outside the city who can afford to drive and not the many who can't. And the result of that is not just that mass transit stays the same and or deteriorates slightly, but that new mass transit is not being built.|||的选择。当然，当我住在纽约时，我不想惹上拥有一辆车的麻烦。这就是为什么我没有车。但在当年，大多数纽约人根本买不起车。而摩西却把所有的资金都转移到了道路建设上，剥离了公共交通的资金，正如我们所说的那样，导致公共交通票价上涨，使用的人更少了，因此票价不得不再次上涨以弥补这一缺口。钱被用来帮助城市中少数买得起车的人，或者城外买得起车的人，而不是那些买不起车的多数人。其结果不仅是公共交通保持原状或略有恶化，而是新的公共交通根本没有被建造。
And Kara talks about how there were plans for the fabled legendary Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this second avenue subway line. Now, nearly 80 years later, it's still not fully finished yet in the way that it was talked about at the time. It was going to be this amazing line going all the way up to the city and now it goes like four extra stops on the Upper East Side, you know, and it took billions of dollars and a lot of time to get there. And Carol notes, he says,
And Kara talks about how there were plans for the fabled legendary Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this Second Avenue subway line. Roman, you've never lived in New York, so you don't know how often this is the topic of conversation is if only we had this second avenue subway line. Now, nearly 80 years later, it's still not fully finished yet in the way that it was talked about at the time. It was going to be this amazing line going all the way up to the city and now it goes like four extra stops on the Upper East Side, you know, and it took billions of dollars and a lot of time to get there. And Carol notes, he says,|||卡拉谈到曾有过关于传奇色彩的第二大道地铁线的计划。罗曼，你从未在纽约住过，所以你不知道人们谈论这个话题有多频繁，比如“要是我们有这条第二大道地铁线就好了”。罗曼，你从未在纽约住过，所以你不知道人们谈论这个话题有多频繁，比如“要是我们有这条第二大道地铁线就好了”。现在，将近80年过去了，它在当时被谈论的那种规模上仍然没有完全完工。它本来是一条通往市中心的神奇线路，而现在它在上东区增加了大概四站路，你知道的，为了达到这一步花费了数十亿美元和大量时间。卡罗指出，他说：
by building transportation facilities for the suburbs, he was ensuring that no transportation facilities would be built for the ghettos. Therefore, planners saw in the transportation field, the portion of the public helped by the use of public resources would not be the portion of the public that needed help most. So once again, like he did with parks earlier, like he did with the roads within the city.
by building transportation facilities for the suburbs, he was ensuring that no transportation facilities would be built for the ghettos. Therefore, planners saw in the transportation field, the portion of the public helped by the use of public resources would not be the portion of the public that needs help most. So once again, like he did with parks earlier, like he did with the roads within the city.|||“通过为郊区建设交通设施，他确保了贫民窟不会有任何交通设施。因此，规划者在交通领域看到，通过使用公共资源而得到帮助的那部分公众，并不是最需要帮助的那部分公众。”因此，再次像他早先对待公园那样，像他对待城市内部的道路那样。
He is waiting resources towards the people who don't really need them to live their lives in the city. And the end result of this is that poor residents are cut off from the full use of their own city. There are neighborhoods that are just inaccessible for them to live in. There are parts of the city they can't get to easily. There's resources that they should be able to share in because it's part of their city and they just can't get there in an easy way. And carers make the case that it's not just that Moses through his road building is not helping these people,
He is waiting resources towards the people who don't really need them to live their lives in the city. And the end result of this is that poor residents are cut off from the full use of their own city. There are neighborhoods that are just inaccessible for them to live in. There are parts of the city they can't get to easily. There's resources that they should be able to share in because it's part of their city and they just can't get there in an easy way. And carers make the case that it's not just that Moses through his road building is not helping these people,|||他把资源倾斜给那些在城市生活中并不真正需要它们的人。其最终结果是，贫困居民被剥夺了充分利用自己城市的权利。有些社区对他们来说根本无法居住。有些城市区域他们无法轻易到达。有些资源本该是他们能够分享的，因为这是他们城市的一部分，而他们却无法以一种简单的方式到达那里。卡罗提出，这不仅仅是摩西通过修路没有帮助这些人，
but he is actively, maybe not deliberately hurting them by making it harder for them to take full use of this amazing city that they live in and have just as much a right to as anybody else. Yeah, yeah. And what's interesting as the number of cars has increased so much, people are starting to recognize that building more roads is not working for them. Like this is really beginning to reach the average person where they're like, I'm not buying this anymore,
but he is actively, maybe not deliberately hurting them by making it harder for them to take full use of this amazing city that they live in and have just as much a right to as anybody else. Yeah, yeah. And what's interesting as the number of cars has increased so much, people are starting to recognize that building more roads is not working for them. Like this is really beginning to reach the average person where they're like, I'm not buying this anymore,|||而是他通过增加他们充分利用这座他们所居住的、并且与其他任何人享有同样权利的神奇城市的难度，从而在积极地（也许并非故意地）伤害他们。是的，是的。有趣的是，随着汽车数量的大幅增加，人们开始意识到修建更多的道路对他们来说并没有用。这真的开始触及普通人了，他们会觉得，我再也不买账了，
you know? And then the new sort of this beginning of an urbanism movement and thinkers like Lewis Mumford are presenting it and people are more actively talking about it and are more aware of it. Yeah, you start to see like letters to the editor to newspapers talking about the need to cut down on cars. The newspapers themselves don't cover this particularly much, which is something that we're gonna see
you know? And then the new sort of this beginning of an urbanism movement and thinkers like Lewis Mumford are presenting it and people are more actively talking about it and are more aware of it. Yeah, you start to see like letters to the editor to newspapers talking about the need to cut down on cars. The newspapers themselves don't cover this particularly much, which is something that we're gonna see|||你知道吗？然后这种城市主义运动的新萌芽开始出现，像刘易斯·芒福德（Lewis Mumford）这样的思想家也将其展现出来，人们开始更积极地谈论它，并对此有了更多的认识。是的，你开始看到给报社编辑的信件，讨论减少汽车的必要性。报纸本身并没有对这一点进行特别多的报道，这是我们在
throughout these chapters is the lack of either interest or appetite or desire in the part of the major newspaper press in covering the idea that there is a problem with trafficking the city and the problem is not just we don't have enough roads to take care of all these cars. And something that we're going to see throughout is one, this kind of failure on the parts of the papers to call real attention to this. And two, for modern readers, the continuing shock at how many newspapers were in New York at the time, which we can talk about more later. Just you read it and you're like, all these newspapers that you don't know about.
throughout these chapters is the lack of either interest or appetite or desire in the part of the major newspaper press in covering the idea that there is a problem with trafficking the city and the problem is not just we don't have enough roads to take care of all these cars. And something that we're going to see throughout is one, this kind of failure on the parts of the papers to call real attention to this. And two, for modern readers, the continuing shock at how many newspapers were in New York at the time, which we can talk about more later. Just you read it and you're like, all these newspapers that you don't know about.|||这些章节中将贯穿看到的事情——主流报纸媒体在报道“城市交通存在问题，且问题不仅仅是我们没有足够的道路来应付所有这些汽车”这一观点时，缺乏兴趣、胃口或愿望。我们将始终看到的一点是，其一，报纸未能引起人们对这一问题的真正重视。其二，对于现代读者来说，他们会持续感到震惊的是，当时纽约竟然有那么多的报纸，我们稍后可以多谈谈这一点。你读着读着就会觉得，天哪，有这么多你压根没听说过的报纸。
And it's just you really had your choice back then. I also want to mention the, it's fun to see Lewis Mumford mentioned a couple times in this chapter. I'm a big fan of his. I love his book, The City in History. And his architectural reviews, they're like, you know, lovably curmudgeonly
And it's just you really had your choice back then. I also want to mention the, it's fun to see Lewis Mumford mentioned a couple times in this chapter. I'm a big fan of his. I love his book, The City in History. And his architectural reviews, they're like, you know, lovably curmudgeonly|||在那个时候你确实有得选。我还想提一下，很高兴看到刘易斯·芒福德在这章中被提及好几次。我是他的超级粉丝。我喜欢他的书《城市发展史》（The City in History）。他的建筑评论，它们就像是，你知道的，那种讨人喜欢的顽固
in a way that I enjoy reading. And so like, you know, as people are recognizing that these roads are not like serving everybody, that they're not doing all they need to do, they're not really like an opposition movement that says like, build no roads. The sort of new thinking is, well, how about we build the roads, but in between that highway,
in a way that I enjoy reading. And so like, you know, as people are recognizing that these roads are not like serving everybody, that they're not doing all they need to do, they're not really like an opposition movement that says like, build no roads. The sort of new thinking is, well, how about we build the roads, but in between that highway,|||以一种我喜欢阅读的方式。所以就像，你知道的，当人们认识到这些道路并非在服务所有人，它们没有完成它们需要做的一切时，它们并不是真正像那种说“不要修路”的反对派运动。某种新思潮是，好吧，我们修路怎么样，但在那条高速公路中间，
we put a train because we're gonna do it anyway. And this is like the thing, this like theoretical notion. You know, I used to, you know, the blue line in Chicago goes along the 95 in between. And it sort of makes a ton of sense. You're clearing the road, there's a middle section, it's straight, you know, like let's put a train there. But this is not ever fly on Long Island.
we put a train because we're gonna do it anyway. And this is like the thing, this like theoretical notion. You know, I used to, you know, the blue line in Chicago goes along the 95 in between. And it sort of makes a ton of sense. You're clearing the road, there's a middle section, it's straight, you know, like let's put a train there. But this is not ever fly on Long Island.|||我们放一辆火车，因为反正我们也要建。这就像这件事，这种理论上的概念。你知道，我曾经，你知道，芝加哥的蓝线沿着95号公路中间穿行。这在很大程度上非常合理。你清理出道路，中间有一个部分，它是直的，你知道的，就像我们在那里放一辆火车。但这在长岛永远行不通。
No, it's true. Also in Los Angeles, there are train lines that go down the middle of freeways and they always look weird to me because I'm not used to seeing that from New York, but lots of cities have them. It's crazy. And the planners, the city planners say to Moses, look, we don't have the money to build
No, it's true. Also in Los Angeles, there are train lines that go down the middle of freeways and they always look weird to me because I'm not used to seeing that from New York, but lots of cities have them. It's crazy. And the planners, the city planners say to Moses, look, we don't have the money to build|||不，确实如此。同样在洛杉矶，也有穿行在高速公路中间的铁路线，它们在我看来总是很奇怪，因为我习惯了纽约的景象，但很多城市都有。这太疯狂了。规划者，城市规划者对摩西说，听着，我们没有钱去建造
these mass transit lines into Long Island that we'd like. It's a late 1940s. New York never has any money. America is flush with post-World War II money, but New York somehow is still, still has no money. The greatest city in the world that is always penniless, you know, always has its pockets hanging out
these mass transit lines into Long Island that we'd like. It's a late 1940s. New York never has any money. America is flush with post-World War II money, but New York somehow is still, still has no money. The greatest city in the world that is always penniless, you know, always has its pockets hanging out|||我们想要的通往长岛的公共交通线路。那是1940年代末。纽约从来没有钱。美国充斥着二战后的资金，但纽约不知为何依然、依然没有钱。世界上最伟大的城市却总是身无分文，你知道的，总是兜底朝天
because there's no, there's no money and just like little moths flying out of it. But they say, look, all you have to do to make it affordable in the future for us to build those lines is as you're planning the Long Island Expressway, just, yeah, get an extra 50 more feet of right away, leave a center island so that we can build rail down there eventually. And look, it's going to lower the cost of these eventual trains. It's going
because there's no, there's no money and just like little moths flying out of it. But they say, look, all you have to do to make it affordable in the future for us to build those lines is as you're planning the Long Island Expressway, just, yeah, get an extra 50 more feet of right away, leave a center island so that we can build rail down there eventually. And look, it's going to lower the cost of these eventual trains. It's going|||因为根本没有钱，就像有小飞蛾从里面飞出来一样。但他们说，听着，为了让我们将来能够负担得起建造这些线路的费用，你所要做的就是在规划长岛高速公路时，顺便，对，多留出50英尺的通行权，留出一个中央隔离带，以便我们最终可以在那里修建铁路。你看，这会降低未来这些火车的成本。这将会
to lessen the disruption of the construction because it's going to be right in the middle of the road with cars on either side rather than up against people's homes. It's going to prepare the city for future development. It'll be easy, it'll be inexpensive. Carol points out the cost for all this would be borne by the city and the state, not Moses, not Triborough. You don't need federal approval. If the city doesn't do it now,
to lessen the disruption of the construction because it's going to be right in the middle of the road with cars on either side rather than up against people's homes. It's going to prepare the city for future development. It'll be easy, it'll be inexpensive. Carol points out the cost for all this would be borne by the city and the state, not Moses, not Triborough. You don't need federal approval. If the city doesn't do it now,|||减少施工带来的干扰，因为它将直接位于道路正中央，两侧都有汽车，而不是紧挨着人们的家。这将为城市未来的发展做好准备。这很简单，也很便宜。卡罗指出，所有这些费用将由市和州承担，而不是摩西，也不是三区桥梁隧道管理局。你不需要联邦批准。如果城市现在不这样做，
you'll never be able to afford it. As you said, Roman Chicago is already doing something similar. There's literally, literally no reason at all not to do this. There is no reason not to do it, except the one reason that Moses has, which is I don't wanna do it.
you'll never be able to afford it. As you said, Roman Chicago is already doing something similar. There's literally, literally no reason at all not to do this. There is no reason not to do it, except the one reason that Moses has, which is I don't wanna do it.|||你将永远负担不起。正如你所说，罗曼，芝加哥已经在做类似的事情了。字面意义上，字面意义上完全没有任何理由不这样做。没有任何理由不这样做，除了摩西有一个理由，那就是我不想这么做。
And this is when he, Caro's got every now and then he'll introduce us to kind of like a new, what I would call a bureaucratic researcher hero. He has like his heroes who really get into research and paperwork. And he mentions F for Francis Dodd-McHugh, who's the chief of the Office of Master Planning of the City Planning Commission. And he draws up this
And this is when he, Caro's got every now and then he'll introduce us to kind of like a new, what I would call a bureaucratic researcher hero. He has like his heroes who really get into research and paperwork. And he mentions F for Francis Dodd-McHugh, who's the chief of the Office of Master Planning of the City Planning Commission. And he draws up this|||这就是当他——卡罗时不时会向我们介绍一种新的，我称之为官僚研究员英雄的角色。他有那种真正钻研研究和文书工作的英雄。他提到了弗朗西斯·多德-麦克休（Francis Dodd-McHugh），他是城市规划委员会总规划办公室的主任。他起草了这份
master plan for the New York airports, where he's looking at all these new roads that Moses is planning to build to go to like Idlewild Airport, which is now JFK. And he realizes that the roads Moses building, particularly the Van Wick, it's totally inadequate for the number of people who are gonna need to go to the airport. It's inadequate, especially considering there are people who are gonna use this road who aren't going to the airport. Let's not forget about them also, there's other people.
master plan for the New York airports, where he's looking at all these new roads that Moses is planning to build to go to like Idlewild Airport, which is now JFK. And he realizes that the roads building, particularly the Van Wick, it's totally inadequate for the number of people who are gonna need to go to the airport. It's inadequate, especially considering there are people who are gonna use this road who aren't going to the airport. Let's not forget about them also, there's other people.|||纽约机场的总规划，他在其中审视了摩西计划修建的所有通往诸如爱德华野机场（Idlewild Airport，现为肯尼迪机场）之类的新道路。他意识到摩西修建的道路，尤其是范威克高速公路，对于需要去机场的人数来说完全是不够的。这是不够的，特别是考虑到有些人使用这条路并不是去机场。我们也不要忘记他们，还有其他人。
And Moses like, I'll widen the roads, it'll be fine. That's not gonna be sufficient either. It's tens of thousands of people above what they're actually gonna be able to carry. And once people get to Idlewild, how are they gonna get around? Where are they gonna put their cars? How are they gonna get from the parking lot to the terminal?
And Moses like, I'll widen the roads, it'll be fine. That's not gonna be sufficient either. It's tens of thousands of people above what they're actually gonna be able to carry. And once people get to Idlewild, how are they gonna get around? Where are they gonna put their cars? How are they gonna get from the parking lot to the terminal?|||而摩西却说，我会拓宽道路，没问题的。那也将是不够的。这比它们实际能够承载的人数多出成千上万。一旦人们到了爱德华野，他们将如何四处走动？他们要把车停在哪里？他们将如何从停车场到达航站楼？
And McHugh says the only real solution is some kind of big rapid transit link. Similarly, where you'd carry more people faster, you run it down the middle of the road. And Caro at one point in this, he estimates that a rapid transit trip from Penn Station in the middle of Manhattan to Idlewild Airport would take 16 minutes,
And McHugh says the only real solution is some kind of big rapid transit link. Similarly, where you'd carry more people faster, you run it down the middle of the road. And Caro at one point in this, he estimates that a rapid transit trip from Penn Station in the middle of Manhattan to Idlewild Airport would take 16 minutes,|||麦克休说，唯一的真正解决方案是某种大型快速交通连接线。同样，如果你想更快地运送更多的人，你就把它建在道路中央。卡罗在此处的某处估计，从曼哈顿中部的宾夕法尼亚车站（Penn Station）到爱德华野机场的快速交通行程将花费16分钟，
would take six minutes, which blows my mind. I can't, that's one part where I'm like, I don't know about that, I don't know. Cause right now, if you want to get from Penn Station to the airport, which I've done many times, that's a long trip. Like you're gonna have to, at some point, you have to go from the subway to the air train,
would take six minutes, which blows my mind. I can't, that's one part where I'm like, I don't know about that, I don't know. Cause right now, if you want to get from Penn Station to the airport, which I've done many times, that's a long trip. Like you're gonna have to, at some point, you have to go from the subway to the air train,|||只需要六分钟，这让我大开眼界。我不能，那是让我觉得——我对此持保留态度，我不知道。因为现在，如果你想从宾州车站去机场——我已经去过很多次了，那是一段很长的旅程。比如你必须在某个时刻从地铁换乘机场快轨（air train），
or you have to, it's a, or you get to one of the shuttle buses. Anyway, you don't need to hear from me about how you get to the JFK airport, Penn Station, but it takes a long time. And Caro, he goes into all this detail about how relatively easy and inexpensive it would be to build those rapid transit links
或者你必须，或者你需要搭乘其中一辆穿梭巴士。总之，你不需要听我唠叨如何前往肯尼迪机场、宾州车站，但这确实需要很长时间。而卡罗花费了大量笔墨去详细描述，建造这些快速交通连接其实相对容易且成本不高
at this one point in history. While at the same time, you could use that opportunity to build a subway link between Brooklyn and Queens. He goes into a lot of detail about all this. It is such total fantasy catnip for me, certainly as a New Yorker. When I was first dating my wife, I lived in Astoria, Queens,
在历史上的这个特定时期。与此同时，你可以利用这个机会在布鲁克林和皇后区之间建造一条地铁连接。他对此进行了非常详细的描述。对于我来说，这绝对是完美的幻想大麻，尤其是作为一个纽约人。当我刚开始和妻子约会时，我住在皇后区的阿斯托里亚，
and she lived in Park Slope, Brooklyn. And the only way to get between the two was to take a train that went through Manhattan, and it took so much longer than it needed to. It's like, a couple other times later, we'll talk about points where Caro is talking about a thing that would have directly benefited my life when I lived in New York.
而她住在布鲁克林帕克坡。两地之间唯一的交通方式是乘坐穿过曼哈顿的火车，这比实际需要的时间长得多。这就像，在稍后的其他几次节目中，我们会谈到卡罗所提到的某些观点，如果当年在纽约生活时实现了，将会直接让我的生活受益。
And it's like you were saying, Roman earlier, that he's working on this scale, not just of geographic space, but chronological time, that he's saying this type of, this little bit of work now would in the future be so much more valuable and be worth so much more. And I tell you, Roman, I'm living proof of it, just the hours I wasted because this stuff didn't exist and McHugh says
就像你之前说的，罗曼，他在运作这种规模的事情时，不仅跨越了地理空间，还跨越了历史时间。他说，现在投入的一点点工作，在未来会变得更有价值，其意义也会大得多。我跟你说，罗曼，我就是活生生的例子，我浪费了那么多时间，仅仅是因为这些东西当年并不存在。而麦克休说
Even if we don't build these transit links now same story as with the Long Island Expressway We could reserve the land for less than two million dollars This is at a time when the city is pouring 280 million dollars into Expressway construction the money the city that has no money is spending nearly three hundred million dollars on Expressway construction And she goes if we don't spend that two million dollars now We're never gonna have the chance to do this rapid transit again. And he wants to put this proposal in his plan, but he makes a mistake.
即使我们现在不修建这些交通连接——这和长岛高速公路的故事如出一辙——我们也可以用不到两百万美元预留这些土地。当时正值市政府斥资2.8億美元用于高速公路建设，这座本就没钱的城市竟然砸了将近三亿美元在高速公路上。她接着说，如果我们现在不花那两百万美元，我们将永远错失再次修建这种快速交通的机会。他想把这个提议写进自己的规划中，但他犯了一个错误。
Roman, you know what that mistake is that McHugh makes? Well, I mean, he defies Robert Moses, but he also forgets that he is a civil servant. Yeah, so he mentions it to his boss, who mentions it to Moses, and McHugh gets yelled at, the mass transit proposal is slashed from the airport plan and his salary gets slashed to the minimum and he ends up resigning from his job.
罗曼，你知道麦克休犯的是什么错误吗？嗯，我的意思是，他公然挑衅罗伯特·摩西，但他也忘记了自己只是一名公务员。是的，所以他把这事告诉了他的上司，上司又告诉了摩西，结果麦克休挨了一通大骂，公共交通的提案被从机场规划中无情砍掉，他的薪水也被削减到最低，最后他只能辞职。
Like it is such unnecessary retaliation from Moses. And it's all part of this big, this refusal, this refusal to share any space or any money with mass transit that at certain points almost feels like an obsession, like how Batman has all those villains that are obsessed with a specific thing. Calendar Man is all about holidays,
这简直是摩西毫无必要的报复。而这一切都源于那种极大的拒绝——拒绝与公共交通分享任何空间或资金。在某些时刻，这甚至让人觉得近乎一种执念，就像蝙蝠侠的那些反派一样，每个人都对某件具体的事情着迷。日历人满脑子都是节日，
and Kite Man is all about kites, and Robert Moses is all about roads. He's the Highwayman. Yeah, Highwayman, yeah, yeah. And this is another one of those things where it's like, the way that an airport functions as a spoke in a transportation system, it really only makes sense if a train goes to it.
风筝人满脑子都是风筝，而罗伯特·摩西满脑子都是公路。他就是公路人。对，公路人，没错，没错。这也是其中一类事情：机场作为一个交通系统中的枢纽，它的运作方式其实只有在有火车通达时才真正说得通。
I mean, that's its peak functionality would be a train going there because taking a car and leaving it at the airport for two weeks, I mean, I do this all the time. I'm not saying like morally it's wrong necessarily. One, I'm gonna say two weeks. That's pretty nice vacation. That's pretty sweet.
我的意思是，它的巅峰功能性就应该是有一列火车开到那里，因为如果开车去并把车停在机场两个星期——我的意思是，我经常这么做。我并不是说从道德上讲这绝对是错的。首先，我要说的是两个星期。那可真是个不错的假期。那可真够惬意的。
Maybe a week, but. But you're right. It's a misuse of that infrastructure. For sure. And for no reason, for no reason at all. If you asked me, would you rather take a quick train to the airport and not have to worry about your car or even drive it there, I would say yes, 100,000%. That'd be fantastic.
也许一个星期吧，但是……但你说得对。这是对基础设施的滥用。肯定的。而且毫无理由，毫无道理。如果你问我，你愿不愿意坐一趟快车去机场，不用担心车子停放甚至不用自己开车去，我会说愿意，十万分愿意。那太棒了。
But it's shocking how many airports do not link to public transit in this country. That's a mistake, you know, done over and over again in the Bay Area. There have been sort of janky add-ons for, you know, a few decades, and then recently it's sort of like connected more smoothly, but it's just one of those things that if you really thought about it, you would,
但令人震惊的是，这个国家有多少机场竟然不与公共交通连接。这是一个错误，你知道的，在湾区一遍又一遍地发生。几十年来，那里有一些拼凑出来的简陋替代方案，而最近情况虽然有所改善，连接得更顺畅了些，但这绝对是那种只要你稍微动脑筋就会……
like if the FAA had the power, you know, like if they were building more airports with it, or not really, I would require it, you would, like, if the FAA had the power, you know, like if they're building more airports with or not, really, I would require it. You know, like I would require that there's a public transit link to an airport. It just makes so much sense. It's a little nuts that it is, in most cities, it is easier to get to a stadium than it is to get to an airport. You know, that it's, it's in New York, certainly it's easier to get to Yankee or stadium or city field than it is to get to the airport without using a car, at least in my experience. New Yorkers write me in, tell me if I'm wrong, if it's gotten harder to get to those
就像如果美国联邦航空管理局（FAA）拥有这种权力，你知道的，如果他们在建造更多机场时……或者说，其实不用，我会强制要求这样做，你知道的。我会要求机场必须有公共交通连接。这太合情合理了。在大多数城市，去体育场竟然比去机场还要容易，这简直有点荒谬。你知道的，在纽约，至少以我的经验来看，去洋基体育场或花旗球场，比起不用车去机场要容易得多。纽约的听众们可以写信告诉我，如果我错了，如果近年来去那些
stadiums in recent years. And Kara talks about, we had talked about this kind of, this for lack of a better word, ghettoization of certain city residents. And he talks about how opponents of Moses saw this as an inadvertent oversight, that he just didn't care enough to look into it. But Caro is again presenting it as a deliberate objective that he wants to keep specifically poor people, but also likely non-white people from Long Island. And that that's one of his interests in not having mass transit there. And he quotes a 1945 speech that Moses gives to the Nassau Bar Association, where he literally says, figure out what sort of people you want to attract into Nassau County. By that, I mean people of what standards, what income levels, and what capacity to contribute to the source of government.
体育场变得更加困难的话。卡罗提到——我们之前也讨论过这种——用一个不太恰当的词来形容——某些城市居民的“隔离化”。他谈到，摩西的反对者们曾认为这只是一种无意的疏忽，觉得他只是不够关心因而没有去深入研究。但卡罗再次指出，这是一个蓄意的目标，他希望把特定的人——主要是穷人，但也可能包括非白人——阻挡在长岛之外。这也是他不希望那里有公共交通的原因之一。他引用了摩西1945年对拿骚县律师协会的一次演讲，在演讲中摩西直言不讳地说道：弄清楚你们到底想把什么样的人吸引到拿骚县来。我的意思是，他们应该具备什么标准、什么收入水平，以及对政府税收有什么样的贡献能力。
Even if you strip that of all of the more recent kind of implications, he's still saying certain places are for certain people, and we need to build our infrastructure and arrange those places to attract only that certain type of people. We don't want those other kinds of people, which is pretty damning for a guy who is working in theory for a city and a state rather than for a constituency. Yeah, that's right. I mean, that's really, I don't know, but it's even, I don't think he has a quiet part to say out loud.
即便你剥离掉所有这些更为现代的言外之意，他依然是在公开宣称：某些地方只属于特定的人，我们必须建设基础设施并安排好这些地方，以便只吸引那种特定类型的人。我们不欢迎其他类型的人。对于一个理论上为整个城市和州服务，而不是为某个选区服务的人来说，这简直是 damning（罪证确凿）。是的，没错。我的意思是，这真的很……我不知道，但这甚至不需要他把那些“不该说的话”藏在心里。
There's always that phrase, he's saying the quiet part loud. But he just is this, it's just very, very clear what he is about, is about dividing this community up and really, again, just not serving the whole community. It really is. It's about funding all the resources towards the few people who have cars and those communities that they create
总有这样一句话：他把心里想说的话大声说了出来。但情况就是这样，他的意图非常非常清晰，他所做的一切就是为了分裂这个社区，说到底，就是拒绝服务整个社区。事实确实如此。他把所有的资源都倾斜给极少数拥有汽车的人以及他们创建的那些社区，
and really leaving behind all the rest of them and not just leaving behind a sort of neglect or even benevolent neglect. It's like it's true harm being done to them. It's awful, it's awful stuff. Yeah, and Carol then he goes in again to, he has a long section about how Moses's personality kind of insulates him from changing reality is from criticism and his confidence is never
而把其他人彻底抛在脑后。这不仅仅是一种漠视，甚至不是一种所谓的“善意的忽视”。这简直是对他们实实在在的伤害。这太糟糕了，太糟糕了。是的，接着卡罗又深入探讨了这一点——他有一大段篇幅讲述了摩西的个性如何使他免受现实变化的影响、免受批评的影响，他的自信从未
shaken because his power and arrogance keep him from learning anything that might shake it and how he's sure these roads will make his name immortal. He's like the builders of ancient Rome. And he has an article he writes about New York in the year 1999, where he's basically talking about how great his roads are and how they're, they're still going to be there. And I want to, we know this stuff about him. So I want to rush through to this amazing sentence that, that Carol has where she talks about within two weeks of its opening that Van Wyk Expressway, it's jammed with traffic. And I love this. Carol writes, traffic will flow freely. Moses had promised inappropriate adverb. And I love it. I think
动摇过，因为他的权力和傲慢使他无法接受任何可能动摇信念的东西。他确信这些道路会让他的名字永垂不朽。他就像古代罗马的建造者。他写过一篇关于1999年纽约的文章，在文中他基本上在夸耀自己的道路有多么伟大，它们将永远存在下去。我想……我们已经对他的这些为人有所了解了，所以我想要快进到卡罗写下的那句惊艳的话：范韦克高速公路通车仅仅两周内，车就已经堵得水泄不通了。我太喜欢这句话了。卡罗写道：交通将顺畅流动。摩西曾这样承诺。——一个极其不恰当的副词。我太喜欢了。我想
that's two words. And just as, as like, as a grammar teacher, just undercutting him, just like, I love that, I just love writing, just the way he writes, inappropriate adverb. Like, yeah, it's not moving freely. And I don't have to, I'm not gonna go into a lot of detail about that. It's so funny. There's so many points in this book, rereading it again where I'm like,
这只有两个词。作为一名语法老师，这句话简直是在拆他的台，太棒了，我就喜欢这种写法，就喜欢他这种文风——“一个极其不恰当的副词”。就像在说：得了吧，交通根本没有顺畅流动。我不需要对此展开过多阐述。太搞笑了。在这本书里，当我再次重读时，有很多地方都会让我觉得：
this is a funny book. You know, it's a sad book and it's a very dense book, but there's some very funny moments in it. And all this, like, the big problem is book. It's a sad book and it's a very dense book, but there's some very funny moments in it. And all this, like the big problem is him not thinking in terms of these systems is like, once you begin to build out and extend and connect all these roads,
这是一本很有趣的书。虽然它是一本悲伤的书，也是一本非常晦涩沉重的书，但里面确实有一些非常搞笑的时刻。而所有这些……就像这本书最大的问题在于，当他不从系统层面去思考时，一旦你开始建设、延伸并连接所有这些道路，
they all just get worse and worse and worse. Yeah. You know, like it really just doesn't, his ability to underestimate traffic and not understand the concept of induced demand and not really, you know, learn anything and update anything in his brain is just really destroying and creating a system that,
情况只会变得越来越糟糕。是的。你知道的，这真的是……他低估交通流量的能力、无法理解诱发需求（induced demand）的概念，以及无法真正地吸取教训并在脑海中更新观念，这实在是在毁坏一切，并且创造出一个
you know, just like a machinery that does not move anymore. And it seems that every one of his projects has the same exact problem. They all lead to greater congestion. They don't take congestion off of the pre-existing traffic arteries. And Caro, he gives us a lot of vehicle counts, travel times, lengths of traffic jams. This is a data mine. And these chapters, something Roman and I were talking about before recording, these chapters have a lot of information in them and a lot of
你知道的，就像一台再也无法运转的庞大机器。而且他的每一个项目似乎都有完全相同的问题。它们只会导致更严重的拥堵，根本无法分流原本就拥挤的交通动脉。卡罗为我们提供了大量的车辆统计数据、出行时间、交通拥堵的长度。这里简直是一个数据矿藏。而这些章节，正如罗曼和我在录制前讨论的那样，包含着大量的信息，以及许许多多
facts and figures that are not really fully necessary, it feels like at times, to make these arguments. But there's part of me that thinks that Carol is putting it in there just so it's somewhere, you know, that if it's not in this book, no one's ever going to know it. But it certainly is, at a certain point, you're like, well, yeah, I get it. The roads are really full. There's a lot of cars. He's already dead. Yeah. I mean, it has that quality of just piling on the details and I do think that, you have to imagine the book landing 1974,
似乎有时并非完全必要的、用来支撑这些论点的客观事实与数据。但我心里总觉得，卡罗把这些内容写进去，纯粹是为了让它们有个记录，你知道的，如果这些不写进书里，就永远不会有人知道了。但话又说回来，到了某个特定节点，你也会忍不住想：好吧，我懂了。道路真的很挤，车真的很多。反正他都已经死了。是的。我的意思是，这种不断堆砌细节的风格确实存在，而且我真的认为，你必须想象这本书在1974年出版时的情况，
Caro knows exactly what it takes, the sort of amount of shoe leather to get all this data and put it together into a cogent narrative. And he must be thinking, this is the document. There is no internet, there is no thing to look up. This is where it's going to be. It's going to get more and more scattered and lost over time.
卡罗非常清楚，要获取所有这些数据并将它们整理成一个有说服力的叙事，需要付出多少“跑腿”的辛苦。他当时一定在想：这就是最终的文献。那时候没有互联网，没有地方可以去搜寻。所有的记录都将在这里。随着时间的推移，这些信息只会越来越零散，最终彻底湮没。
And if he doesn't put it here, it will be gone. And I think this is a real kind of the choice of a historian versus the choice of just a pure storyteller in this moment. Yeah. Not like, I think Robert Caro is an unparalleled storyteller. I'm not meaning to disparage him at all, but this is sort of like the difference between making a movie of this versus making
如果他不把这些写下来，它们就会永远消失。我认为，这正是历史学家的抉择与纯粹的故事讲述者在这一刻的抉择之间的本质区别。是的。并不是说——我认为罗伯特·卡罗是一位无与伦比的故事讲述者，我绝无贬低他的意思——但这有点像拍一部电影和为历史撰写一份档案之间的区别。他在平衡这两种理念。
a document for history. He's balancing those notions. He is, and I think even more than that, I feel like it's a little bit like he is putting together a scientific argument. That the myth of Moses was so strong, he felt that he needed to marshal so much evidence to prove his point that at this point it's almost like he's writing a lab or a research paper, you know, to really prove, no, no, this, this evidence supports what I'm saying. And so there's a lot here that to a modern day reader where
他确实在平衡，而且我觉得更甚于此，这给我的感觉更像是他在构建一个科学论证。关于摩西的神话曾经是如此强大，以至于他觉得必须搜集大量的证据来证明自己的观点，以至于到了这个地步，他写的几乎就像是一篇实验室报告或研究论文，你知道的，为了真正证明：不，不，这些证据完全支持我的说法。因此，这里有许多内容对于现代读者来说——
I feel like everyone reading this book has already bought into the main premise by this point, you know, we have no lived experience of Robert Moses, we didn't grow up being told he's a he's an amazing man. And so it's so it feels at times like, oh, this is a lot. But I think you're right that, that Carol feels like this information needs to be out there, I need to tell it to people and it's nowhere. And if it's not here, it's never going to be anywhere. And it was just a huge burden to feel when you are a biographer, you know, when you're a history writer, this idea that, oh, well, I found this information and if I don't put it here, it's just going to disappear forever. And he's spoken about that, the feeling of horror of the idea like, if I don't get this into the book, no one's going to know it. You know, it's just going to, it's never going to reach people's awareness. Hey, though he's getting some help here because the newspapers, remember those newspapers we talked about? They've started printing stories again about traffic. It takes so long to get everywhere.
我觉得每一个读这本书的人到这时候都已经全盘接受了核心前提，你知道的，我们没有经历过罗伯特·摩西的时代，我们从小没有听着“他是一个了不起的人”长大。所以有时候会觉得：哇，这内容也太多了吧。但我觉得你是对的，卡罗觉得这些信息必须公之于众，他必须告诉人们，而且别无去处。如果这里没有，那就永远不会有了。作为一个传记作家、一个历史写作者，当你意识到“我发现了这些信息，如果我不把它写在这里，它就会永远消失”时，心中会有一种沉重的负担。他曾经谈到过这种恐惧感：如果我不把这些写进书里，谁都不会知道。你知道的，它将永远无法触及大众的认知。嘿，不过他在这里得到了一些帮助，因为报纸——还记得我们之前讨论过的那些报纸吗？它们又开始刊登关于交通的文章了。去哪儿都花太长时间。
This isn't the first time it's happened. Kara talks about how there's just this kind of like cycle each time there's a big traffic jam in the 20s, 30s, 40s, traffic is bad. Everyone gets mad about it. And then they sink into this kind of sullen, apathetic acceptance and he compares it explicitly to a lab rat getting used to electric shocks, which is such a horrifying way to think about urban life that it's just, you're just getting used to torture, you know, over time. And that there's this cycle that always ends in numbness. It goes from anger to numbness. And now we're back in that boom and bust cycle of outrage because people are back
这已经不是第一次发生了。卡罗谈到，这其实是一个循环：每当20年代、30年代、40年代发生大塞车时，交通状况就会变得糟糕透顶。每个人都为此勃然大怒。然后，人们又会陷入一种阴郁、冷漠的顺从状态。他甚至非常直白地将其比作实验室里的老鼠逐渐习惯了电击，这种形容城市生活的方式简直令人毛骨悚然——这意味着你只是在日复一日地习惯受虐，你知道的。而且这个循环总是以麻木告终。情绪从愤怒演变为麻木。现在，我们又回到了这种愤怒的“繁荣与萧条”循环中，因为在经历了战争期间几年没有车开的日子后，人们又重新回到了
on the roads after a couple of years during the war of not being on the roads. And traffic is new to them. The frustration of traffic is new to them. And to those of us living in 21st century America, I feel like this boom bust outrage cycle that ends with sullen numb acceptance feels very, like, unfortunately, very real. Very real and very uncomfortable, you know? It's sort of the template to the modern condition,
公路上。交通状况对他们来说是新鲜的，交通带来的沮丧感对他们来说也是新鲜的。对于我们这些生活在21世纪美国的现代人来说，我觉得这种以阴郁麻木的顺从告终的愤怒循环，实在是——不幸的是——显得太真实了。非常真实，也非常让人不舒服，对吧？这简直就是现代生活状况的某种模板，
for sure. Yeah. But what is very clear is even though more people are talking and writing about the fact that traffic is a problem and this sort of dependency on the car is a problem, it's still not getting through to the only man that it matters. Who would that man be?
毫无疑问。是的。但非常显而易见的是，尽管越来越多的人开始讨论并撰写关于交通是个问题、这种对汽车的依赖是个问题的事实，但这些声音依然无法传达给那个唯一真正有决定权的人。那个人会是谁呢？
Roman, who's that? That would be the elusive Robert Moses, who we haven't mentioned yet so far in the book. He is not changing his mind. There's nothing about it. In fact, it just kind of accelerates as much as possible. Yeah, and public awareness is slowly shifting and Tarot is looking at like the proportion of letters
罗曼，那人是谁？那当然就是那个至今还未在书中露过面的神龙见首不见尾的罗伯特·摩西。他根本没有改变心意。丝毫没有。事实上，他的计划反而在以最大可能的速度加速推进。是的，公众的意识在慢慢转变，卡罗在研究各大报纸上读者来信与社论的比例。
to the editor versus editorials in major newspapers. And he's saying, people experiencing this seem to be understanding it's a problem before the powers that be do, before the major kind of communication organs of the city. But like you said, it doesn't matter. Moses, does he just want to do anything? He fights all these proposals. There's one point where in 1952, state legislators, they suggest that a Triborough should take over the subways
他说，亲历这一切的民众似乎比当权者更早意识到这是一个问题，比城市的各大主要宣传机器更早意识到。但就像你说的，这根本没用。摩西压根不在乎，他要一意孤行吗？他反对所有这些提案。1952年曾发生过这样一件事：州议员们建议由三区桥梁隧道管理局接管地铁，
and use its surplus money to improve them. And Moses flies back from a vacation in the Virgin Islands to shut this down as quickly as possible. He goes, no, Triborough has no extra money. Mass transit's too expensive, we shouldn't do it. And there's just this lack of understanding at a basic foundational level. And I think maybe this is why Caro is marshaling so many facts and figures as this, to change that understanding of how necessary mass transit really is to make the city livable
并利用其盈余资金来改善地铁系统。结果摩西立刻从维尔京群岛的度假胜地飞回来，以最快速度把这件事给掐断了。他说：不，三区局没有多余的资金。公共交通太贵了，我们不该这么做。这种在根本基础层面上的缺乏理解，实在是……我想这也许就是为什么卡罗要罗列如此之多的事实和数据，以此来改变人们对公共交通真正重要性的认知——明白公共交通对于让城市保持宜居、以及明白公路到底是如何运作的，究竟有多么必要。
and how roads actually function. And he quotes this article from 1951 in the Herald Tribune. Again, like New York had so many newspapers, there's no Herald Tribune anymore. Like, come on. Talking about the traffic boom in good terms, as if bridges and roads were like companies that were experiencing this post-World War II, you know, 50s boom. And it says in it, business is booming, traffic is everywhere exceeding the experts' predictions. If the present volume keeps up, all the bridge bonds will be retired by 1957
他引用了1951年《先驱论坛报》上的一篇文章。话说回来，以前纽约有那么多报纸，现在已经没有《先驱论坛报》了。真是的。文章把交通热潮说成是件好事，仿佛桥梁和道路就像那些在二战后经历50年代经济腾飞的公司一样。文中写道：
and all tunnel bonds by 1963. Good work, gentlemen. And it's like, no, traffic is bad. Like to look at these public works as companies that are getting a lot of customers and that's gonna increase profits and therefore that we can pay off the bonds faster is such a basic misunderstanding of what's going on here.
商业正在蓬勃发展，交通流量到处都在超出专家的预测。如果目前的增长势头持续下去，所有的桥梁债券将在1957年之前全部还清，所有的隧道债券将在1963年之前还清。干得好，先生们。这就好比——不对，交通糟糕透顶啊。把这些公共工程看作是吸引了大量客户、从而能增加利润、进而让我们能更快还清债券的公司，这简直是对当前状况最基本的误解。
I totally agree. Even the notion of like, the subway system has to be net neutral, or has to make money. It's like, no, you can provide a surface, and it costs money. And that is just a thing we pay into all the time to make the city more livable.
我完全同意。甚至连“地铁系统必须收支平衡，或者必须盈利”这种观念也是如此。根本不对，你可以提供一项公共服务，而这需要花钱。这本就是我们一直在持续投入、以使城市更具宜居性的事情。
Like, running things as a business is the type of thinking that I'm just like, never on board for for. Like there's just some things that just that that's okay. Like we pay things that represent our values and they don't need to pay off. The post office doesn't need to make money. You know, like like subways don't need to make money. It's just like it's a crazy notion and it's like infected all parts of public life. It drives me mental. Yes, and it's not a new idea, but it's an idea that won't go away. I mean, I was just rewatching Robocop and that's entirely about why you shouldn't run a police department like it's a business. You know, there's this assumption that if something takes in some money, then it must need to pay for itself. And the idea of a free subway system,
把经营公共事务当成开公司一样来看待，这种思维方式我真的是……永远无法认同。有些事情，本来就是可以这样的。我们为体现我们价值观的事物付费，它们并不需要带来经济回报。邮局不需要盈利，你知道吗？地铁也不需要盈利。这简直是一个荒谬的观念，而且它已经侵蚀了公共生活的方方面面。这快把我逼疯了。是的，这并不是什么新想法，但这是一个阴魂不散的想法。我的意思是，我刚才在重温《机械战警》，那部电影整部讲的就是为什么你绝不能把警察局当成一家公司来运营。你知道，社会上总存在这样一种假设：如果某样东西能收进来一点钱，那它就必须实现自我造血、自负盈亏。至于免费地铁的概念——
which would be an astounding gift to all New Yorkers, it never enters into any thinking whatsoever. But this chapter, we're on the close this chapter. And we know that things, they can't get any worse, right? According to Robert Carroll, they can always get a little worse. Because as this chapter ends, Karo says, and in 1954, he took a further step, one that sealed the city's future. Bum, bum, bum. I added the bum, bum, bum.
这本可以是对所有纽约人的一份惊人厚礼——却从未进入过任何人的考虑范围。不过，这一章即将接近尾声。我们知道，情况绝不可能变得更糟了，对吧？但根据罗伯特·卡罗的说法，情况永远还可以变得更糟一点。因为在这一章的结尾，卡罗写道：“而在1954年，他采取了进一步的行动，这一举动彻底封死了这座城市的未来。”咚，咚，咚。——“咚，咚，咚”是我自己加的。
He didn't write that part. But it would be great if he did. You could send him some notes. That's all due. Yeah. For the new electronic edition that they just released. We will get to the bum, bum, bum after this. We will get to the bum bum bum after this.
他原文可没写这几个字。不过要是他真写了那就太棒了。你可以给他提点意见。就当是这样。为了他们刚刚发布的新电子版。我们稍后会讲到那个“咚，咚，咚”。我们会在那之后讲到“咚，咚，咚”。
Okay, now we're on chapter 40, Point of No Return. It really is what it says on the tin. He is, what he's doing is laying out this idea that his plans for Long Island and the Long Island Expressway really just dooms Long Island to what it's going to be. It's like it's going to be a traffic congestion nightmare with low density housing. I mean, he's really just setting it up. This whole chapter is about that. That's the real TLDR of this one. You're right. You basically said it, but he goes into much more detail on that, which we will too.
好了，现在我们进入第40章：不归路（Point of No Return）。这一章的内容正如其名。他所做的一切，就是阐明这样一个观点：他对长岛以及长岛高速公路的规划，彻底注定了长岛未来的命运——它注定要成为一个低密度住宅林立、交通拥堵的噩梦。我的意思是，他就是在亲手布下这个局。整章都在讲这件事。这就是本章真正的“太长不看版”（TLDR）。你说得对。你基本上已经概括了，但他在书中阐述了更多细节，我们接下来也会细讲。
As the chapter starts, we're back in the 50s now. Moses is being too successful. His authorities are bringing in way more money than his actual bridges and tunnels and roads cost to operate. He's pulling in $21 million in surplus a year. He can use that to capitalize bonds worth half a billion dollars. He's got so much more money that it risks getting the attention of the government, forcing him to use that money to bail out the subways
随着这一章的开始，时间回到了50年代。摩西此时实在是太成功了。他的各个管理局赚到的钱，远远超过了他实际建造的桥梁、隧道和道路的运营成本。他每年能带来2100万美元的财政盈余。他可以用这些钱来筹措价值高达五亿美元的债券资本。他的钱实在是太多了，以至于有招致政府注意的风险，从而迫使他不得不把这笔钱拿出来去营救濒临破产的地铁，
or retire his bonds. And if he does either of those things, he loses the potential capitalization money that having that money allows him to. So in order to keep making money, he's got to spend all his money. It's a real Brewster's Million situation that Bob Moses finds himself in here.
或者提前赎回他的债券。如果他做了这两件事中的任何一件，他就会失去拥有这些资金所带来的巨额资本筹措能力。因此，为了继续赚钱，他必须把所有的钱全都花光。鲍勃·摩西此时陷入了一种现实版的《布鲁斯特的百万横财》（Brewster's Millions）的困境中。
But the weird thing is that Robert Caro then almost immediately contradicts himself by saying also Moses construction plans were so huge that he didn't have enough money to fulfill them. He's got all these projects. He's going to build a New York Coliseum, the Throgs Neck Bridge, different expressways. He's got the Jamaica Bay Park. He's got all these enormous plans that he wants. So Robert Moses, the guy who has too much money, still needs to get more money,
但奇怪的是，罗伯特·卡罗随后几乎立刻又自相矛盾地指出，摩西的建设规划实在是太庞大了，以至于他根本没有足够的资金去全部实现它们。他手里有那么多的项目：他要建造纽约大都会展览馆（New York Coliseum）、瑟古斯颈桥（Throgs Neck Bridge）、各种高速公路。他还要建牙买加湾公园（Jamaica Bay Park）。他有无数宏伟的计划想要实施。所以，这个本该“钱多得花不完”的罗伯特·摩西，其实依然需要更多的资金，
and he's still looking for ways to get it. And as we've seen before, he's able to take advantage of federal programs like the lobbying for his roads to be included in the federal highway bill and things like that to get access to this money. And there's another organization that he's gonna need the help of. The only, he needs, if he's gonna get highway money
并且他一直在寻找筹钱的途径。正如我们之前所见，他能够利用联邦项目来谋取资金，比如通过游说将他的道路项目纳进联邦公路法案等等，以此来获取资金支持。此外，还有一个组织也是他必将寻求帮助的。如果他想要从联邦政府那里拿到公路资金，
from the federal government, he needs to build an interstate road. Unfortunately, due to the geography of New York, there's only one state he can really put it through. Yeah, and then he can, yeah, there's only one state he can enter, and that's New Jersey, my home state, which I'll admit is not as cool as New York.
他就必须修建一条州际公路。不幸的是，由于纽约的地理局限，他真正能把公路修过去的州只有一个。是的，然后他可以——是的，他只能进入一个州，那就是新泽西州，我的老家。我得承认，它确实没有纽约那么酷。
It's kind of like New York's little brother that like is like, hey, what about me? What about me? And New York's like, no. So I apologize to all the residents of Philadelphia who got mad at me last time. Cause reading this part, I was like, I could feel viscerally Moses' lack of interest in actually building a road into New Jersey.
它有点像纽约的小弟弟，总是一副“嘿，那我呢？那我呢？”的样子，而纽约则回应：“滚一边去。”所以我在这里要向所有上次对我生气的费城居民道个歉。因为读到这一部分时，我能切身感受到摩西对于在新泽西州修路是多么地缺乏兴趣，
And I understood it. Even being from there, I understood it. It's a great state, but still, it's not a romantic state that people desire to be in. A very true story from my life is that when my parents moved from New York City, the New York City area to New Jersey, and then my mom's brother, my uncle,
我完全理解他。哪怕我是个新泽西人，我也能理解。那是个好州，但它终究不是那种人们心驰神往的浪漫之地。我生活中有一个非常真实的经历：当我的父母从纽约市及其周边地区搬到新泽西时，我妈妈的兄弟、也就是我的舅舅，
also moved to New Jersey, my grandmother, who was a lifelong New Yorker, for years did not tell her friends that her children lived in New Jersey. Instead, she just would avoid the subject. Wow. Yeah. When you're in New York, New Jersey is...
也搬到了新泽西。结果我的外祖母，一个老纽约客，多年来一直不敢告诉她的朋友们她的孩子住在新泽西。相反，她总是刻意避开这个话题。哇。是的。当你身处纽约时，新泽西……
I mean, when you're in New Jersey, New York is the only place you want to be if you're in North Jersey. Don't even get me started on South Jersey. It's a different world down there. But if you're in New York, you have no interest in it. But if Moses is going to be able to build something in New Jersey, he needs to make nice with the port authority. That's right, there's another authority around, and they are bruisers. You know, as anyone who's been in Port Authority bus terminal can tell you,
我的意思是，如果你住在北泽西，当你在新泽西时，纽约就是你唯一想去的地方。南泽西就更别提了，那里的世界完全是另一番景象。但如果你身在纽约，你对新泽西是毫无兴趣的。不过，如果摩西想要在新泽西境内搞点建设，他就必须跟港务局（Port Authority）搞好关系。没错，当时还有另一个强力机构存在，而他们可都是些狠角色。正如任何去过港务局巴士总站的人所能告诉你的那样，
they do not have the finesse or the elegance of the Triborough Authority. So yeah, so he has to sort of mend fences there, which he always sort of butted heads. I mean, I can't remember the specific details of how the Port Authority and how Moses has tried to angle to take over more things from Port Authority at different times and then being thwarted by some other sort of schemer or another, but he has to figure it out. Yeah, they've been having turf battles all this time. It's a little bit like the scene of the being of the warriors when all the gangs are being brought together
他们可没有三区桥梁隧道管理局那种手腕和优雅。所以，是的，他必须去修补在那里的关系——他俩过去一直有点不对付。我的意思是，我记不清港务局与摩西之间那些具体的过节了，比如摩西曾在不同时期密谋从港务局手里抢夺更多的控制权，然后又被这样或那样的阴谋家给 thwart（阻挠）了，但他现在必须把这层关系理顺。是的，他们一直在进行地盘争夺战。这有点像电影《战士帮》（The Warriors）开场时的场景，当时所有的帮派都被召集到一起，
and Cyrus is like, we could work together and it's in the gangs in the end, it doesn't work out. They've got to mend those fences and that's because Port Authority has so much money on hands. They have the potential to capitalize $700 million worth of bonds, just an astonishing amount of money in the 1950s.
赛勒斯（Cyrus）说：“我们可以合作。”但最终帮派之间还是没能合作成。摩西和港务局必须修复关系，因为港务局手里握着巨额资金。他们有潜力筹措高达7亿美元的债券资本，这在50年代简直是一笔天文数字。
But Port Authority, it lacks Moses' greatest strength, which is not his ability to twist the law to do whatever he wants, not his shamelessness and refusal to be bound by ethics, but his vision. And Caro describes Port Authority as long on cash and short on dreams. All they ever think about building
但港务局也有个致命弱点，它缺乏摩西最强大的武器——不是那种为了达到目的而随意曲解法律的能力，也不是那种不知羞耻、拒绝受任何道德约束的作风，而是远见。卡罗将港务局形容为“现金充裕，梦想匮乏”。他们一心只想修建
is revenue producing stuff. They don't have the vision for a grand system. The kind of thing that can inspire say Albany to get behind a project in the way that Moses seems to so easily generate these dreams that people just flock to. And, uh, you know, Moses has those dreams, but his dreams only involve highways and bridges and cars. No. That's it.
那些能够产生产值的项目。他们没有构建宏大系统的宏图大略。那种能够激励奥尔巴尼全力支持某个项目的远见，正是摩西总能轻而易举地激发人们趋之若鹜的梦想。而且，你知道的，摩西确实拥有那些梦想，但他的梦想仅仅局限于高速公路、桥梁和汽车。没了。
In different configurations though. Sometimes it's a highway leading to a bridge, sometimes a bridge leading to a highway. But luckily, the port authorities are all on board for that. Yes, because they don't just have a shared need and the need to combine money with vision and political power. Because the other thing is that Moses had so much power in Albany. They also have a shared enemy, a common enemy between the two of them, that both Triborough and Port Authority are happy to stomp into the mud. And that enemy is trains.
不过只是换了不同的组合方式罢了。有时是一条通往桥梁的高速公路，有时是一座通往高速公路的桥梁。但幸运的是，港务局对这些完全举双手赞成。是的，因为他们不仅有着共同的需求——需要将资金与远见和政治权力结合起来。还有一个原因，那就是摩西在奥尔巴尼拥有巨大的权力。此外，他们俩还有一个共同的敌人，一个双方都乐于将其狠狠踩入泥潭的共同敌人。那个敌人就是——火车。
Yeah. No love of trains. They do not like trains. They love roads with tolls on them. They love traffic. They love tolls. Or not traffic necessarily, but they like having lots of cars going over their stuff. And so January of 1955, Tribor authority, Port authority, these two titans of roads and inconveniencing people, they released the joint study of arterial facilities that strangely enough recommends building the stuff that Moses wants to build. It's amazing. It turns out it's just the best way to do it.
没错，对火车毫无好感。他们讨厌火车。他们喜欢收费公路。他们喜欢交通拥堵。他们喜欢收过路费。或者说不一定是喜欢交通拥堵本身，但他们喜欢有大量的汽车从他们的设施上开过。于是，在1955年1月，三区局、港务局——这两家道路与制造出行不便的巨头——联合发布了一份名为《干线设施联合研究》的报告，非常“凑巧”的是，这份报告建议修建的正是摩西一直想要修建的东西。太神奇了。结果证明，这竟然是最佳的建设方案。
Lots of expressways, even the long threatened mid Manhattan elevated expressway, which we talked about before, which thankfully was never built. And Carol lists so many potential expressways all through the city reaching out to the suburbs. And he says, this is a business arrangement. Moses doesn't have the money to build these things. Port Authority has the money, but doesn't have the power. So for instance, the Verrazano narrows bridge, they come to this agreement.
大量的高速公路，甚至包括那个长期以来备受威胁的曼哈顿中区高架高速公路——我们之前讨论过，万幸的是这条路最终没有被建造出来。卡罗列举了数不清的潜在高速公路，它们纵横交错穿过整座城市，一直延伸到郊区。他说，这是一场商业交易。摩西没有资金来修建这些东西，港务局有钱但没有权力。因此，比如维拉赞诺海峡大桥（Verrazano-Narrows Bridge），他们达成了这样一项协议：
Port Authority will fund the bridge. Tribal Authority will lease it and control it. And at some point, they will buy it back from the Port Authority in the future. So Moses brilliantly, it's kind of hard to know the Port Authority in the future. So Moses, brilliantly, it's kind of hard to know what Port Authority is getting really out of this except for short term amount of tolls because he's convinced his rival to fund his own project. And when the bridges are built, both authorities are raking in huge amounts of money. I guess that is what they get out of it is the money. And Carol quotes Moses describing this bridge and there's such an
港务局出资修建大桥，三区局负责租赁并运营管理，并且在未来的某个时刻，三区局再将大桥从港务局手中买回。因此，摩西表现得极为高明——其实很难弄清楚港务局在这场交易中究竟得到了什么，除了短期的过路费收益之外——因为他成功说服了自己的竞争对手来为他自己的项目出资。当这些大桥建成后，两个管理局都赚得盆满钵满。我想，这确实就是他们从中得到的好处——金钱。卡罗引用了摩西对这座桥的描述，而他谈论此事时的语调中，有着一种极其
unfortunate modern parallel in the way he talks about it. I don't know if you'll be able to recognize the person that it reminds me of in the way Moses talks about this bridge. He goes, there's gonna be a bridge pretty soon, the bridge of my dreams. It's gonna be the most important single piece
令人悲哀的现代既视感。我不知道你们是否能从摩西谈论这座桥的方式中，听出它让我想起了哪位现实中的人物。他说：很快就会有一座桥拔地而起，这就是我梦寐以求的桥。它将是世界上
of arterial construction in the world. It will be the longest suspension bridge in the world and the tallest. It's all superlatives when you talk about this bridge. Like everything's the best that he does. Everything's best. Everything, you know, he, he just goes just short of calling it the most beautiful bridge in the world, which he said before about his stuff.
最重要的一段独立干线建筑。它将是世界上最长的悬索桥，也是最高的悬索桥。当他谈论这座桥时，满嘴都是最高级。仿佛他做的所有东西都是最好的。一切都是最好的。一切，你知道的，他——
Yeah. And, uh, Caro talks about how it's not just Triborough and Port Authority. Moses still has this alliance of people behind him also profit, namely number one among them, people who make cars, people who sell cars, people who make money repairing cars. He is the darling of the auto industry. We'll see in 1964, Moses is going to run the New York World's Fair and we'll see what a lack of success that is in some ways. And the automakers pour millions of dollars into that. But my favorite detail here is how in 1953, Moses enters and wins an essay contest
他甚至差一点就要称其为“世界上最美丽的桥”了——就像他以前形容自己的其他项目时那样。是的。卡罗谈到，这不仅仅是三区局和港务局的事。摩西的身后依然站着一个庞大的利益同盟，其中最核心的头号人物，就是那些制造汽车的人、销售汽车的人、以及通过修理汽车赚钱的人。他是整个汽车工业的宠儿。我们将看到，在1964年，摩西将负责操办纽约世界博览会，而从某些方面来看，那场博览会是多么地失败。但汽车制造商们为此倾注了数百万美元。不过我最喜欢的细节是，在1953年，摩西竟然参加并赢得了一场由通用汽车举办的作文比赛，
run by General Motors, and he wins a $25,000 prize. And it seems it's so funny to me, the idea of him entering a corporate essay contest. And I just imagine like some kid won second place and didn't get the $25,000, but Robert Moses walked away with it. And Carrow says, Moses is America's most vocal, effective, prestigious apologist for the automobile. He's just, he's so good at pushing cars. And the carmakers are just one of this regiment that he has that we've talked about before. Caro says, the joint program represented profit, profit from bonds, deposits, contracts, premiums,
并赢得了25000美元的奖金。一想到他去参加一个企业办的作文比赛，我就觉得滑稽极了。我脑海中甚至浮现出这样的画面：某个小孩得了第二名，错失了25000美元大奖，而罗伯特·摩西却大摇大摆地把奖金拿走了。卡罗写道：摩西是美国最大声、最有效、最具声望的汽车辩护士。他太擅长推销汽车了。汽车制造商只是他麾下的其中一个兵团，我们之前也讨论过。卡罗指出：这一联合计划代表着利润——来自债券、存款、合同、保费、
retainers, jobs, payoffs, bribes, Greece. It enlisted behind him all those forces in the city, banks, unions, contractors, venal politicians, venal or short-sighted public officials who put profit from public works above the public interest or the public trust. Like, look, if you've got a project that can make a lot of money, you'll have lots of people who are happy to be a part of it.
聘金、工作岗位、回扣、贿赂以及种种利益输送的利润。它将城市里所有的这些力量都集结到了他的身后：银行、工会、承包商、唯利是图的政客、或是那些将公共工程带来的私利置于公共利益或公众信任之上的短视公职人员。听着，如果你手里有一个能赚大钱的项目，你就会发现有大把的人乐意参与其中。
And Moses has that. And because he personally doesn't care about how much he takes in graft, as we've talked about before, he can spread it around and he can enforce loyalty if he has to. With that same old threat, if a local politician is like, maybe I don't want you to build this enormous road straight through my neighborhood, he can say, all right, then that project and all the money it represents will vanish and you just won't have it. And he institutes this kind of, I guess, informal policy where borough presidents,
而摩西正是这样的人。由于他个人并不在乎自己能从贪腐中捞到多少钱——正如我们之前讨论过的，他可以把这些资源四处分发，并在必要时强力维持忠诚。他握着那柄老掉牙的威胁之剑：如果某个地方政客说，“我可能不希望你把这条巨型公路直接修进我的社区”，他就会冷冷地回应：“好吧，那这个项目以及它所代表的所有资金将彻底化为乌有，你们什么也别想得到。”于是他建立起了一种——我猜是非正式的——政策：各区的区长们
they're allowed to publicly criticize Moses's plans, but in private, when they're actually voting on the board of estimate, they are not allowed to stop those plans. They don't veto those projects. They allow them to go through. And the result of this, as Caro says, is that the city would just go on building bridges,
可以公开批评摩西的规划，但在私底下，当他们在估价委员会（board of estimate）进行实际投票时，他们绝不被允许阻挠这些计划。他们不敢对这些项目行使否决权。他们只能眼睁睁地放任这些项目通过。正如卡罗所说，这样做的结果就是，这座城市将不断地建造桥梁，
it would go on building highways, and building basically nothing else. Yeah, yeah. And he spent some time talking about like what you could build with this much money. You know, that's a sort of like this amazing fantasy land of, of modernizing the Long Island railroad and also, you know, new tunnels to bring trains full of people from Manhattan to New Jersey.
不断地建造高速公路，除此之外基本上什么也不建。是的，是的。他花了一些时间讨论，如果你把这么多钱用在其他地方，究竟能建造出多么宏伟的工程。你知道的，这简直就像是一个美好的幻想乡：实现长岛铁路的现代化，或者修建新的隧道，把载满乘客的火车从曼哈顿直接开到新泽西去。
You could finish that second avenue subway, all this sort of stuff that's like, there's so much you could build with this amount of money. And even though that idea of there's like, there's not the old school style corruption in the system of him taking money, there's still the same impulse is causing a kind of internal corruption.
你甚至可以修完那条第二大道地铁，所有这些类似的项目——有这么一大笔资金，你本可以建造如此之多的设施。尽管系统里已经没有了那种老派的、个人贪腐拿钱的传统作风，但那种相同的内在冲动，依然在导致另一种形式的体制性腐败。
The fact that this set of public transit system just does not have the same financial upside in the end. Like the margins are different. It is more of a service that you're providing than a business that you are creating. And that is the core. That is like the cancer at the center of this decision making. Yes. The quantifiable metric that they're using to judge where things are worth doing is exactly how much revenue is it gonna bring in
这套公共交通系统最终在财务上确实没有同样的收益前景。就像利润率不同一样。与其说你是在创造一项商业，不如说你是在提供一种服务。这就是核心所在。这就是这场决策核心处的毒瘤。是的。他们用来衡量哪些事情值得去做的量化指标，正是它能带来多少收入，
for the people involved and not the metric of how much is this going to improve or assist the lives of the residents of the New York area. And I'll tell you, Roman, reading over this list of the things you could have done, I was like, that would have helped me, that would have helped me, that would have helped me. Like he specifically mentions extending the
而不是这能在多大程度上改善或协助纽约地区居民生活的指标。而且我告诉你，罗曼，读着你列出的这些本可以完成的事情，我当时想：那会对我有帮助，那会对我有帮助，那会对我有帮助。就像他具体提到把地铁延伸到米尔盆地，那是布鲁克林深处的一个地方，在进入长岛之前，那是你能到达的布鲁克林的尽头。而我想，是的，我和我妻子以及我们的朋友莎拉想去米尔盆地熟食店的那天我还记得。我们花了一整天坐公交和步行才走到这家熟食店吃午饭。就像他每次提到什么，我都觉得：对，那会对我有帮助。所以我可以告诉你，如果我们投资了这个幻想清单，而不是他们想要建造的项目，这会对我的生活带来切实的改善。卡罗说，他们本可以拿着这笔钱，把它们花在一个全新、现代的地铁系统上。在1955年，这两大机构凭借它们的权力和资金，
subway out to Mill Basin, far out in Brooklyn, as far as you can get Brooklyn Basin before you're in Long Island. And I'm like, yeah, I remember the day that my wife and I and our friend Sarah wanted to go to the Mill Basin deli. And it took the entire day on bus and on foot to get to this deli for lunch. Like, each time he's mentioning something, I'm like, yeah, that would have helped me. So I can tell you it would have made a measurable improvement in my life if we had had this fantasy list paid into rather than the projects that they wanted to make. And Kara says they could have taken this money and they could have spent it on an entirely new modern subway system. That these two authorities, with their power and their money in 1955,
本可以极大地改善该地区数百万人的生活。然而相反，几乎所有的钱都流向了汽车设施。他们花了大笔资金。在那个研究中提到的桥梁、隧道和高速公路上，他们就花费了7.55亿美元。而这还只是那份研究中提到的资金。这还仅仅是三桥和隧道管理局（Triborough）花费的资金。
could have so massively improved the life of the millions of people that live in the region. And instead, nearly all of it goes to car facilities. They spend so much money. They're spending $755 million on bridges, tunnels, and highways that were mentioned in that study. And that's just the money that were mentioned in that study. And that's just the money that Triborough is spending.
卡罗说，从1955年到1965年，有12亿美元的联邦和州资金投入到了那项联合研究中提到的高速公路建设中。在接下来的十年里，即1955年至1965年，他们修建了439英里的新高速公路，而铁路或地铁轨道的新建里程却为零。卡罗说，在1974年，纽约市内及其周边使用地铁和铁路的人们，依然坐着1904年至1933年之间铺设的轨道，那是罗伯特·摩西掌权之前的最后一年。
And Carro says from 1955 to 1965, there's $1.2 billion in federal and state money that goes into highways mentioned in that joint study. And over the next decade, from 1955 to 1965, they built 439 miles of new highway and they build zero new miles of railroad or subway track. And Carol says in 1974, people using subways and railroads in and around New York were still riding on tracks laid down between 1904 and 1933, the last year before Robert Moses came to
自那以后，连一英里都没有新建过。而现在，在随后的50年里，虽然修建了一些新英里数的轨道，但绝对不多。非常之少。是的。所以我们现在仍在纽约——我用“我们”就好像我还住在那里一样。我们仍然乘坐着在一百多年前、
power in the city. Not a single mile had been built since. And now it's in the 50 years since then, some new miles have been built, but certainly not. Not many. Very many. Yeah. And so we're still in New York and I say weird as if I still live there. We're still riding on, in tunnels that were built
甚至一百多年前建造的隧道里行驶的列车，几乎没有什么新的轨道和铁轨。你时常听到这样的故事：嗯，相关的机械设备如何都已经过时了之类的。当时本有一个转机，他说本可以把一切都改善，但他们就是没有做。这让我太生气了。
a hundred, more than a hundred years ago with very little new tracks and rails. And you hear all the time stories about, uh, how the, uh, the, the machinery involved is all out of date and things like that. And there was this moment he's saying when it all could have been improved and they just didn't do it. It makes me so mad.
抱歉，罗曼，我有点激动了。这真的让我太生气了。这些发生在70年前、60年前的事情，我至今仍然这么生气。而且部分原因是因为它确实在多年里实实在在地影响了我的生活。是的，火车抛锚，系统，切换系统都很陈旧，
I apologize, I'm getting all worked up, Roman. It makes me so mad. This stuff that happened 70 years ago, 60 years ago, I'm still so mad about it. And only partly because it affected me personally for years of my life. Yeah, the trains break down, the system, the switching systems are old.
罗伯特·肖（Robert Shaw）在左右劫掠。哦，你说得对。就在这本书出版的同年，你真的看到四个男人劫持了一辆地铁列车，这或许是有史以来最伟大的电影。我会说是的，我会这么认为。但接下来我们要进入的领域是——这也许我们可以精简一下——
Robert Shaw is robbing them right and left. Oh, you're right. The same year this book comes out, you've got literally four men hijack a subway train in maybe the greatest movie ever made. I'll say yes, I'll say it is. But here is where we get into the territory, and this is like maybe we could condense it,
卡罗列举了那些敢于乘火车或地铁出行的人们所遭受的种种屈辱。哦，那些不得不应对如地狱般炼狱般的铁路旅行的人们。我们可以在这里精简一下。因为首先，他谈到了地铁和长岛铁路，基本上是在谈论这些列车状况有多么糟糕，
where Caro gives the litany of indignities that befall people who dare to travel by train or subway. Oh, the people who have to deal with that hellish purgatory that is rail travel. We can condense it here. Because first, he talks about the subway and the Long Island Railroad, basically talking about how the trains are in bad condition,
它们总是抛锚，它们不可靠，有时它们根本就不出现，而且列车本身肮脏不堪。窗户破了。暖气和空调都不起作用。如果你想按时赶上火车去上班，你必须起得奇早无比，才能挤过那些排着队准备上车的人群。他还谈到了人们因为班次被取消或错过列车而愤怒到袭击工作人员的各种事件。
they break down all the time, they're unreliable, sometimes they just don't show up and the trains themselves are filthy. The windows are broken. The heating and the refrigeration doesn't work. And that if you want to get on a train to get to work in time, you have to show up incredibly early to get past the crowds of people who are going to build to get onto these trains. And he talks about, you know, different incidents where people get so mad at canceled trains or missed trains that they attack staff members.
他谈到了一列火车，一列长岛铁路的火车，人们坐在上面，它停在了轨道中间，于是人们走下车向它扔石头。他说，看到一列由另一列火车推着到达牙买加站（Jamaica）的火车已不再是什么新鲜事。还有一辆从巴比伦（Babylon）开往布鲁克林的列车连续102天没有运行。
He talks about one train where, one Long Island railroad train where people are on it, it stops in the middle of the tracks and people get out and throw rocks at it. He goes, it was no longer unusual to see a train arrive in Jamaica being pushed along by another train. And there's this train from Babylon to Brooklyn that doesn't run for 102 consecutive days.
它被称为“幽灵号”，因为当你去赶这趟车时，它就是不在。我们对地铁和长岛铁路的讨论有时会交替使用。它们是两条不同的铁路。但他基本上是用很多细节讲述了他自己的版本。在我看来，其中有很多精彩的内容，几乎达到了《疯狂杂志》（Mad Magazine）的水平，比如关于这些列车是多么令人作呕、
And it gets named the Phantom because when you show up, to take that train is just not there. And he, we're talking kind of interchangeably of the subway and the Long Island railroad. They're two different trains. But he's basically saying his version in a lot of details. There's a lot of great, it's almost Mad Magazine level, to me, like details about how disgusting
以及这些列车的状况多么荒谬的细节。但这几乎就像是他版本的古老卡茨基尔（Catskills）笑话，说这里的食物难吃，而且分量还这么少。就像火车糟糕透顶，你根本无法指望在需要它们时它们能准时出现。这是人们每天都必须经历的一种极其痛苦、在许多方面令人身心疲惫的体验。
and unreal how these trains are. But it's almost his version of the old Catskills joke about the food is terrible and such small portions. Like the trains are terrible and you can't rely on them to be there when you need them. It's such an uncomfortable, debilitating, in many ways, experience that people have to go through on a daily, daily basis.
但公共交通的关键在于，它能够良好运转的支柱是班次频繁且能把你送到你想去的地方。而一旦这些环节失效，其他一切也随之开始崩溃。你知道，比如资金不足以进行维护，接着就会发生故障，然后一切都变得越来越糟糕、越来越糟糕。这是一个深陷其中、极难自拔的厄运螺旋，除非你做出这样的决定：不，我们要这么做，因为我们必须这么做。
But that's the thing about mass transit is that the pillars of it functioning well are that it is frequent in it gets you to where you want to go. And as soon as those fail, everything else begins to fail afterward. You know, like then there is enough money to upkeep, then there's breakdown, and then everything becomes worse and worse and worse. It's a doom spiral that is just really, really hard to pull out of, unless you just make the decision of just like, no, we're going to do this because we need to do this.
这就像是，我们要去做这些事，因为它们很难。你知道吗？这就是它的本质。为了让公共交通发挥作用，你必须有可靠的服务。不幸的是，这不是高速公路所具有的弱点。当它们不可靠时，人们只是选择接受。
It's just like, it's going, we're gonna do these things because they are hard. You know? And that's just the nature of it. Like you have to have reliable service for mass transit to work. Unfortunately, this is not a weakness that highways have. When they are unreliable, people just accept it.
这个系统有一种奇怪的方式，能将这种故障包容为一种设计上的宽容。因为你可以换个时间再试一次，而且它确实会起作用，而且它有点像是偶发的。但公共交通有这样一个问题，那就是你一旦踏上轨道，它就只是——它只朝一个方向开。它有点像棘轮效应，人们只能逆来顺受，你知道，就像他对汽车的那种狂热，以及他这种，嗯，你知道的，对公共交通的这种整体偏见。
The system, it has a weird way of tolerating that type of failure affordance as a design. And because you could try it at another time, and it does work, and it's sort of sporadic. But mass transit has this problem of like you get on the track and then it just, it's going in one direction. It's a kind of a ratchet and it just suffers through this, you know, just like this mania that he has for cars and this, um, this, you know, just this whole bias against mass transit.
是的。在这一长段关于地铁和长岛铁路变得多么糟糕的论述结束时，卡罗谈到了这样一个观点：其中最糟糕的代价并不是人们发怒并引发“路怒症”时表现出的零星暴力，也不是发生在火车上的那些事故——因为火车本身维护不善，
Yeah. And, and Carol gets to at the end of this kind of long section about how crappy the subway has gotten and how crappy the Long Island railroad has gotten. He gets to this idea that the worst toll of it isn't seen in kind of sporadic violence that happens when people get mad and they get going to like train rage. And it's not, we're seen in the accidents that take place on the train because that the trains themselves are not Well maintained but in this general
而是通勤者们默默忍受的那种普遍的被动、无助和一种带有失败主义的妥协。他们只是生活在与往返于家和工作地点之间的日常出行相关的持续不适和精疲力竭的状态中，以及往返于家和工作地点之间的日常出行相关的持续不适和精疲力竭的状态中。在这段话中，卡罗多次用斜体重复了“习惯就好”（get used to it）这句话。而且他只在对某些事情感到分外痛心时才使用斜体，你知道的，或者只在他对某些事情感到格外愤怒时才使用。对于习惯了苦难这种想法，他简直感到震惊。他在斜体字中写道：我们学会了容忍不可容忍的状况。每当我读到这里，我都会觉得其背后蕴含着如此强烈的愤怒。
passivity and helplessness and kind of defeated giving in that the commuters just put up with that they just live in a state of constant discomfort and exhaustion related to the trip they have to take to get between their home and work every day and to the trip they have to take to get between their home and work every day. And a few times in this passage, Carrow repeats the phrase, get used to it, in italics. And he uses italics only when he is particularly grieved about things, you know, or only when he's particularly mad about things. And he's just appalled at the idea of getting used to misery. And he says in italics, we learn to tolerate intolerable conditions. And it feels like when I read it, there's such anger behind that.
不仅仅是对人们被这项服务冷落、生活因此变得更加困难这一事实的愤怒，而是这种将日常不适感标准化的做法，会让你变得麻木，感觉不到这些系统给你的人生带来的痛苦，最终也让你对生命本身的价值感到麻木。因为如果你每天都在经历这一切，也许你就会将其内化，并认为：
Not just at the idea that people are underserved by this, that it makes people's lives more difficult, but that there's this standardization of routine discomfort that numbs you to the pain that you're feeling in your life as a result of these systems, and also ultimately numbs you to the value of your life. Because if you're living through this every day, maybe you internalize it and you think,
也许我不配得到比这更好的东西。这不仅是在窃取人们的时间，不仅是在窃取人们的舒适，而且在非常真实的意义上，是在窃取他们对自身生活的信念，以及想象自己的生活可以比现在更好的能力。那种明天可以比今天更好的信念。
maybe I don't deserve more than that. And that it is not just stealing time from people, it's not just stealing comfort from people, but stealing in a very real sense, this kind of faith in their own lives and the ability to think of their own lives being better than they are. That sense that tomorrow can be better than today.
我对这段话做了相当多的过度解读，但我感觉这些内容大部分都在那里，大部分都在那里。对于人们必须迫使自己去适应不适感这件事，他显得非常非常愤怒。而这在关于交通的讨论中是我很少听到的。即使在今天，讨论也大多集中在速度有多快、效率有多高、会花多少钱上，却极少讨论乘坐这列火车或行驶在这条高速公路上的人类体验是什么——而这才是最重要的方面，因为这是其中关乎人的部分。
I'm reading quite a lot into it, but I feel like it's mostly there, mostly there. That he seems very, very angry at the idea of people having to acclimate themselves to discomfort. And that's something that I don't hear very much in discussions of transit. Even today, it's mostly about how fast, how efficient, how much money is this gonna cost, and very rarely about what is the human experience of riding on this train or riding on this highway, which is the most important aspect of it because it's the human part of it.
我们都是人。很抱歉打破各位的幻想，大家，我们都是人。所以对我来说，人的方面才是最重要的。老实说，这一系列事件都是由决定以那种方式修建长岛高速公路（LIE）的决定所启动的——没有把它作为一个宏伟的计划来构想，长岛高速公路造成了低密度，而这种低密度再也无法支持一条铁路，
And we're people. I hate to break it to you, everybody, but we're people. So the people aspect is the most important one to me. And truly this whole series of events is set in motion by the decision to do the Long Island Expressway the way it was, to not sort of think of it as a grand plan, that the Long Island Expressway creates a low density, that low density can no longer support a train
哪怕事后他们想要一条铁路也无济于事。事情就这样顺理成章地推进了。我的意思是，这才是所谓“不归路”的真正含义。是的，在对铁路进行了这种广泛的考察之后，他最终将镜头精确地对准了这一点。那是1955年，长岛高速公路项目，他提醒我们，长岛正如其名，是一个岛屿。
even if they wanted to have a train after the fact. It just continues like this was set into motion. I mean, this is really what the point of no return is about. Yes, he zeros in finally after this kind of wide ranging look at rails on exactly that. It's 1955, the Long Island Expressway, and he reminds us Long Island, as the name suggests, is an island.
就像你只能向一个方向开到一定程度，然后陆地就会停止并变成水域。唯一的出路就是反方向进入城市。不可避免地，这意味着如果你唯一的出行方式只有这条路，就会产生交通拥堵。如果你没有这种公共交通系统的话。与此同时，长岛的人口在不断地增长、增长、增长。这里不再是30年前（即20世纪20年代）摩西曾走过的田园牧歌般的开阔田野、富豪庄园和小农场了。这里变成了城郊蔓延区。它正在被填满。同样，卡罗又要引入统计数据
Like you can only go so far out in one direction before the land just stops and becomes water. The only way to go in the is the other direction into the city. And inevitably, that means congestion if all you have is this road to get there. And if you don't have this mass transit. And meanwhile, Long Island's population is growing and growing and growing. It's no longer the bucolic open fields and robber barren estates and small farms that Moses walked through 30 years ago in the 1920s. It's suburban sprawl. It's filling up. And again, Caro's going to get into statistics
和数字了。我们没必要纠结所有这些数据。他确实有一句台词：长岛的马铃薯地里将涌入一个相当于费城人口规模的群体，你看，我对费城说过很多话。作为一个衡量迁入长岛的人口数量的指标，它非常有用，而且这些道路根本无法应付如此庞大的交通流量。他说，试图通过修建高速公路来应对如此巨大流量的交通是根本说不通的。他审视了各种方案。好吧，摩西不打算修建铁路。
and numbers. We don't have to get into all those. He does have one line. He goes, onto Long Island's potato fields was going to be dumped a population the size of Philadelphia, which look, I said a lot of things about Philadelphia. It's very useful as a metric for the number of people moving into Long Island and just that there's no way these roads can ever handle it. And he says, attempting to handle traffic in such volumes by building highways just didn't make sense. And he looks at each thing. Okay, Moses is not going to build a train.
那么让公交车通行更顺畅呢？不，他也不想要这个。公交车是为失败者准备的，他说。他说公交车是为失败者准备的。他说，一旦长岛高速公路建成，一旦它落成，这种改变人口密度、让进出更方便、让出行更便捷的机会就永远消失了。如果你让汽车成为从这个地方通勤到城市的唯一方式，那么你就把这种发展模式永远锁定了下来，使其成为该地区的默认状态。他说：修建带有公共交通的长岛高速公路，或者至少为未来安装公共交通预留空间，长岛或许还能成为一个适合居住和玩乐的好地方。修建没有公共交通的长岛高速公路，长岛就会迷失，至少几十年内如此，
What about making it easier for buses to go through? No, he doesn't want that either. Buses are for losers. He says. He says buses are for losers. And he says once the LIE is in place, once it's built, this opportunity to change the density, to make it easier to get in and out, to make it easier to get around, is gone. If you make cars the only way to commute from this place to the city, then you lock in this development forever as just the default state of the region. And he says, build the Long Island Expressway with mass transit, or at least with provision for future installation of mass transit, and Long Island might remain a good place to live and play. Build the Long Island expressway without mass transit and Long Island would be lost, certainly for decades,
很可能几个世纪如此，甚至可能永远如此。这听起来有点夸张。确实有很多人住在长岛。罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）我想就在长岛有一个度假屋，比如夏季住宅或周末住宅。所以人们确实住在那里，但他们必须忍受这种糟糕透顶的交通，忍受这种进出城市的糟糕方式。是的。实际上，我在这段罗伯特·卡罗讨论的描述中所喜欢的一点是，当他在20世纪70年代初撰写此书时，这种观点具有某种超前性。尽管我对罗伯特·摩西“公交车是为失败者准备的”这种态度不以为然，但公交车其实是解决这些问题最伟大、
probably for centuries, possibly forever. Which sounds a little melodramatic. A lot of people do live in Long Island. Robert Carer, I think has a vacation place, has like a summer home or a weekend home in Long Island. So people do live there, but they have to put up with this abysmal traffic, this abysmal way of getting in and out to go to the city. Yeah. One of the things I actually like in this description that Robert Carr talks about is kind of ahead of its time when he's writing it in the early 1970s, is that despite what I put on the attitude of Robert Moses that buses are for losers, is that buses are kind of the greatest,
最具灵活性的方式。拥有一个专门供公交车使用的快速公交车道，是一种极其有效、低成本的方式，可以用来弥补人们在道路规划上犯下的许多错误。就像麦德林（Medellin）等其他城市一样，它们通过引入专用的公交车道，彻底革新了交通状况。
most flexible way to solve these problems. And to have like a rapid transit lane that's devoted to buses is extremely effective, low cost way to like unmake a lot of these mistakes that people made with roads, like other cities like Medellin, like they've just totally revolutionized traffic by putting in dedicated
他在这里将这个想法作为解决问题的一种良策提了出来。但这个想法最终却不了了之，因为罗伯特·摩西根本不相信这一点。不过我喜欢你能看出他在那个时期一直在关注刘易斯·芒福德（Lewis Mumford）。就像他意识到当时正在进行的这种思考一样。我觉得在通俗非虚构类书籍中，能如此超前地以这种方式探讨这些问题，是非常令人印象深刻的。我觉得它相当有远见。是的，我也这么觉得。有一件事——我们稍后会讨论桥梁和公交车，因为我们即将触及本书中
bus lanes. And he kind of presents that as an idea here as a way to be the remedy for this. But it just goes nowhere because Robert Moses just doesn't believe in it. But I love, you can tell that he is paying attention to Louis Mumford in this time. Like he's aware of this, the thinking that's going on. And it strikes me as being very early in, you know, kind of a popular nonfiction book to be talking about this in these ways. I find it pretty prescient. Yeah. I think so too. One thing that is, and we'll talk about bridges and buses in a moment because we're about to get to one of the
更具争议的部分之一。但有一件事我一直在想，这也是卡罗当时不可能未卜先知的事情，但我今天一直在思考：我好奇这些章节在今天读起来是否会有所不同，我好奇现在的体验是否有所不同。在我们今天生活的世界里，远程工作（或者至少是部分时间远程工作）的选择已经成为人们生活的一部分，而罗伯特·卡罗却把“你有一份工作，你需要去上班”视为理所当然，所以如果你住在长岛，你很可能就要通勤去曼哈顿
more controversial parts of it. But one thing that I wonder, and this is something Carol could not have been prescient about, but I was thinking about today is I wonder if these sections read a little differently and I wonder if the experience is a little different now. In the world we live in now where the option of remote work or at least part-time remote work is a thing that people are living with, that Robert Carrow is taking it as such a given that you have a job, you need to go to that job And so if you live in Long Island, you're probably commuting to Manhattan We're somewhere in the New York area and you cannot get out of it. And I wonder if that is in some way
或纽约地区的某个地方，并且你无法摆脱这种通勤。我在想，这是否在某种程度上稍微缓解了一些情况？可能没有达到所需的规模——长岛高速公路上的交通依然荒谬绝伦——但我很好奇，对于一个年轻人来说，这些章节读起来是否会有所不同。他们会想：“为什么我非得去公司上班呢？为什么我不能在家工作呢？”当然，在1974年，当然还有1955年长岛高速公路建成时，这是不可能的。你根本做不到这一点。我的意思是，它向我指出的一点是，
Alleviating things a little bit probably not at the scale necessary like the traffic on the LA is still ridiculous But I wonder if that if these sections read differently to a younger person who is like, well, why do I have to go in to my job? Why can't I do it from home? Which of course in 1974 and certainly in 1955 when the LIE was built was impossible. You could not do that. I mean, what it points out to me
我会把这种逻辑倒过来，基本上会说：鉴于今天工作的灵活性或更高的灵活性，这更清楚地表明，在1955年做出这些选择是一个多么糟糕的决定。长岛上可能确实有更多的人在附近工作或在家工作，比起当年要多。
is I would sort of like flip that and say essentially like, given the flexibility of work or the greater flexibility of work today, it really points out how it was an even worse decision in 1955 to make these choices. And that there probably is a greater spread of people on Long Island just working nearby or working at home than there was then.
但这也恰恰说明了摩西在整个议题、整个问题上戴着多么厚重的有色眼镜。是的，因为在1955年，你无法打电话说：“老板，我今天要在家里工作。”对方会问：“怎么工作？所有的文件都在这里。”我的意思是，当时长岛唯一在家工作的人大概只有漫画家了。而且他们仍然不得不开车把他们的美术作品送到编辑手里，你知道的。而且，当然，这里的情况和我们之前讨论过的一样。你现在根本不需要修建轨道。
But that just goes to show the degree in which Moses had blinders on about the sort of whole issue, the whole problem. Yeah, because you can't, in 1955, you can't call and be like, boss, I'm going to work from home today. And be like, how? All the paper is here. Like, there's no, I think the only people working from home in Long Island at the time were comic book artists. And they still had to drive in with their art to hand it into the editor, you know. The, and of course, it's the same story here that we talked about before. You don't have to build the tracks right now.
只需要在马路中间留出那个空间，我们以后就可以建轨道了，但他就是不想这么做。即便那项研究显示——甚至是在为了迁就摩西而把修建铁轨的设想置于最不利的角度进行评估后——研究依然表明这样做会便宜得多、高效得多、有效得多，但摩西就是不想这么做。于是他直接开始施工了。等到关于铁路线的大型提案最终敲定时，提案不得不这样写：我们自己的提案已经过时了，因为道路建设已经超前太多，做什么都来不及了，而且这在报纸上根本没有引起任何注意。在道路开工建设之前，任何人考虑过这样做的想法被轻而易举地埋葬了。
Just leave that space in the middle of the road, and we can build the tracks later, and he just doesn't want to do it. And the study that like shows even bending over backwards for Moses to put rails in the worst possible light, the study still shows just how much cheaper and more efficient, more effective it would be, but Moses just doesn't want to do it. So he just starts building. And by the time that the big proposal for a rail line is finished, the proposal has to say, our own proposal is obsolete because the road is already too far ahead to do anything, doesn't matter, and this gets no mention in the newspapers. It's so easily buried, the idea that anybody considered doing this before the road started being built.
是的，这正是他惯用的“既成事实”的绝招。在任何人提出批评之前，在任何事情付诸行动之前，官僚系统的运转如此缓慢，以至于他已经开始动工了，因此，这就成了一个既成事实。此时此刻，你根本不可能再铺设一条铁路线了。再次说明，这种思维方式，
Yeah, it's the classic steak driving move that he does. Before he can sort of respond to any criticism, before anything can be done, the system is working so slowly that he just starts building things, and therefore, it's a fait accompli. There's no way that you can actually put in a railroad at this point. And again, this is like the thinking of this,
每当我想到所有那些本可以让你的生活变得更好的潜在地铁和铁路线时，就会让我感到无比愤怒。就像我想的那样，你知道的，如果回过头来思考，哦，整个高速公路系统——如果在每条道路的分隔带中间都铺设一条铁路线会怎样？
it sort of gets me sort of incensed the way when you think about all those potential subways and rail lines that could have made your life better. Like I think about this, you know, like if going back and thinking about, oh, the entire highway system, like what if they just put a rail line between every median?
就像，你知道的，如果他们那样做了呢？我们今天能拥有什么？这太合乎逻辑了。我不知道我是否真的这样想过：从宏观上考虑，让每条道路旁边都有一条列车线路，将是一项惊人的成就。我们现在本可以过上一种完全不同的生活。
Like, you know, what if they did that? What could we have today? It makes so much sense. And I don't know if I've ever really thought about it that way that you could, in a widespread way, think about every road is having a train line next to it would be kind of a stunning achievement. We would be able to have a totally different life now.
那将是太棒了。罗曼，别说了，对于卡罗在书中提到那些未能建成的设施，我已经够难过的了。别再提那些会让生活变得更好、更轻松却偏偏没有的更宏大的事物了。那将彻底改变整个国家的性质，而且会以一种非常惊人的方式实现。
It would be amazing. Roman, don't, I'm already sad enough about the stuff that didn't get built that Carol mentions in the book. Don't mention even bigger things that would make life even better and easier that we don't have. It would just change the nature of the whole country and in these ways that would be really amazing.
而且这本来会是如此简单和廉价。就像，缺乏这种前瞻性思维简直让我大开眼界。我的意思是，唯一的争论大概就是你所描述的那种情况。这在技术上虽然不是社会主义，但听起来已经足够接近了，让我感到有些不舒服。所以，不，但你是对的。
And it would have been so easy and cheap. Like it just like the lack of forward thinking about that is kind of blows my mind. I mean, I guess the only argument is what you're describing. It's not technically socialism, but it sounds close enough to it that it's making me uncomfortable. So, no, but you're right.
这本会——我的意思是，这一切归根结底都在于，我认为卡罗在书中对此有极其深刻的认识：所有关于我们生活方式的决定其实都是决定。它们全都是选择，没有哪个是不可避免的。如果你有一个具备足够前瞻性思维的人，你就可以做出惊人的选择和决定，最终你就会得到像琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）那样原本不会存在的东西。
It would have been, it just, I mean, it all comes down to, I think, that one of the things that I think Caro is so aware of in this, that all decisions made about the way we live are decisions. They're all choices and none of them are inevitable. And if you have someone who's sufficiently forward thinking, you can make amazing choices and decisions and you end up with something like Jones Beach that otherwise wouldn't exist.
而如果你有一个目光长远但却做出糟糕选择和决定的人，那么你就会得到一条连一根铁轨都没有的长岛高速公路。我很遗憾，罗曼，我很遗憾要向你剧透这一点，但它一开通就几乎立刻陷入了拥堵。正如卡罗引用司机们的话称其为“世界最长的停车场”那样，年复一年皆是如此。是的，摩西的解决方案——你猜对了，把它修得更大。
And if you have someone who is very far seeking but is making bad choices and decisions, then you get the Long Island Expressway with no trains on it at all, which I hate to, I hate to spoil this for you, Roman, but it opens up and it is almost instantly congested. And just year after year is, is Carol Quote's drivers calling it the world's longest parking lot. Yeah. Moses solution, you guessed it, make it bigger. And that, which makes it even worse because now while they're finishing the later stages
而这让情况变得更糟，因为当他们正在收尾长岛高速公路后期工程的同时，他们又在重建长岛高速公路的前期工程以拓宽路面。而这种建设工作只会进一步加剧交通拥堵。卡罗在1974年撰写这本书时表示，当时仍有将长岛高速公路一直拓宽到世纪末的计划。
of the LIE, they are rebuilding the later stages of the LIE, they are rebuilding the earlier stages of it to make them wider. And that construction work only adds to the amount of traffic. And Carol says in 1974, when he was writing this book, there are still plans to widen the Long Island Expressway that will stretch out to the end of the century.
我不知道他们——我假设他们某个时候完成了，但我不知道，也许他们没有完成。也许这就像博尔赫斯（Borges）小说里那种情节：一旦他们完工，他们就会马上重新开始翻修，你知道的。谁知道这到底还是不是原来的那条路？
And I don't know if they, I assume they finished at some point, but I don't, maybe they didn't. Maybe it's one of those things like in a Borges story where as soon as they're done with it, they just start rebuilding it again, you know. Who knows if it's the same road anymore? Yeah, yeah, it's crazy. And, you know, he's describing it like you said, there's this island, it's an island with a choke point. And by the time you get to the, you extend it out to the east, the west is insufficient to do the job. And so they just keep building it, widen it again.
是的，是的，这太疯狂了。而且，你知道的，正如你所说，他在描述这样一个地方：这是一个岛屿，一个拥有交通瓶颈的岛屿。当你把它向东延伸时，西边的道路已经无法胜任这项工作了。于是他们只能不断修建、再次拓宽。
And it's just one of those things that is just, again, really, really upsetting. Like this is the thing that he can somehow wrap his mind around changing or improving, but he can't conceive of a world in which, when you improved it, you could just make a place for a rail line or make the overpasses taller, which gets us to one of the major talking points when it comes to this book, which is the height of the underpasses
这就是那些再次让人感到——真的非常非常沮丧的事情之一。这就是他不知为何能够将其纳入自己改变或改善范畴的事情，但他却无法想象这样一个世界：当你在改善交通时，你完全可以顺便为一个铁路线留出空间，或者把立交桥修建得更高一些——这就把我们带到了本书的几个主要争论点之一，那就是立交桥的高度，
like where cars are going through, the bridge is going over them, they are not very tall. They're not tall enough specifically for buses to go under them on any outer lanes. Yes. And a bus can go, technically a bus can go through the center lanes, but as Carol says, any bus line manager is not going to send their buses down a highway where there's only one lane basically that they can use in each direction. What if the bus breaks down? What if there's a lot of traffic? They've got to keep up a schedule. And there's been a ton of argument one way or the other about whether this height for bridge was standard practice at the time, whether it's unfair to accuse Moses of deliberately keeping buses off, whether it's unfair to read a racial element to that or a class element to that.
即汽车穿行、桥梁从其上方跨过的地方，它们建得不够高。具体来说，它们的净空高度不足以让任何外侧车道的公交车从下方通过。是的。从技术上讲，公交车可以通过中央车道，但正如卡罗所说，任何公交公司经理都不会把他们的公交车派往这样一条高速公路上：在这里，基本上每个方向只有一条车道是他们可以使用的。如果公交车抛锚了怎么办？如果交通非常拥堵怎么办？他们必须维持时刻表。关于这种桥梁高度在当时是否属于标准做法、指责摩西故意将公交车挡在外面是否不公、或者从中解读出种族或阶层因素是否不公，各方一直存在着大量的争论。
And it's always surprised me the controversy of it because in that section, Carol literally quotes Sid Shapiro, Moses right- man saying, yeah, we kept the bridges too low so that buses couldn't go through and kind of reminiscing in a happy way about the few buses that tried and had their roofs smashed in, you know, or he touched out one where the top was rolled back like a can of sardines. And it's like, I don't know, if you got it straight from the guy who was working with Moses, then it seems like whether other people in other places were doing that, I feel like that's all you need. That's as close as you're going to get to Moses saying, yeah, this is why I did it.
这场争议总是让我感到惊讶，因为在那一章节中，卡罗字面意义上地引用了摩西的得力助手西德·夏皮罗（Sid Shapiro）的话，对方说：“是的，我们把桥建得很低，这样公交车就开不过去了”，并且带着愉快的心情回忆起那些试图通行却被削掉车顶的少数公交车，你知道的，或者他提到了一辆车顶像沙丁鱼罐头一样被卷起来的公交车。这让我觉得，如果你直接从这个与摩西共事的人口中听到这些，那么无论其他地方的其他人在做什么，我觉得这就是你需要的一切。这就是你所能找到的最接近摩西亲口承认“是的，这就是我这么做的原因”的证据了。
Yeah. And him, you know, like sort of being very, very clear about using the roads as a way to sort of gatekeep people from being in different places. He's very explicit about that as a motivation for him when he builds things and when he's talking to like the Nassau County officials, you know? And so to have it expressed in that way, like his intent, he always had this part of his sort of intention
是的。而且他——你知道的——非常非常明确地表达了利用道路作为一种把人们隔离在不同地方的守门工具的想法。他在构建事物时，以及在与拿骚县（Nassau County）官员交谈时，总是非常明确地将这作为他的动机，你知道吗？因此，当以这种方式表达出来时，这就是他的意图——他建造事物时始终带有这种意图的一部分。让西德·夏皮罗谈论这件事，让他们在后来重建时稍微做些改变——也许有些桥梁确实增加了一些高度，让后来的立交桥变得高了一点，你知道的——但即便如此，我还是不明白。就像，我不明白这里到底有什么灰色地带可以用来制造某种怀疑。我不知道。
when he built things to have Sid Shapiro talk about it, to have them like change a little bit, maybe when they get rebuilt, you know, there's like some increase in some of them to get a little taller for later, you know, overpasses, but like it's, I don't get it. Like, like, like I don't get what sort of daylight there is here to sort of create a kind of doubt. I don't get what sort of daylight there is here to sort of create a kind of doubt. I don't know.
我在想，这是否只是一种人类天生就喜欢挑刺的需要：这本书里包含了如此多的主张和如此多的佐证，以至于人们渴望找到哪怕一点感觉可以说“嗯，这不是真的”的东西。然后把这当作一根线头，
I wonder if it's just a human need to kind of poke holes in things, that there's so much that's claimed by this book and so much that's backed up, to be able to find something that feels like you could say, mm, this is not true. And then to use that as the loose thread
试图把它抽出来，以此拆解其余的所有内容。但我不知道，这是那些我从未完全理解的争论之一：为什么要反对相信西德·夏皮罗的原话，以及相信卡罗关于西德·夏皮罗说过这话的记录？所以很奇怪，这竟然成了最具争议的部分之一，
that you're gonna pull out and unravel the rest with. But I don't know, it's one of those things that I've never quite understood the arguments against taking Sid Shapiro at his word and taking Caro at his word that Sid Shapiro said this thing. And so it's strange that this is one of the controversial parts,
不过我猜人们对桥梁确实情绪激动。也许他们对桥梁净空高度非常敏感。我觉得人们的反应其实是在反弹那种被过度简化、坍缩后的叙事，即“摩西不希望黑人去琼斯海滩，所以故意把桥修建得太矮以至于公交车无法通行”。然后人们就会反驳：“但是当时确实有公交线路——”
but people get very agitated about bridges, I guess. Maybe they feel very sensitive about bridge heights. I feel like what people are reacting to is the collapsing of the narrative of Moses didn't want black people at Jones Beach and therefore made the bridges too short for buses. And then people go, but there were bus lines that kind of made it go, but there were bus lines
“——曾经到达过那里，只不过它们规模不大。”这有点像：“是的，但琼斯海滩确实有一个专门的黑人区域。”他们反驳的，我认为正是那种被简化、在营火晚间流传的版本。
that kind of made it there, but they weren't very extensive. And it's kind of like, yeah, but there was a black section of Jones Beach. And like, but what they're arguing against, I think is that collapsed version, you know, told, you know, like around a campfire. The shorthand. Yeah, around the campfire.
那种简化的说法。是的，在营火晚会上。最吓人的故事往往都是在基础设施营地里讲的。
Yeah, and the scariest story is told at infrastructure camp. Yeah. And I think that's what they're reacting to and mainly trying to, in their way, they're trying to add nuance to that narrative that feels too collapsed and too simple. But I think that when you take in the book as a whole and the section as a whole,
是的，我认为这正是他们的反应所在，他们主要是想以自己的方式为那种感觉过于单一和简化的叙事增添细微的差别。但我认为，当你把整本书和这一章节作为一个整体来审视时，
it just has so much support in it. And even if there are other bridges and other things that are low and they weren't forward thinking in the same way, it was clear that they were taking advantage of that convention to still get these same ends. So I think that's kind of where it lands. It just is really about people objecting
其中有着如此之多的事实支撑。即便还有其他桥梁和其他高度较低、同样缺乏前瞻性思维的建筑，但很显然，他们当时确实在利用这种惯例来达到同样的目的。所以我想这才是问题的落脚点。人们反对的其实是
to the shorthand version of this rather than what's actually written. And what's actually written is like a quote from Sid Shapiro, like laughing about it. Like it's hard to argue that. Yeah, to me it's just funny that this is one of the big things that people go after in the book. It feels a little bit like in online debates,
这种简化的说法，而不是实际写在书中的内容。而书中的实际内容正是引用了西德·夏皮罗的话——甚至带着嘲笑的意味。这真的很难反驳。是的，在我看来，滑稽的是这竟然成了人们攻击这本书的重头戏之一。这有点像我们在网络辩论中看到的情形：
you'll see someone refer to an AR-15 as an assault rifle and somebody will say, that's not what the AR stands for, you don't even know what you're talking about. It's like, you're right, I got the initials wrong on that. Therefore, people don't get hurt with guns, you're right. They're wonderful, because I didn't know the terminology properly,
你会看到有人把AR-15称为“突击步枪”（assault rifle），然后就会有人跳出来说：“AR根本不是那个意思，你根本不知道自己在说什么。”这就像是在说：“没错，我确实把首字母缩写搞错了。因此，人们不会在枪支暴力中受到伤害，你是对的。这些枪太棒了，因为我不懂专业术语，
you beat me. And somehow arguing that this doesn't, this is just like a little star in the constellation of what Robert Moses did. And it fits as part of that completely. Like it is not a deviation from the rest of his patterns and behavior. It's really right there. And so again, it's like picking it out as its own thing is strange to me because all of this short-sighted thinking, all of this classism, all of this like non-system thinking and not caring about how these pieces fit together and serve a whole community is just,
你把我击败了。”不知何故，争辩说这不属于罗伯特·摩西所作所为星系中的一颗星，这种观点是荒谬的。它完全构成了他行为模式和行为轨迹的一部分。这绝对不是对他的其他模式和行为的偏离，它就明摆在那里。所以再次强调，将其单拎出来作为异类去批判让我觉得很奇怪，因为这种短视的思维、这种阶级主义、这种缺乏系统性的思考，以及不关心这些碎片如何组合并服务于整个社区的做法，
is a part of his whole career for decades and decades. And so if it was somehow a deviation, is a part of his whole career for decades and decades. And so if it was somehow a deviation, then it seems like it's sort of more right for criticism, but it really just sort of fits in with everything else. Yeah, like you're saying, it fits with Moses' desires, his preferences, like his overall themes. And what Caro is basically saying at the end of this chapter is that he has had the foresight
恰恰贯穿了他长达几十年的整个职业生涯。所以，如果这在某种程度上算是一种偏离的话，那它似乎才更适合接受批评，但事实上它与他的其他一切行为都完美契合。是的，正如你所说，这完全符合摩西的欲望、他的偏好，以及他的总体主旨。卡罗在本章结尾处基本上想要表达的是，他有先见之明地
to lock in those desires for future generations, that by building this way, he has made it so that future generations have to travel the way Robert Moses would prefer to them to travel. And in Caro's view that says doomed Long Island to a messy and congestion-based development pattern, I honestly don't know if that's changed since then. Maybe Long Island has opened up and become a traveler's paradise. I'll never know. I just refuse to find out.
将这些欲望为后代锁死了。通过以这种方式进行建设，他使得后代不得不按照罗伯特·摩西希望他们的方式出行。在卡罗看来，这注定让长岛陷入了一种凌乱且以拥堵为基础的发展模式。我老实不知道自那以后这种情况是否发生了改变。也许长岛已经开放，变成了一个旅行者的天堂。我永远不会知道了，我只是拒绝去寻找答案。
In this chapter, in ending on that point of Moses, through his use of concrete and steel, has locked in a way of living for generations, if not centuries, that he wants people to have, even if they don't necessarily want it, even if it's damaging to them. We have reached the capstone and the end of the Moses triumphant section of the book. This is the Act 2, in which Moses has had his power, enhanced it, and wrecks havoc with it. We saw Act 1, in which young Moses learned the ways of power and gained that power.
在本章中，在以“摩西通过使用混凝土和钢筋，为后代（如果不是几个世纪的话）锁定了某种他希望人们拥有的生活方式，即便人们不一定想要它，即便这对他们是有害的”这一观点收尾时，我们已经到达了本书“摩西的凯旋”部分的顶点和终点。这是第二幕，在这一幕中，摩西拥有了权力，巩固了权力，并用它大肆破坏。我们见证了第一幕，年轻的摩西学习了权力的运作方式并获得了权力。
This has been the end of Act 2, in which he has reached the ways of power and gained that power. This has been the end of Act 2, in which he has reached the apex of that power and used it to decide how people living in Long Island now will get in and out of New York, which the way I put it just now doesn't sound like a major victory, but it is. Trust me, there's millions of people that he's dealing with. Now we're about to enter Act 3, Moses's hubristic downfall. And reading the book again, spoiler as we get into this, it strikes me that this downfall section, you want it to be because the system rises up, some brave hero is able to turn the tide and get him. But more than anything, it seems to be because Moses is just getting older and he's losing his faculties and he
这是第二幕的尾声，在这一幕中，他达到了权力的巅峰，并利用它来决定现在生活在长岛的人们将如何进出纽约。我刚才的表述听起来可能不像一场重大胜利，但它确实是。相信我，他应对的是数百万的人口。现在我们即将进入第三幕：摩西因傲慢而走向的垮台。重新阅读这本书，在进入这一部分时先剧透一下，这给我的印象是，这一垮台的章节——你本希望看到的是因为体制的反抗，某个勇敢的英雄能够扭转乾坤并扳倒他。但比起别的什么，它似乎更多是因为摩西正在变老，他正在丧失各项机能，他
can't navigate the system the way he used to. And I think that is part of Caro's point is that the system did not self-correct here. Moses just overreached by aging out of his potential, his highest level of power. And we're going to see it, but you kind of, I'm going to warn people, they're not going to get the downfall that they want, which is for Moses to be pushed out by a crowd of well-meaning protesters or things like that, or to be pushed out by a crowd of well-meaning, you know, protesters or things like that, or, you know, to be put on trial or something. Instead, it's going to be much, much slimier and more self-destructive and a
无法再像过去那样在官僚体制中游刃工巧了。我认为这也是卡罗观点的一部分，即体制在这里并没有自我纠偏。摩西只是因为年龄超出了他的潜力、超出了他最高权力的巅峰而导致了权力过大。我们将会看到这一点，但我必须提前警告读者，他们不会看到他们想要的那种垮台——比如摩西被一群心怀善意的抗议者等推翻，或者被推上法庭受审之类的结局。相反，结局要阴暗得多、自我毁灭得多，而且也
little bit less satisfying. Roman, do you feel the same way? Well, I would sort of add one other thing, which is he does seem to have worse and worse ability to deal with the public, but the public is somehow has the platform, has the will, has a bit of the organization to kind of give him a few flesh wounds along the way. I mean, and they seem to be landing more. I mean, like famously, the Jane Jacobs chapter. I mean, like, famously, you know, the Jane Jacobs chapter
没那么让人满意了。罗曼，你也有同感吗？嗯，我差不多要补充另一件事，那就是他在处理与公众关系方面的能力似乎越来越差，但公众不知为何却拥有了平台、意愿和一点组织能力，能在这一过程中给他造成一些皮外伤。我的意思是，而且这些伤似乎正中要害。我是说，就像那段著名的简·雅各布斯章节。我是说，就像那段著名的，你知道的，简·雅各布斯章节
of this was taken out. That would have happened probably a little bit... Right, right, I'm trying to... Where would it happen? But it would have been... Yeah, it would have been a little bit later. It would have been like the early 60s, late 50s, I think, was the fight over the lower Manhattan Expressway, I think.
的内容被删掉了。那件事大概发生得稍微……对，对，我在想……它会发生在什么地方？但它应该会……对，它应该会晚一点。我觉得大约是60年代初、50年代末，关于下曼哈顿高速公路的争论，我想。
But it's clear that there is, even in these chapters, it's clear that there is, even in these chapters, it's clear that there is opposition forming in the public. They're not really identifying it as Robert Moses is the culprit. When people are talking about traffic is bad and traffic and the cars aren't the solution and the expressways aren't the solution, they're not really tying that to Robert Moses in the papers.
但很显然，即使在这些章节里，也很显然，即使在这些章节里，很显然公众中已经开始形成反对势力。他们并没有真正把罗伯特·摩西视为罪魁祸首。当人们在报纸上讨论交通状况有多糟糕、交通和汽车并不是解决办法、高速公路也不是解决办法时，他们并没有真正把这些与罗伯特·摩西联系起来。
But like they'll begin to, and then there'll be some dumb like follies that he'll make later on where he's like, you know, like where he's just making bad decisions that are, that have bad PR, which is something that he wouldn't have done earlier on, you know, like he's so full of himself that he just doesn't think bad press relates to him, but he does get a bit on that later on, but I do think that there's
但他们开始这样做了，接着他后来会犯下一些愚蠢的错误，比如他做出一些糟糕的决定，带来糟糕的公关危机——这是他以前不会做的事，你知道的，他太自负了，根本不认为负面新闻会牵连到自己，但他在后来的确因此吃了不少苦头，不过我确实认为
a little bit more agency in the public to take him on. And that sort of like runs against him being a little less savvy and a little less able to take care of it. And then he runs against a, you know, later on an equally arrogant person. Yeah, I think you're right. You know, I think I was overstating things by saying that it was just his own kind of folly and not the system. I think this is something that I should point out later after we've talked about it more,
公众在挑战他方面拥有了更多的自主权。这与他变得不那么精明、不那么能够掌控局面形成了呼应。然后他遇到了一个，你知道的，后来同样傲慢的人。是的，我觉得你说得对。你知道，我之前说那只是他自己的某种愚蠢行为而不是体制的问题，这话确实有些夸大其词了。我想这是我稍后在咱们深入探讨之后应该指出来的一点，
but I'm almost inevitably going to forget. So I'm gonna mention it now, because this is something I should say next episode, is that Robert Moses has been having his way with the city in large part because he has been doing damaging things to the lower classes, and he's been doing helpful things to the upper classes. But there's one class that he has kind of had a good reputation
但我几乎不可避免地会忘掉。所以我要现在提出来，因为这是我下集节目应该说的话，那就是罗伯特·摩西之所以能在城市里为所欲为，很大程度上是因为他在对下层阶级做着破坏性的事，同时却在为上层阶级做好事。但有一个阶级，他与之保持着
with but other than kind of Jones beaches, Jones, Jones beaches and playgrounds things like that. He hasn't had as much interaction with other than building roads and that's the middle class. And the middle and the upper middle class, once he starts rubbing them the wrong way and getting on their bad side that you're, I think you're right that that that's what really starts to hasten his downfall. Yeah, and the middle class in the 50s and 60s is growing, and they're going to be a really powerful voting block in setting the opinions and the agenda for things.
不错的声誉——除了琼斯海滩、琼斯、琼斯海滩和游乐场之类的事情外。除了修建道路，他与该阶层的互动并不多，那就是中产阶级。而中产阶级和中上阶级，一旦他开始惹恼他们、让他们产生反感，你就会发现，我觉得你说得对，正是这一点真正开始加速了他的倒台。是的，50年代和60年代的中产阶级正在壮大，他们将成为一支非常强大的投票力量，决定各种事情的观点和议程。
And that's the sort of golden age of the middle class. And as he's getting weaker, they're able to find sort of like chinks in his armor at the same time. And I think both things are working in concert to bring him to his loss of power, which is part seven, which happens next after the break. Beautiful segue. Radio, 20 years. Okay, now we're up to part seven, the loss of power. We have made it. Elliot, Kaelin, we're already here. It feels so good to finally be at this section, the loss of power.
而那是中产阶级的黄金时代。当他日渐式微时，他们同时也在寻找他盔甲上的裂痕。我认为这两者正在共同作用，导致他失去了权力，也就是第七部分，将在休息之后的下一节播出。绝妙的过渡。无线电，20年。好了，现在我们来到第七部分，权力的丧失。我们成功了。埃利奥特，凯琳，我们已经到这了。终于来到这一部分——权力的丧失，感觉真是太好了。
It doesn't feel so, not in that I want to be done with the book. I'm loving reading through this book, talking about this book, but it feels so good to finally see the words, the loss of power and be like, wait a minute, but that must be referring to Robert Moses losing power. Except for the process of him losing power still represents a bunch of misery. And so actually like chapter 41, rumors and reports of rumors is actually one of the more
这种感觉并非因为我想赶快读完这本书。我很喜欢阅读这本书，谈论这本书，但终于看到“权力的丧失”这几个字，并且觉得——等一下，但这一定是指罗伯特·摩西失去了权力。只不过他失去权力的过程仍然伴随着一堆苦难。所以实际上，就像第41章《谣言与谣言的报告》其实是
miserable chapters. Yes, that's true. In terms of its detail. So, you know, we've been talking about roads all this time, but what we have not yet really spent a lot of time on, and you know, Caro hasn't spent a lot of time on, is that he's also the director of the Mayor's Slum Clearance Committee,
最悲惨的章节之一。是的，没错。从它的细节来看。所以，你知道，我们一直在谈论道路，但我们还没有真正花大量时间去关注的一点是——卡罗也没有花太多时间去关注的一点——那就是他同时还是市长贫民窟清除委员会的主任，
and he has this massive power over public housing. In fact, I have now read this book three times. I don't fully understand his role in public housing completely to tell you the truth. I think that is mostly by design, Roman. So this period, we should remember, in the 50s leading into the 60s, this idea of slum clearance and the rebuilding
并且他对公共住房拥有巨大的权力。事实上，我已经读了这本书三遍了。老实说，我并没有完全彻底地理解他在公共住房中扮演的角色。我想这主要是刻意安排的，罗曼。所以我们应该记住，在50年代到60年代这段时期，这种清除贫民窟和重建
of the city's neighborhoods so that you could eliminate blight was something that was really big. The idea that there were poor parts of a city, there are rich parts, there are middle-class parts. What if we could get rid of the poor parts? What these, you know, what used to be called kind of like the tenement areas are now seen as slums. And I think a big part of that is because
城市街区以消除城市衰败的理念非常盛行。当时的想法是，一个城市里有贫困地区、富裕地区和中产阶级地区。如果我们能除掉贫困地区会怎么样？那些以前被称为贫民窟区域的地方，现在被视为贫民窟。而我认为其中很大一部分原因在于
they are now often populated by people of color rather than, say, immigrants from Germany or Italy who at the time when they came in were not really accepted, but there was still a greater visual link, let's say, with the powers that be. But setting all that aside, everyone's talking about slum clearance. Let's get the poor out of this bad housing and into better housing, or as Moses would say, let's get them out of this bad housing and then question mark, question mark, question mark. And as the mayor's slum clearance committee director, it's another one of these big overall czar positions where he is not directly overseeing each individual project, but he is overseeing the assigning of slum clearance projects to private developers through the federal kind of Title I program where you
这些地方现在通常居住着有色人种，而不是像德国或意大利移民那样——他们刚来时虽然不被真正接受，但与当权者之间仍然存在着某种更强的视觉联系，可以说是这样。但抛开这一切不谈，每个人都在谈论清除贫民窟。让我们把穷人从这些糟糕的住房里搬到更好的住房里，或者按摩西的话说，让我们把他们从这些糟糕的住房里赶出去，然后打上问号、问号、问号。作为市长贫民窟清除委员会主任，这是又一个巨大的总督式职位，他并不直接监督每一个独立项目，而是通过联邦的“第一章”（Title I）等计划，监督将贫民窟清除项目分配给私人开发商，通过这些计划，
can get federal money for, I think, conversions by a developer of private residences into a new housing development. And Carol's talked earlier about this idea that of eminent domain that Moses is taking advantage with his roads, the idea that like you can take land from a private owner and use it for the public good. And this housing development slum clearance is a further step in that where you are taking private buildings away from private owners and then handing them to other private owners in theory as a public good in order to create better housing for citizens and residents. And it's another one of these things that, oh, he's a big hero.
你可以获得联邦资金，我想是由开发商将私人住宅改造成新的住房开发项目。卡罗之前讨论过摩西在修路时利用的征用权（eminent domain）理念，即你可以从私人业主手中征收土地并将其用于公共利益。而这种住房开发和贫民窟清除则是更进一步的做法，你从私人业主手中夺走私人建筑，然后理论上作为公共利益将其移交给其他私人业主，以便为市民和居民创造更好的住房。这也是那种“哦，他是大英雄”的事情之一。
He's clearing out the slums. He's building all this new housing. New York is in a housing crisis. You know, it needs more. And everyone just takes it for granted that he says it's going great. And the newspapers just kind of run with that. But as Caro says, a few isolated, but perceptive observers were getting to notice clues to something very disturbing about slum clearance and
他在清除贫民窟。他在建造所有这些新住房。纽约正处于住房危机中。你知道，它需要更多。而每个人都理所当然地认为他说一切都进展顺利。报纸也只是顺着这种说法进行报道。但正如卡罗所说，少数孤立但敏锐的观察者开始发现一些非常令人不安的线索，关于清除贫民窟和
here, Caro starts constructing this little like Avengers style cast of reformers who each get like their own little sex, their own little adventure where they're learning about the problems with the slum clearance programs in the same way. You've got activist lawyer Hortense Gable. She helps found the New York State Committee on Discrimination and Housing, and she is middle class, but she starts talking to and listening to black and Puerto Rican New Yorkers who are being affected by the housing policies in a way that previous reformers hadn't really. Previous reformers had also been of the like, we know what's best, give these people the things that we think are best. They kind of thought the way that Moses thought, and Kara was kind of portraying this as a difference in a way that this new breed of activist is taking the lead of the people they're trying to serve in some ways. And she starts going
在这里，卡罗开始构建一个类似于复仇者联盟风格的改革者演员阵容，他们每个人都有自己的小插曲、自己的小冒险，通过同样的方式去了解清除贫民窟项目的问题。你拥有激进派律师霍滕斯·盖布尔（Hortense Gable）。她帮助创立了纽约州住房歧视问题委员会，她是中产阶级，但她开始与受住房政策影响的黑人和波多黎各裔纽约人交谈并倾听他们的心声，这是以往的改革者们从未真正做到过的。以往的改革者也持“我们知道什么最好，把我们认为最好的东西给这些人”的态度。他们的思维方式有点像摩西，而卡罗将此描绘成了一种区别：这种新一代的激进主义者在某种程度上带头倾听他们试图服务的人民。她开始走入
into the buildings that are being built and she is horrified by some of them. There's a moment that I find so scary just from the implications of it where she's in one of these apartments and she goes into the bathroom to check her hair and she looks in the mirror and there is no mirror. There's just a hole looking into the next apartment. That's astonishing to me that they're just like, yeah, yeah, we just left a hole there between these two apartments. There's city planning commission member Lawrence Orton. He starts questioning the statistics that most is using to show that the families that have been evicted are being given new, equitable housing.
正在建设中的大楼，并对其中的一些情况感到震惊。有一个时刻，仅仅从其暗示的意义上讲就让我感到非常害怕，当时她在其中一间公寓里，走到浴室去整理头发，结果照镜子时发现根本没有镜子。那只有一个通往隔壁公寓的洞。这让我大为震惊，他们竟然会觉得：对，对，我们就在这两间公寓之间留了个洞。还有市规划委员会成员劳伦斯·奥顿（Lawrence Orton）。他开始质疑摩西用来证明被驱逐家庭已经获得新的、公平住房的统计数据。
And he knows there's simply not enough public housing in the city being built to meet the needs of these displaced residents. And there's Walter Fried, Regional Council of the Federal Housing and Home Finance Agency. And he's noticing that the buildings in his own neighborhood in the West 90s are getting seedier, that more people are crowding into them. And by the summer of 1953, it's clear to him that these poor people of color, black and Puerto Rican residents, are being pushed out of their homes by this huge Moses controlled urban renewal project right nearby. And the closer he gets to the site of that project, the worse the state of the neighborhood
他深知市里建造的公共住房根本远远不够满足这些流离失所的居民的需求。还有沃尔特·弗里德（Walter Fried），他是联邦住房和住房金融署（Federal Housing and Home Finance Agency）的区域委员会成员。他注意到自己在西90街的邻里社区里的建筑正变得越来越破旧，越来越多的人挤进这些建筑里。到1953年夏天，他清楚地看到，这些贫困的有色人种、黑人和波多黎各居民，正被附近这个由摩西控制的巨大城市更新项目从家中挤出去。而且他距离该项目工地的位置越近，社区的状况就
gets. And he's realizing this slum clearance project is not clearing out a slum. It's just kind of like smooshing it down so it spreads outward. Like if you put too much peanut butter on a sandwich and you smoosh it down, it's not like the peanut butter gets cleared away,
越糟糕。他意识到这个清除贫民窟的项目根本不是在清除贫民窟。它只是像把它压扁一样，让它向外蔓延。就像你在三明治上抹了太多花生酱然后把它压扁一样，花生酱并没有被清除掉，
like it just overflows. So it's appearing to each of these people in different instances, like the old proverb of the three blind men with the elephant. They're all feeling different parts of this problem and not quite seeing how they connect, but understanding it's all part of one thing related to Moses's housing developments, not doing what they're promising to do, which is to rehouse people in better places.
它只是溢出来了。所以，对于这些人在不同情况下的经历来说，这就好像盲人摸象的古老寓言一样。他们每个人都在摸索这个问题的不同部分，并没有完全看清它们是如何关联的，但他们明白这一切都与摩西的住房开发项目有关——这些项目并没有履行承诺，即把人们重新安置到更好的地方。
Yeah, that's right. They're, they're, they're picking up little bits of things that you maybe wouldn't notice if you weren't on the ground. That's the thing that's really clear, this idea of like, well, these places that are nearby that are getting more run down, are getting more run down because the city's not taking care of those spaces to accommodate all the extra people
是的，没错。他们，他们，他们正在收集一些细小的片段，如果你没有亲临实地，你可能根本注意不到。这是非常明确的一点，这种想法就是：嗯，附近这些变得越来越破败的地方之所以破败，是因为城市没有照管好这些空间，以容纳所有额外的人口。
which are now being crammed into extra places, being divided up by landlords taking advantage. And they mentioned, you know, seeing way more garbage cans than you would expect outside of an apartment building, indicating that instead of, you know, five people living in a place, like 12 people are living in a place.
而这些人现在被塞进额外的地方，被那些趁火打劫的房东分割居住。他们提到，你知道，看到公寓楼外面的垃圾桶数量远超预期，这表明原本应该住5个人的地方，实际上住了12个人。
And this is all just like, again, this is like a person who is in charge, who is not thinking about the whole and also not thinking about the suffering of other people. Yes. And these are things that we've noticed before in the stories that Carol tells of the people being affected directly by them. And part of the difference here that we're going to see is that, as we mentioned before the break, these are middle class people that are noticing this. Two of these people are lawyers. Two of them have official positions in government. That makes all the difference that these are people who have access and also the space
而这一切，再次说明，这是一个掌权者，他既没有考虑整体，也没有考虑其他人的痛苦。是的。这些都是我们在卡罗讲述那些直接受影响之人的故事中以前注意到的事情。我们要在这里看到的区别的一部分是，正如我们在休息前所提到的，注意到这一点的是中产阶级。其中两个人是律师。其中两人在政府中担任官方职务。这就带来了全盘的不同，这些人拥有渠道，并且由于他们的生活优渥——我必须假设，即使不是极其富有，他们的生活也足够舒适——从而有精力和空间
in their life because they're living comfortably, I have to assume, if not wealthily, they're living comfortably enough to give thought and energy to what's being done and how to put it together as opposed to just trying to survive while they are being put in a difficult position. And I want to mention two things. One is I love the way that Caro writes each of these sections. He starts each of them with a similar mirroring phrase. The first one goes, for Hortense Gable, it was rumors and it goes through hers. For Lawrence Orton, it was statistics and goes through his section. For Walter Fried, it was garbage cans and goes through his section, which is great.
去思考正在发生的事情以及如何将其拼凑起来，而不是仅仅在被置于艰难境地时苦苦挣扎求生。我想提两件事。第一，我喜欢卡罗撰写每一个这些章节的方式。他用类似的镜像短语开启每一个章节。第一段是：对霍滕斯·盖布尔来说，那是谣言，然后讲述了她的故事。对劳伦斯·奥顿来说，那是统计数据，然后讲述了他的故事。对沃尔特·弗里德来说，那是垃圾桶，然后讲述了他的故事，这太棒了。
Also funny, it's rule three is right there. The third one is the funny one. But it shows you how, to me, how Caro is working on a literary scale and on a larger scale. He's not just writing each of these sections to be good reading, but he's connecting them in a way that he is, it's just magnified fractally throughout the book, which I think is so amazing to hold the whole thing in his head in that way, the whole design. But here he's also talking about that idea of blight. And we talked about in the last chapter
同时也很搞笑，规则三就在那里。第三个最好笑。但它向你展示了，在我看来，卡罗是如何在文学层面上以及更宏大的层面上进行创作的。他不仅仅是为了让每个章节都好看而写作，而是以一种贯穿全书的分形放大的方式将它们连接起来，我认为能在脑海中以这种方式把握全局和整个设计真是太惊人了。但在这里，他也谈到了“城市衰败”（blight）的概念。我们在上一章中讨论过
about how he was using some language that kind of edged into where we were feeling uncomfortable about how he was describing blight. And I feel like here he is not falling into that same problem. It feels like here is making it clear, blight is not a problem caused by the poor people in the neighborhood. It's the problem of those people not having access to adequate housing, adequate resources
他是如何使用一些边缘化的语言，让我们对他在描述城市衰败时的方式感到有些不舒服的。我觉得在这里他没有陷入同样的问题。感觉他在这里说得很清楚：城市衰败并不是由社区里的穷人造成的，而是这些人无法获得充足的住房和充足的资源所导致的问题，
and that Moses slum clearance title one projects are pushing former residents of those slums into worse housing and it's spreading the overcrowding and the problems farther. So I think he's, he's for all the like kind of queasiness that we had about some of his language in the last chapter, I feel like reading this chapter over again, I was like, oh, Mr. Caro, yeah, you're back on firm ground. It's not the people on the ground that are a problem,
并且摩西的贫民窟清除第一章项目正在把这些贫民窟的前居民推向更糟糕的住房，从而让过度拥挤和各种问题进一步蔓延。所以我觉得，尽管我们对他在上一章中的某些语言感到有些不安，但重新阅读这一章后，我发现：哦，卡罗先生，好吧，你又回到了坚实的立场上。出问题的不是实地的人民，
it's the people making decisions above them. They're the problem. And part of that is told through the eyes of these crusaders who have the time and the empathy and they've just evolved to take people's individual experiences and not see the failure of a neighborhood as the failure of individuals.
而是那些在他们头顶做决定的人。他们才是问题所在。而其中一部分是通过这些十字军战士的眼睛讲述出来的，他们拥有时间和同情心，并且已经进化到能够理解人们的个人经历，而不把一个社区的失败视为个人的失败。
It's really the failure of people like Robert Moses and the city pointing out that they might go to a kind of a rundown neighborhood, but every time they go into a home, they see that the home is lovely and cared for. And these folks really want to have nice things, but the system is really stacked against them. And this is further motivating their actions to
这实际上是像罗伯特·摩西这样的人以及城市的失败，他们指出，人们可能会去到一个有些破败的社区，但每次他们走进一户人家，就会发现那个家温馨而备受关爱。这些普通人真的很想拥有美好的生活，但体制对他们太不公了。这进一步激发了他们的行动，
recognize that this isn't a thing that anyone deserves. It's a thing being done to them. And it's sort of, that's the heartening part of all this, is that there's these people out there that are, you know, the antithesis of Moses. Yeah. And for all that we've heard about how people need to be cleared out of slums, it becomes clear to these activists, too, as they talk to people there, that these are poor neighborhoods, these are neighborhoods that the public at parts of them that individual families can't control are run down or not clean, but their houses are clean and the insides are clean and also they don't want to leave these places. This is where their communities
让他们认识到这不是任何人应得的遭遇。这是强加在他们身上的遭遇。某种程度上，这也是所有这些事情中最令人欣慰的部分，那就是有这样一群人存在，你知道，他们是摩西的对立面。是的。尽管我们听到了很多关于人们需要从贫民窟中被清除出去的说法，但这些激进主义者在与当地人交谈时也清楚地发现，这些虽然是贫困社区，是公众无法控制其某些部分的、个别家庭可能破败或不干净的社区，但他们的房子里面是干净的，而且他们并不想离开这些地方。这是他们的社区
are. They're worried about being relocated to places that are even smaller, more expensive, and it's tough. They, the people there don't want to leave those places. They prefer to have the homes they live in improved and being given access to the resources to do that. But, uh, their fear is that they're going to be forced out and kind of scattered to the winds and the activists are, uh, they're on top of it. You know, they're, they're out there.
所在。他们担心被重新安置到更小、更贵的地方，这很艰难。他们，那里的人们并不想离开这些地方。他们更愿意让自己居住的房屋得到改善，并获得相应的资源来实现这一点。但是，呃，他们的恐惧是他们会被强行赶走，然后四处流散，而激进主义者们，呃，他们正在全力应对。你知道，他们正在行动起来。
They're trying to get the newspapers to cover it. They go to the New York times. Is the New York times interested in this story? Roman? No, sir. They're not. No, they're like, we're not an investigative paper, maybe take it somewhere else. It's like, well, what do you do?
他们正试图让报纸进行报道。他们去了《纽约时报》。《纽约时报》对这个故事感兴趣吗？罗曼？不，先生。他们不感兴趣。不，他们觉得：我们不是一家调查性报纸，也许你该去别处看看。这就好像是：好吧，那你还能做什么？
What does a reporter do other than investigate? You know? Yeah. And so what they start to do things in their own way. And Orton from the city planning commission, I really love what he's doing here. Where he, so he works in the master plan unit, which nobody has been paying attention to. We talked in earlier episodes on New York does not have a master building plan. Moses very successfully stopped that from happening.
一个记者除了进行调查还能做什么？你知道的？是的，所以他们开始用自己的方式做事。来自市规划委员会的奥顿，我真的很喜欢他在这里所做的事情。他负责总体规划部门，而这个部门一直以来都没有人关注。我们在之前的剧集中讨论过，纽约没有总体建筑规划。摩西非常成功地阻止了这种情况的发生。
But there's this master plan unit and he's like, well, nobody pays attention to us. We can do whatever we want. So they just become kind of an eviction data collecting unit, uh, and looking at how many people have been evicted, what happens to them afterwards, or the consequences for the city and Orton acts like he's the member of like an underground resistance, uh, team, which I find kind of adorable to be honest. And Orton is working with bad data, incomplete data. The only people who may have the right numbers are people at Randall's Island,
但存在这样一个总体规划部门，他心想：既然没人关注我们，我们就可以为所欲为。于是他们摇身一变，变成了一个驱逐数据收集单位，呃，专门研究有多少人被驱逐了、他们后来遭遇了什么，以及对这座城市造成的后果。奥顿表现得就像他是地下抵抗组织的一员，老实说，我觉这挺可爱的。而且奥顿使用的是糟糕的数据、不完整的数据。唯一可能掌握准确数字的人是在兰德尔岛（Randall's Island），
maybe people in Tribro and Moses and his men have used their influence to keep those statistics out of the public eye. And so they're working with just the statistics they can get from Triborough, which are deliberately kept low by generalizing rather than actually counting people. And even with that low end estimate, Orton's group says that 170,000 people have been displaced in New York City for these public works in the seven years since the end of World War II. And Caro, he loves lists. So he goes, more people than lived in Albany, Phoenix, Little Rock, Sacramento, Tallahassee, Topeka, Baton Rouge, Trenton, Santa Fe.
也许是三区大桥管理局（Triborough）的人，而摩西及其手下则利用他们的影响力将这些统计数据瞒过公众。因此，他们只能使用从三区大桥管理局能弄到的统计数据——而这些数据是通过泛泛而谈而不是实际清点人数被故意压低的。即便按照这个保守的低端估计，奥顿的团队也指出，自二战结束以来的七年里，纽约市有170,000人因这些公共工程而流离失所。而卡罗，他热爱列举清单。所以他写道：这个数字比奥尔巴尼、菲尼克斯、小石城、萨克拉门托、塔拉哈西、托皮卡、巴吞鲁日、特伦顿、圣达菲的总人口还要多。
And I'll stop it there, but this, you know, a good sized, you know, small city of people have been removed and a remarkably disproportionate number of those displaced people are black or Puerto Rican and poor. And this is this this Orton survey that confirms the suspicions of the liberals. And they find that while Moses has been promising to relocate people, he usually just, as we've seen, moves them from one pre-demolished building to the next. And a third of the resident files are marked disappeared, whereabouts unknown. And Caro writes about how Moses couldn't really know if the living quarters that people were going to were better or equivalent where they left,
我就列举到这里，但你知道，这相当于一个规模可观的小城市的人口被赶走，其中流离失所的人口中，黑人或波多黎各人以及穷人所占的比例高得惊人。这就是这份证实了自由派怀疑的奥顿调查报告。他们发现，尽管摩西一直承诺重新安置居民，但他通常只是像我们所见的那样，把他们从一个刚被拆除的建筑转移到下一个。三分之一的居民档案上都被标记着“失踪，下落不明”。卡罗写道，摩西根本无法得知人们去往的住处是否比他们离开的地方更好或相当，
because he doesn't even know where those living quarters are. He doesn't know where these people went to. So when he's saying, oh yeah, everyone ended up in better housing, it's like, there's no way. But it's a safe bet that they're not moving into a better situation than the one that they were forced out of. And there's this parallel here with what we saw in East Tremont, where
因为他甚至不知道那些住处在哪里。他根本不知道这些人去了哪里。所以当他说“哦，是的，每个人最终都住进了更好的住房”时，这就好比：这根本不可能。但可以肯定的是，他们的处境绝对没有比他们被强行赶出去时的处境更好。这里有一个平行现象，正如我们在东特雷蒙特（East Tremont）看到的那样，
a lot of these neighborhoods, the activists are finding, are valued by their residents, even with their flaws, but not by outsiders. And the outsider is the ones making the decisions, but the residents here have an even greater sense of helplessness because they know as people of color, disproportionately, they have even less of a say in this system, in their own future, and even less access to housing in the rest of the city. It's really, these are the people who are really at the biggest disadvantage and the most vulnerable to this kind of slum clearance, pushing them into worse and worse living situations.
激进主义者发现，许多这样的社区尽管有种种缺陷，却深受居民的珍视，但外来者却不这么认为。而外来者正是那些做出决策的人，但这里的居民却有一种更强烈的无助感，因为他们知道，作为不成比例的有色人种，他们在这一体制中、在他们自己的未来中拥有更少的话语权，并且在城市其他地方获得住房的机会也更少。真的，这些人才是处于最不利地位、最容易受到这种清除贫民窟并将其推向日益恶化的生活环境的群体。
Yeah, it's really tragic stuff. Like all that sort of bullying, the sort of like, you need to be out in 10 days. That's completely bogus. All that sort of stuff. I don't even know. Like I'm a person of great means. If somebody, if the city of Berkeley put a thing
是的，这真是太悲惨了。所有那种霸凌行径，诸如“你必须在10天内搬走”之类的话。这完全是无稽之谈。所有类似的事情。我甚至不知道。比如我是一个经济条件很好的人。如果伯克利市在我的门上贴了一张通知
on my door that said you had to be out in 10 days, I would freak the fuck out, you know? And it's just miserable. You know, it's in one of these things like the roads, the bad thinking, the bad planning is one thing. This kind of not feeling safe and secure in your home, which is really the emotional center of feeling safe in your home
说我必须在10天内搬走，我会彻底抓狂的，你知道吗？这太悲惨了。你知道，这是其中一件事，就像道路一样，错误的思考、糟糕的规划是一回事。这种在自己家里感到不安全、不安心的感觉——这实际上是感到在自己家中安全的心理核心，
and being able to relax at the end of a day is so fundamental to a healthy person's life, you know? And to think about that they're on edge all the time and then he treats it as nothing. I mean, one of the things that he's doing is he's, you know, like triple and quadruple and maybe quintuple counting what's available. So he's building things and he's like,
并且能够在一天结束时放松下来——对于一个健康的人的生活来说是如此基础，你知道吗？想到他们一直处于精神紧绷的状态，而他却对此不屑一顾。我的意思是，他正在做的一件事就是，你知道，对可用房源进行三重、四重甚至五重的重复计算。所以他在建设并宣称：
yeah, we got like a thousand units available for people. But he's like, he's not, they've already been promised and that, you know, it's kind of like, he's just doing this shell game when he's trying to answer for this stuff. And it's just gross behavior. It's really gross and he's not oblivious to the problem. I think that's part of the issue is it's not like
是的，我们为人们提供了大约一千套可用住房。但实际上，他并没有——这些房子已经许诺出去了，你知道，这就像他在试图回应这些事情时玩的一场骗局。这真是太恶劣的行径了。这真的很恶劣，而且他并非对问题一无所知。我认为这正是问题的一部分，并不是说
he's like, oh, I didn't realize that. I thought we were doing great. No, he knows what he's doing. He knows that even the housing that they are producing is priced at a point that is too high for the people he's evicting to afford. That he is replacing housing for the poor with housing for the middle class. And these facts are available to him because he's hiding these facts. It's not like you get the liberal
他好像在说：“哦，我没意识到。我以为我们干得很好。”不，他很清楚自己在做什么。他知道哪怕是他们建造的住房，其定价也高得让那些他正在驱逐的人根本负担不起。他正在用中产阶级的住房取代穷人的住房。这些事实是他完全知晓的，因为他正在隐瞒这些事实。这可不是你去找他，然后抱着自由派的梦想说：
dream of going to him and saying like, did you notice this? And him going, Oh no, I never realized that guys shut it down. Shut it down. Instead. He's like, yeah, I know, I know what I'm doing and I don't care. Uh, And so activists, they start writing up these reports. Orton has his master plan unit write report. This other group, the Women's City Club, they write a report and nobody sees these reports, especially with the Orton report. Moses, I guess caught wind of it
“你注意到这一点了吗？”而他回答说：“哦，天哪，我从来没意识到，伙计们，关停它！关停它！”相反，他的反应是：“对，我知道，我清楚自己在干什么，但我不在乎。”于是，激进主义者们开始起草这些报告。奥顿让他的总体规划部门写了一份报告。另一个组织“妇女城市俱乐部”（Women's City Club）也写了一份报告，但没有人看到这些报告，尤其是奥顿的那份报告。摩西大概听到了风声，
and his allies in the city planning commission, they delay the release of that report for nine months and they rewrite it to be supportive of Moses's housing work. And they so changed the tenor of this report that Orton is like, I need to be able to write a minority rebuttal to the report that my team wrote that you changed. And in the case of the report from the Women's City Club, Moses' lawyer, Samuel Rosenman, who I think we mentioned before, who was like, had the ear of presidents and things like that,
他在市规划委员会的盟友将那份报告的发布推迟了九个月，并对其进行了改写，使其转变为支持摩西住房工作的立场。他们如此彻底地改变了这份报告的基调，以至于奥顿不得不表示：“我必须写一份少数派反驳意见，来反驳我团队所写却被你们篡改了的报告。”而在妇女城市俱乐部报告的情况下，摩西的律师塞缪尔·罗森曼（Samuel Rosenman）——我想我们之前提到过他，他曾是总统等人的耳目，
a very respected figure in New York, he releases his own public rebuttal of that that provides a second set of conflicting facts. So city reporters are like, I don't know which facts to choose from, this women's club or this guy who's a well-respected part of the democratic government establishment. I guess we just won't deal with it. And the newspapers either bury or ignore the reports completely. If they cover it, they lead with this proposal that Moses people inserted deliberately as a diversion saying they might increase the city tax on telephones to pay for housing. So if there's any coverage of these reports about how massively the housing developments are failing people of the city, it is about how we don't want to pay higher tax on telephones. Like it's
是纽约一位备受尊敬的人物——则发表了他自己的公开反驳，提供了第二套相互冲突的事实。因此，城市记者们会觉得：我不知道该选择哪一套事实，是这个妇女俱乐部，还是这个作为民主政府建制派中备受尊敬一员的家伙？我想我们还是别理它了吧。报纸要么将这些报告束之高阁，要么完全无视。如果他们进行了报道，他们也会把摩西的人为了转移视线而故意塞进去的提议作为头条，声称他们可能会提高城市电话税来支付住房费用。所以，如果说关于这些住房开发项目如何极大地辜负了城市居民的报道还有什么的话，那就是我们不想缴纳更高的电话税。这就好像是
something, some totally irrelevant, not real proposal. And at one point the New York Times quotes Moses's reply to the Orton rebuttal. And Orton is like, I don't even know he had written a reply until it was quoted in the New York Times. Like no one even told me that he rebutted my rebuttal. And the paper is ultimately, they don't care what happens to poor people. Caro says, this is a heartbreaking sentence. Caro says, the fate of poor people had never been news in New York city. It still was not news.
某种完全不相关、并非真实的提议。有一次，《纽约时报》引用了摩西对奥顿反驳的回应。而奥顿则表示：直到它被引用在《纽约时报》上之前，我甚至不知道他写过回应。就像根本没人告诉我他对我的反驳进行了回击一样。报纸最终根本不在乎穷人的遭遇。卡罗写下了这样一句话，这是一个令人心碎的句子。卡罗写道：穷人的命运在纽约市从来都不是新闻。现在依然不是新闻。
And it's like, oh, that's so like, it's such a, it's such a sad, um, kind of. Truthful statement of the abdication of any sort of power to take care of people who desperately need that help. That just like, yeah, news in New York City is not that people are poor and poor people get pushed around. Like that's not news. People either assume it
这就像是——哦，这太像了，这简直是一个令人备感悲伤的、
or they don't wanna know about it or they don't care about it. And just such a, that sentence when I was rereading this chapter, it just was like a, it was just sprung out at me. It hit me so hard, you know, cause it's still true, you know, to such a great extent. For sure, for sure. And here me so hard, you know, because it's still true, you know, to such a great extent. For sure, for sure.
道出了那些迫切需要帮助却被剥夺了任何关怀权力的残酷真相的陈述。这就好像是：没错，在纽约市，穷人不是新闻，穷人被欺负也不是新闻。这根本不是新闻。人们要么默认这一点，要么不想去了解它，要么根本不在乎。当我重新阅读这一章节时，那句话简直就像是从纸面上跳了出来。它深深地击中了我，你知道吗，因为在很大程度上它至今仍然是事实，你知道的。确实如此，确实如此。
And here in all this, you know, dealing with Title One and independent developers is where a lot of sort of old fashioned corruption happens and skimming. And it seems like this might be something that could build into a scandal, although it somehow doesn't, but I still don't like, could you describe what the scandal that's potentially happening here? I would love to, I would love to.
而在这其中所有的事情——处理第一章和独立开发商的事宜——正是许多老派腐败和中饱私囊现象发生的地方。这看起来似乎是一件可能酝酿成丑闻的事情，尽管它不知为何没有演变成丑闻，但我仍然觉得——你能描述一下这里潜在发生的丑闻是什么吗？我很乐意，我很乐意。
So there's in 1954, the Senate actually like investigated one of the projects that was being done to look at the books. And we get a cameo in the book from Senator Prescott Bush, who when this book was written was not yet the father and grandfather of presidents of the United States of America. He's just a senator. And they talk about how, for instance, real estate worth $15 million on the open market had been given to developers for $1 million.
所以在1954年，参议院实际上真的对其中一个正在进行的项目进行了调查以查阅账目。我们在书中迎来了参议员普雷斯科特·布什（Prescott Bush）的客串登场，当这本书写成时，他尚未成为美利坚合众国总统的父亲和祖父。他当时只是一名参议员。他们讨论了例如：在公开市场上价值1500万美元的房地产，竟然以100万美元的价格送给了开发商。
And in the time that these developers have been mandated to tear down 338 buildings, they've torn down 58. And the other 280 are not only still standing, the developers are running them and collecting rent from the tenants. And so essentially, developers who have promised to tear down buildings and build new, better buildings are instead just taking over the management of those buildings and raising the rents and refusing to maintain the buildings. So people are paying more for worse living in slums.
而在开发商被强制拆除338栋建筑的期限内，他们只拆除了58栋。其余的280栋不仅依然矗立，开发商还在经营它们并向租户收取租金。因此，本质上，那些承诺拆除旧建筑并建造崭新、更好建筑的开发商，实际上只是接管了这些建筑的管理权，抬高了租金，并且拒绝维护这些建筑。所以人们在为贫民窟里更糟糕的居住条件支付更高的费用。
And then there's just classic stuff. There's fake legal fees. You put your family members on the staff of this development company and pay them money. And there's a great one that I love that I want to read to you on page 981 about this guy, Caspert, who's running one of these. And it says, Caspert had skimmed off for himself and his family $115,000 in less than a year. He set up a separate corporation headed by his son-in-law. Manhattan town sold the son-in-law's corporation all the gas stoves and refrigerators in the tenements for $33,000 and then rented them right back from the corporation, paying it
然后还有一些经典的勾当。虚假的法律费用。你把自己的家庭成员安插在这个开发公司的员工名单上给他们发薪水。这里有一个我很喜欢的精彩例子，我想在第981页读给你听，关于一个叫卡斯珀（Caspert）的家伙，他负责管理其中一个项目。上面写着：卡斯珀在不到一年的时间里，为自己和家人中饱私囊了115,000美元。他成立了一家由他的女婿领导的独立公司。曼哈顿镇（Manhattan Town）以33,000美元的价格将贫民窟里所有的燃气灶和冰箱全部卖给了他女婿的公司，然后又立刻从这家公司把它们租回来，
in effect for the privilege of using what had been its own appliances. And they're able to make so much money just corruptly milking what the city and the federal government are pouring into this and turning into the most basic kind of graft. And by then, it says, eventually, financially, this development project, Manhattan Town in this case, it was backwards started from. It had made no progress. But his son-in-law had pocketed $115,000. So it's a success as far as the Casper family is concerned. That's right. And so it's that kind of classic graft, you know? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
实际上等于是在为使用本就属于它自己的电器这一特权付钱。他们通过贪污腐化城市和联邦政府倾注进来的资金，能够捞取如此巨额的财富，并将其变成了最基础的营私舞弊。到那时，书中写道：最终在财务上，这个开发项目——本案中的曼哈顿镇——完全是倒退着开始的。它没有取得任何进展。但他的女婿却将115,000美元揣进了腰包。所以就卡斯珀家族而言，这是一个成功。没错。所以这就是那种经典的营私舞弊，你知道的？对，对，对。
But none of this corruption, even though it has sent hearings, even though it's written about a little bit, even though it probably isn't written about enough, none of this blows back to Robert Moses, the head of all this. Yes. And Robert Moses is both the beneficiary and the shield for these projects in that way.
但所有这些腐败——尽管它引发了听证会，尽管它被写进了一些报道中，尽管它可能还没有得到足够的报道——没有一件反噬到这一切的负责人罗伯特·摩西身上。是的。而罗伯特·摩西在这类项目中既是受益者，又是保护伞。
I think there's this understanding still, there's this assumption if incorruptible Robert Moses, the people's public servant, the man with the parks, if he's in charge of it, these things must be going fine. His words still carry his weight. If he says it's fine, it must be fine. And there's such an ingested assumed assumption on the part that's with the most redundant, I think I could possibly say assumed assumption.
人们仍然有一种认知、一种假设：如果清正廉洁的罗伯特·摩西、人民的公仆、拥有公园的男人由他掌管，这些事情肯定进展顺利。他的话依然很有分量。如果他说没问题，那就一定没问题。报纸编辑们在内心中有一种根深蒂固的假设——我觉得这是我能说出的最冗余的词了，所谓的“假设的假设”。
There's such an understanding on the part of the editors at newspapers that Robert Moses is incorruptible that that they tell the reporters, there's not really, probably not a story here. This is probably a bad apple, you know, this one bad apple that maybe most didn't know about, or they're so afraid of his power in the political world that they won't go after it. And so he's able to keep his name out of the official proceedings because he's so powerful and he's able to keep his name out of the papers because he's seen as such a saint, you know, that why would you bother to investigate him? Yeah, yeah. When all these facts are complicated, the trail is hard to follow. They land on
报纸编辑们有一种强烈的共识，认为罗伯特·摩西是绝对清廉的，以至于他们告诉记者：这里大概没什么新闻价值。这可能只是一只害群之马，你知道的，可能是摩西并不知情的一只害群之马，或者他们太害怕他在政治世界里的权势而不敢去深究。因此，由于他权势滔天，他能够将自己的名字排除在官方诉讼程序之外；又因为他被视为圣人一般的人物，他能够将自己的名字从报纸上抹去，你知道的，既然如此，你又何必去调查他呢？对，对。当所有这些事实变得错综复杂、线索难以追踪时，他们最终得出的
this one fact, this foundational, what they think is a foundational truth is that it can't really be all that bad because Moses is the one in charge. And that is what they rely on to the detriment of the entire city and to all these people. It really is a failure on the part of the people who should be reporting these types of things. And it's the kind of thing that we still see in reporting today quite a bit, which I'm sure we'll talk about later in the episode, where just as Moses has cut himself off from new information, and this has meant that his work is at best stale, at worst destructive,
是一个基本事实，他们认为的根本真相是：事情不可能真的那么糟，因为掌舵的人是摩西。而这正是他们所依赖的信念，结果却损害了整座城市和所有这些人的利益。这确实是那些理应报道这类事情的人的失职。而这也是我们在今天的报道中仍然经常看到的那类情况——我确信我们会在本集的后文讨论这一点——就像摩西将自己与新信息隔绝开来，这意味着他的工作往好了说是陈旧过时的，往坏了说是具有破坏性的，
that the people in charge at these newspaper organizations, they've cut themselves off from the possibility of new information. Like Robert Moses, they understand him, they know him, they've known him for years. It's not worth looking in and finding something new. And so they miss out on this enormous scandal, this enormous story. And so from 1952 to 1956, there are, as Carus says, rumors and reports of rumors of the damage that Moses is doing to the people in these slum clearance housing projects. But the papers barely touch it and Moses's reputation remains firm and the rest of the book kind of seems to bear out the idea that again it's because the things he is doing are affecting the poor. They're affecting the people at the bottom
这些新闻机构的负责人同样将自己与接触新信息的可能性隔绝开了。就像罗伯特·摩西一样，他们理解他，他们了解他，他们认识他多年了。根本不值得再去深入探究并发现新东西。因此，他们错失了这起巨大的丑闻、这个巨大的故事。因此，从1952年到1956年，正如卡罗所说，关于摩西对这些贫民窟清除住房项目中的人们造成的损害，一直有着各种谣言和关于谣言的报告。但报纸几乎从不触及这些，摩西的声誉依然稳固，而本书的其余部分似乎也印证了这样一个观点：这一切之所以如此，再次是因为他所做的事情影响的是穷人。他们影响的是处于底层的人们
of the ladder who the people at other rungs of the ladder, unless they are particularly empathetic or open-hearted people, do not care about. But, but, Caro ends this chapter with a little, there's like a little glimmer of hope in there. He says, before the people would be willing to look at Moses's program straight on, they would have to look at Moses straight on. And before the public could do that, there would have to be an issue that would show him so clearly for what he was, that there could be no mistake. And in this next chapter, Roman, in the next episode, we will cover that mistake and we will find that it is maybe
梯子底层的人——除非他们是极具同情心或内心开放的人——根本不在乎。但是，但是，卡罗在本章的结尾留下了微光，里面有一丝希望。他说，在人们愿意直面摩西的计划之前，他们必须直面摩西本人。而在公众做到这一点之前，必须出现一个能将他的本相暴露得如此清晰、让人绝无误解的问题。而在下一章中，罗曼，在下一集里，我们将讲述这个错误，并且我们会发现，它或许
the least of all the things that Robert Moses did that was wrong, but it'll happen. It'll happen in the next episode. It's so funny and weird and it feels so true that the thing that brings someone down or just like really does have a sort of mortal wound to him is something that just matters so much less than everything else horrible that he's done.
是罗伯特·摩西所做错的事情中最微不足道的一件，但它还是发生了。它将在下一集里发生。这真是既滑稽又诡异，而且又显得如此真实：那个能让人跌落神坛、或者说对其造成致命打击的事情，竟然比他所做过的一切其他可怕的事情要微不足道得多。
All these things, it's the Capone tax evasion charge of Robert Moses to a certain extent. But that's one of the lessons of the book I feel like it's not talked about too much at least in my hearing about it There's so much talk about cities and how they work and things like that But the idea that the things that get noticed are less about what's being done than about who they're being done to And the victim matters even more in some cases than the act Especially that victim has connections to the news media,
所有这些事情，在某种程度上就是罗伯特·摩西版的卡彭逃税指控。但我觉得这也是这本书的教训之一，至少在我听到的讨论中，这一点没有被过多提及。人们对城市及其运作方式等话题讨论得很多，但被关注到的事情往往更多取决于事情是被做给谁的，而不是事情本身是什么。在某些情况下，受害者甚至比行为本身还要重要，尤其是当这个受害者与新闻媒体有联系时，
as we'll see in the next chapter. That's right. But we will get to more of the loss of power next time. [♪ MUSIC PLAYING FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES OUT, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES IN, MUSIC FADES Chief of Mother Jones and one of your fellow book club participants. And now our conversation with Clara Jeffery. Clara has been with Mother Jones for more than 20 years and has been editor-in-chief since 2015. Clara now oversees the Center for Investigative Reporting, which produces the exceptional radio show and podcast Reveal after that organization merged with Mother Jones this year. Earlier in her career while she was at Harper's Magazine, Clara edited several essays by the
正如我们将在下一章中看到的那样。没错。但我们下次会探讨更多关于权力丧失的内容。[♪ 音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐弱，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，音乐渐强，《琼斯母亲》杂志的主编兼你的书友会同伴之一。现在是我们与克拉拉·杰弗里的对话。克拉拉在《琼斯母亲》工作了20多年，自2015年起担任总编辑。今年该组织与《琼斯母亲》合并后，克拉拉现在负责监督调查报道中心，该中心制作了出色的广播节目和播客《揭秘》。在她职业生涯的早期，当她在《哈珀斯杂志》工作时，克拉拉编辑了
great investigative journalist Barbara Ehrenreich from when Ehrenreich went undercover as a low-wage worker to expose the impact of welfare reform on the working poor. Those essays later became part of Ehrenreich's seminal 2001 book, Nickel and Dimed. To me, Mother Jones and CIR do the reporting that's closest to what the power broker did when it was published, reporting that drills down deep and explains systems that challenges the status quo, that holds the powerful accountable and focuses on the humanity of the people affected. Well, thank you so much for being on the Nine-Nine for some visible breakdown of the Power Broker. It's just a pleasure to have you here.
伟大的调查记者芭芭拉·埃伦赖希的几篇文章，当时埃伦赖希为了揭露福利改革对城市贫民的影响，隐瞒身份去当了一名低薪工人。这些文章后来成为了埃伦赖希2001年的开创性著作《我在底层的生活》的一部分。对我而言，《琼斯母亲》和调查报道中心所做的报道，最接近《权力的掮客》出版时所做的那种报道——那种深入挖掘、解释体制、挑战现状、追究当权者责任，并聚焦受影响人们的人性尊严的报道。嗯，非常感谢你做客九九播客，对《权力的掮客》进行一些深入剖析。很高兴能邀请你来到这里。
Well, I'm really excited to be part of the carousons. It's the amount, the volume of material to ingest the book itself, your guys' podcasts, their movies, there are articles. It's just a phenomenal upwelling of interest about this book, you know, which is beloved by many for decades, but it's really kind of nice to have this national reading project that you guys have convened. I've been so heartened by people like taking this on
嗯，我真的很高兴能成为卡罗同好的成员。这本书本身需要吸收的材料数量和体量、你们的播客、电影、还有文章。关于这本书的兴趣真是空前高涨，你知道的，几十年来它一直被许多人所喜爱，但你们发起这样一个全国性的阅读项目，感觉真的是挺棒的。我深受鼓舞，看到大家能够接受这一点，
and taking it to their heart and taking on the task of reading this true tour de force of journalism. And, you know, one of the reasons I wanna talk to you is you've been on the front lines of this fight for a long time for championing investigative journalism in society and making sure that we have a healthy ecosystem. And so when you read this book, how does it make you feel as someone
并把它记在心里，承担起阅读这部真正无与伦比的新闻巨著的任务。你知道，我想和你谈谈的原因之一是，长期以来你一直处于这场斗争的前沿，在社会上捍卫调查新闻，并确保我们拥有一个健康的生态系统。所以当你读这本书时，作为这样一个
who is always thinking about stuff like this, fighting to keep Mother Jones alive, often from existential threats, like from people trying to sue it Jones alive, often from existential threats, like from people trying to sue it out of existence. So how do you feel when you read The Power Broker? I mean, first of all, just like utter admiration for the work involved by Caro, by Robert Gottlieb as editor,
总是思考这类事情的人，为了让《琼斯母亲》存续而不断抗争（往往要面对来自那些试图通过诉讼让它彻底消失的人的生存威胁），你会有什么感受？所以当你阅读《权力的掮客》时，你作何感想？我的意思是，首先，对卡罗所付出的工作，对编辑罗伯特·戈特利布，
everybody else in Ina Caro, helping her husband with research for 40 years now. You know, just everyone I'm sure at Knopf and the publishers. I will admit, I can't, I don't know if I'm the only one, but I don't think you can read the power broker and kind of contemplate this all as a journalist or a, you know, public policy person and not feel a great sense of imposter syndrome. You're like,
以及伊娜·卡罗（她四年来一直协助丈夫进行研究）以及 Knopf 和出版商的所有其他人，只有纯粹的敬佩。我承认，我不知道我是不是唯一一个有这种感觉的人，但我想你不可能在读完《权力的掮客》后，作为一个记者或公共政策人士，不产生一种极大的虚假身份综合征（冒名顶替综合征）。你会觉得：
my God, what have I been doing with my life? I will answer that for you. You've been doing play. I'll take the other side of this debate. Not enough. Not enough. Never enough. I think one of the things in kind of contemplating this, it's how indefatigable Moses is, Cairo is, Gottlieb is in this weird troika, you know, speaking as an editor, I throw the editor in there too, but like, and that just an obsessiveness, which is a hallmark of investigative journalists and lots of different kinds of journalists, but I think particularly investigative journalists, it's a personality trait that has many great qualities about it and also we're a little squirrely sometimes. So just contemplating the full sweep of the book
天哪，我这辈子都在干什么？我来替你回答这个问题。你一直在玩。我支持这场辩论的另一方。还不够。远远不够。永远都不够。我觉得在思考这件事时，最让人感叹的是摩西、卡罗、戈特利布这三个奇妙组合中那种不屈不挠的精神，你知道的，作为一个编辑，我也把编辑算在内，但那种强迫症般的执着——这是调查记者和许多不同类型记者的标志，但我认为尤其是调查记者，这是一种具有很多优秀特质的人格特质，而且有时候我们也有点古怪。所以只要想想这本书的全貌，
and how much it has really just influenced so many people, I think both directly, people who remember reading it or are reading it now, and indirectly, because I think that demonstration down to the detail of every little deal and every little inch of land he wrested from somebody or another in one way or another. And to tell that all compellingly, you know, it is really awe inspiring. One of the things that comes up a lot when Elliot and I are discussing the book
以及它如何真正影响了如此多的人——我认为包括直接影响（那些记得读过它或现在正在读它的人）和间接影响，因为我认为这种深入到每一个小交易的细节、他以这样或那样的方式从某人手中夺取的每一英寸土地的展示，以及把这一切都写得引人入胜，你知道的，这真的是令人敬畏。我和埃利奥特在做总结、讨论这本书时，经常出现的一个情况是，
when we're doing the summaries, is I'll read a paragraph that is just, you know, he just put together all the facts and figures of this one little highway. And I think about him assembling that information before the internet, before he wrote it down himself, because he became like the source of it all after a certain point,
我会读到这样一个段落，你知道的，他只是把这一个小小的高速公路的所有事实和数字拼凑在了一起。我想到他在没有互联网、在他自己写下来之前就收集了这些信息，因为在某个时间点之后，他成了这一切信息的来源，
and just how hard one of these single paragraphs that he just tosses off is. It's so nice to be around another journalist who understands how hard some of these – when you go through a book of 1,200 pages, noting that there's a single paragraph in, you know, Chapter 40, that probably would take me three months to assemble, maybe. It's staggering. It is, and it's the sort of particular kind of detail that you find by combing through files and bills and et cetera. But then also just his, you know, whatever, 500 plus interviews. And clearly he interviewed some of these folks multiple times.
而他随手写下的这些单个段落背后，付出的是多么巨大的艰辛。能和另一位深知其中艰辛的同行在一起是多么美好——当你翻阅一本1200页的书，注意到第40章里可能只有那么一个段落，这可能得花我三个月的时间才能拼凑出来。这太令人震惊了。确实如此，这就是那种通过梳理档案、法案等资料才能找到的特定细节。但除此之外，还有他那，不管怎样，500多次采访。而且很显然，其中有些人他采访了不止一次。
And she, you know, sometimes really acknowledges and other times is a little bit more coy about it. But to combine both of those skills, which not journalists often sort of go down one route or the other. Either sort of personality driven journalism, or really in the details and the weeds. And you know, it takes a special talent to fuse those so well, and to make it a compelling psychological study and not just of him, like, you know, LaGuardia, and Al Smith, and you know, all these people that you're just really pulled along by the human drama, as well as you're getting to know, like, the exact cement mix of some overpass or whatever.
而她（指伊娜）呢，有时会大方承认，有时又对此讳莫如深。但要将这两种技能结合起来——通常记者们往往只会走其中一条路线，要么是主打人格魅力的独家新闻，要么是深入细节的深度调查。你知道的，能把这些完美融合，并让它成为一本引人入胜的心理学研究著作，而不仅仅是关于他个人的书，比如拉瓜迪亚、阿尔·史密斯，还有所有这些人物，让你真正被人类的人性戏剧所吸引，同时又能了解到比如某个立交桥的具体水泥配比什么的，
And, you know, exactly how, you know, and exactly what way he filleted, you know, assemblymen to get what he wants. So, yeah, just truly awesome. Yeah, yeah. That's a relief to me, because I was worried that you were going to say that, as an investigative
以及，你知道的，他究竟是如何以某种方式切除议员的羽翼来达到自己目的的。所以，是的，真的太令人惊叹了。太好了，太好了。这让我松了一口气，因为我原本担心你作为一名调查记者，在翻阅时会时常觉得：“这不是我会做的那种方式。”
reporter you'd be looking through it at times being like, that's not how I would have done that. Oh, this isn't how I would do it. Oh, that's not the same way that when I watch a comedy show on TV my wife hates it because I just sit there going like, not how I would have written that. Do you ever have that moment when looking through it or is it just such a monumental work that you can't even find a single crack in its edifice. I mean I think there's some cracks in its edifice but it's more like you know in contemplating what he ended up cutting and some of the stuff that he didn't cut.
哦，这不是我会做的。哦，这就像我在电视上看喜剧节目时，我妻子会恨死我一样，因为我只会坐在那里说：“这根本不是我会写出来的台词。”你在翻阅这本书时有过这种时刻吗？还是说这是一部如此宏伟的著作，以至于你连它宏伟大厦上的一条裂缝都找不到？我的意思是，我觉得它的大厦上还是有一些裂缝的，但更像是，你知道的，在思考他最终删掉了什么以及他没有删掉什么时。
You know I think in in the documentary Turn Every Page which is about him and his editor Bob Gottlieb which is about him and his editor, about Gottlieb. He, well, you know, Gottlieb is talking about being a completist himself. And in that conversation, he sort of is indicating things that he might have wanted to cut, and he doesn't exactly spell out what that is. But it seems to be the sort of summation pieces at kind of the end of every chapter or the sort of like, let me once again step back and tell you the sheer awesomeness of the power that that Robert Moses had assembled. And yet, I mean, I think for a book this ginormous, people even, you know, back in the 70s were probably reading were probably reading it, not as one big sit-down experience
你知道，我认为在纪录片《翻到每一页》中——那是关于他和他的编辑鲍勃·戈特利布的纪录片，是关于他和他的编辑戈特利布的。他，嗯，你知道，戈特利布谈到他自己是一个追求穷尽所有细节的人。在那种对话中，他某种程度上暗示了他可能想要删除的东西，但他并没有确切地说明那是什么。但那似乎是那种位于每章结尾的总结性段落，或者类似于“让我再次退后一步，告诉你罗伯特·摩西所积累的权力的纯粹恐怖之处”。然而，我的意思是，对于一本如此庞大的书，人们甚至在70年代可能就已经在阅读了，
with this 12 pound tome in your lap or whatever, but, okay, now I'm going to take on a chapter or two, and it does allow you to come back to the book having been away for a while and not lose the threads. So even there, if I had to pick a sniggle, I guess it would be that, but it's so minor in the scheme of things. Yeah.
或许并不是坐下来一口气读完这本12磅重的巨著，而是“好吧，现在我要读一两个章节”，它确实能让你在离开一段时间后重新拿起这本书时，而不会理不清头绪。所以即使在那种情况下，如果我非要挑刺的话，我想大概就是这个了，但在宏大的格局中，这实在是微不足道。是的。
You know, speaking about this relationship of the editor and the author, another fundamental text in my life was Barbara Ehrenreich's Nickel and Dime, which you served as the editor at Harper's when it was developing into the book it became. Can you talk about that process of working with someone and having it kind of work for a magazine and then become a book, what that was like? Yeah. I mean, I worked on a couple of the, it's sort of, there's sort of three parts to the book and I worked on two out of three of them when I was at Harper's.
你知道的，说到编辑和作者这种关系，我生命中的另一部基础文本是芭芭拉·E·雷恩赖希的《我在底层的生活》，当这本书还在发展成为后来的样貌时，你正是《哈珀斯杂志》的编辑。你能谈谈与某人合作的过程，以及它如何先是在杂志上发表，然后变成一本书，那段经历是怎样的吗？是的。我的意思是，我参与了其中的几部分，这本书大约有三个部分，我在《哈珀斯杂志》时参与了其中的两个部分。
You know, and the first being a sort of going undercover as it were, as a, you know, as a waitress in a chain restaurant. And it was really fascinating. That kind of thing had become silver boatin. Any kind of undercover work sort of went through this, like, oh no, the grand poobas of journalism say we can't do that. She had the idea that she wanted to do it, and then we talked through a lot. I remember one of the interesting, I was a very young editor and she was already a superstar. But one of the things that I had to sort of reinforce is like you actually have to back up and say,
你知道，第一部分是隐瞒身份去连锁餐厅当女服务员。这真的非常迷人。那种事情曾一度成为黄金标准。任何隐蔽调查都会经历这样的过程，比如，哦不，新闻界的巨头们说我们不能这样做。她萌生了想要这样做的想法，然后我们进行了深入的讨论。我记得其中一个有趣的地方是，我当时是一个非常年轻的编辑，而她已经是超级巨星了。但我不得不强调的一点是，你实际上必须退后一步说：
now I'm doing exactly what maybe Kara would want. You have to back up and say why this is important. You have to back up and also admit that like what maybe Carol would want. or know that they were going back to their literary life. And it was interesting that, I remember having a discussion with her, she's like, do I really need to do that? I'm like, I do really think you need to do that. Maybe a little bit generational,
现在我正在做卡罗可能希望的事情。你必须退后一步，说明为什么这很重要。你还必须退后一步，承认像卡罗可能想要的那样……或者知道他们要回到自己的文学生活中去。有趣的是，我记得曾和她讨论过这个问题，她说：“我真的需要那样做吗？”我说：“我真的觉得你需要这样做。”这可能有点代际差异，
I feel like that's the kind of thing a young person would tell me now. They're like, I really gotta get in there and admit your privilege. That wasn't even the vocabulary that we had back then, but it was part of that conversation for sure. I'd worked on several other pieces with her that were about vaguely defense industry stuff and another piece that did a big bunch of pieces on pinkwashing and breast cancer,
我觉得这就像是一个年轻人现在会告诉我的那种话。他们会说：“我真的得深入进去，承认你的特权。”当时我们甚至没有这种词汇，但这绝对是那段对话的一部分。我曾和她合作过好几篇其他文章，大致是关于国防工业相关的内容，还有另一篇发表了一大堆关于粉红清洗和乳腺癌的文章，
which then became a book for her down the road. Her writing was always lovely and her thought process was always fantastic. So it was just those little tweaks of often like, you need to provide more context or like, you may not come off so great in this way, if you phrase it just in this manner. And very gracious at taking input. That's what I was gonna ask. No push over mind you, but gracious.
这些文章后来成为了她日后出版的一本书。她的文笔总是很优美，她的思维过程也总是棒极了。所以这只是需要做一些微小的调整，通常是像“你需要提供更多的背景信息”或者“如果你只是用这种方式表述，你在这件事上可能显得不那么好”。而且她非常乐于接受意见。这就是我要问的。请注意，她可不是个唯命是从的人，但她很温和。
Yeah. And what are those conversations like? Like, do you get to a point where you build a rapport, where that works and you can be very blunt, or do you always have to be kind of circumspect in your sort of criticism so that everyone feels okay in the end? I think that very much varies by the author that you're working with, partly their personality and how yours interacts, like how much experience they have, how insecure versus overly secure sometimes people are. So you are often playing a little bit of shrink, where, you know, kind of your job is to get
是的。那样的对话是怎样的？比如说，你们会达到这样一种默契：这种合作行之通，你可以直言不讳；还是说你在批评时必须总是小心翼翼，好让每个人最后都觉得没问题？我认为这很大程度上取决于你与之合作的作者，部分取决于他们的性格以及你们如何互动，比如他们有多少经验，人们有时会有多缺乏安全感或过度自信。所以你常常扮演一点心理医生的角色，你知道的，你的工作就是激发出
the best work out of them and help support them in that process and not let them do things that would damage the project or damage their own reputation. I think sadly that latter part has gotten a little bit lost in some corners of journalism where having someone get messy on the page is sort of the goal rather than keeping people from sort of self-harm in a writerly way. But yeah, so it's always partly shrink and supporter and then you're always kind of cracking the whip a little bit, right? There's always a deadline of some sort.
他们最好的作品，并在这一过程中支持他们，不让他们做出会损害项目或损害他们自身声誉的事情。遗憾的是，后一部分在新闻界的某些角落似乎已经有些迷失了，让某人在纸面上表现得一团糟似乎成了目标，而不是防止人们以一种作家的自我毁灭方式伤害自己。所以，是的，它总是部分扮演心理医生和支持者的角色，然后你还得稍微挥舞一下皮鞭，对吧？总归是有某种截止日期的。
Bob Caro doesn't have one, but I think most other people do. a deadline of some sort. Bob Caro doesn't have one, but I think most other people do. And the way the industry has become, I mean, I think just another thing reading this book in the LBJ books is just like, wow, even if it was Bob Caro, would this happen now? Just on an industry economics point and that's really kind of tragic to think about that there's just not, you know, the economy of the business or the priorities of the business have kind of changed whether it's in books or magazines or newspapers or whatever and still a lot of great stuff being done but some things it's hard to imagine would still happen. Yeah, you really do feel it of a, there's parts of the book where you feel like it's
鲍勃·卡罗没有死线，但我认为大多数其他人都是有的。总归是有某种截止日期的。鲍勃·卡罗没有死线，但我认为大多数其他人都是有的。而整个行业现状的发展，我的意思是，我觉得读这本书以及LBJ（约翰逊）传记时的另一个感受就是：哇，即使是鲍勃·卡罗，现在还能发生这种事吗？仅从行业经济学的角度来看，想到这一点真的很悲惨，因为没有了……你知道的，商业经济学或商业优先级已经改变了，无论是在图书、杂志还是报纸等领域，虽然仍有很多优秀的作品在问世，但有些事情很难想象现在还会发生。是的，你确实能感觉得到，这本书的某些部分让你觉得它
super relevant to today, it has a ton of lessons in of the book would feel like it's super relevant to today. It has a ton of lessons in it. I mean, we talk about them all the time. It also does feel like a product of a different era of of just imagining this book hitting the shelves. Like I can't remember the last time something like this like sort of came out of nowhere, a big tome about something came out of nowhere and surprised people as a bestseller. Maybe that book, Capital, that came out 10 years ago, that was also big and dense and seemed very challenging in some ways. But still, this is a rare example of a kind of excellence that you do worry doesn't have the chance to get past the seedling stage in today's world. And it's really interesting. I wasn't able to find that much about exactly, like it seemed to take off right away
超级契合当下，它包含了大量的教训。这本书会让你觉得它超级契合当下，它里面有大量的教训。我的意思是，我们一直在谈论它们。它也确实让人感觉像是另一个时代的产物，仅仅是想象这本书上架的情景。我不记得上一次有这样一本书——某种横空出世的大部头——像这样横空出世并作为畅销书让人大吃一惊是什么时候了。也许是那本10年前出版的《资本论》，它同样又大又厚，在某些方面看起来也非常具有挑战性。但即便如此，这也是一种卓越的罕见例子，让人不禁担心它在当今世界甚至没有机会迈过萌芽阶段。这真的很有趣。我找不到太多关于它确切情况的资料，似乎它一经出版就火了，
and maybe because it's in New York and because Gottlieb was his editor and because all of these things, and Nesbitt was his agent, that was going to happen. But it is kind of phenomenal that it didn't happen, I don't think, so far as I can tell,
也许是因为它在纽约，因为戈特利布是他的编辑，因为所有这些因素，还因为内斯比特是他的经纪人，这一切注定会发生。但它没有发生，据我所知，这确实可以说是非常了不起的，
because a lot of people were having their suspicions confirmed It is kind of phenomenal that it didn't happen, I don't think, so far as I can tell, because a lot of people were having their suspicions confirmed. Like, there are a lot of books that come out that are like, hey, everyone knows this thing is bad. Let me show you how bad it is or why it's bad or maybe good. And this felt like it was, the entire topic was not very well understood even by journalists and scholars of the time but you know I say that you guys are now the experts so please correct me if I've flavoring under it.
因为很多人的怀疑得到了证实。它确实可以说是非常了不起的，据我所知，因为很多人的怀疑得到了证实。就好比有很多书出版时都在说：“嘿，大家都知道这东西很坏。让我来向你展示它有多坏，或者为什么它坏，或者也许是好的。”而这本书给人的感觉是，整个主题甚至连当时的记者和学者都不是十分了解，但我得说，你们现在是专家了，所以如果我的理解有偏差，请纠正我。
No it certainly seems like it wasn't that's one of the one of the exciting things about the book or one of the interesting things about the book now looking at it on its 50th anniversary is it's so become the default way of thinking among so many people about these topics and at the time it very much wasn't and it's one of those things where also you were saying how would something like this happen today and I kind of feel like it almost didn't happen then a book like this and there was a certain amount of novelty I think when it came out of are you gonna read this huge book about Robert Moses the parks commissioner you're going to can you believe this read this huge book about Robert Moses, the parks commissioner? You're going to. Can you believe this is this book is about Robert Moses? That like Robert
不，它当然看起来不是那样的。关于这本书，令人兴奋的事情之一、或者说现在在它出版50周年之际回看它有趣的地方在于，在这么多关于这些主题的讨论中，它已经成为了大家的默认思维方式，但在当时绝非如此。而且这也是那种情况之一，正如你刚才所说，这样的事情在今天怎么可能发生呢？我甚至觉得当时它几乎也没能发生。像这样的一本书，在它刚出版时确实带着一定的新鲜感：你会去读这本关于公园专员罗伯特·摩西的巨著吗？你会去……你能相信吗？去读这本关于罗伯特·摩西的巨著？你会去的。你能相信
Moses now he's, you know, it's because the caro view, which is not as as straightforwardly flat as it's often taken to be, but the caro view of this guy did more harm than good likely, you know, or did a lot of harm is so taken now that at the time it was almost like not not just, oh, are you going to read this whole book of harm, is so taken out, that at the time it was almost like not just, ugh, are you gonna read this whole book demonizing Robert Moses? But literally, are you gonna read this whole book about the most boring man in the world, Robert Moses?
这本书是关于罗伯特·摩西的吗？以至于罗伯特·摩西现在，你知道的，因为卡罗的观点——这个观点并不像人们通常认为的那样直白扁平——卡罗对这家伙的观点是：他带来的危害可能大于好处，你知道的，或者说带来了巨大的危害。现在这个观点已经被广泛接受，以至于在当时，这几乎就像不仅是“噢，你会去读整本关于危害的书吗？”，而是被广泛接受到这种程度：在当时，这几乎就像不仅是“呃，你会去读整本将罗伯特·摩西妖魔化的书吗？”，
And so, like, that it has this uphill battle of even just getting people interested. And Caro talks about how people would say to him, no one's gonna read this book. No one's gonna, and not because he wrote it or because it's big, no one's gonna read a book on this topic, because it's so, so boring. But I feel like every now and then there's one of those,
而是字面意义上的：“你会去读一本关于世界上最无聊的人罗伯特·摩西的皇皇巨著吗？”
just the right book at the right time hits it, where a book that should exist in academic libraries only if the normal rules of market economics applied suddenly becomes this enormous thing. And with a book like this, it's gotta be partly because it's such a rich, it's such a satisfying read, I think. But it's true. It's a funny thing that exactly what you're saying, that like at the time, it wasn't just that people liked Robert Moses, it was people didn't even think about him. It was not even an interesting topic, you know?
所以，它面临着甚至只是让人产生兴趣的逆境。卡罗谈到人们曾对他说：“没人会读这本书。没人会……”并不是因为是他写的，或者因为它体量巨大，而是没人会读一本关于这个主题的书，因为它太无聊了、太无聊了。但我觉得总有那么几次，
Yeah, and I mean, I can only imagine it was very much helped along. Like if Robert Moses had happened in LA or Chicago or another great, huge, important city, but maybe not the heart of where publishing is. Yeah, that would people have been like, wait a minute, that's why I don't have a playground? Or that's why I can't get to the airport by the subway? So I think there was, I have no doubt that that kind of helped accelerate the uptake of the subway. So I think there was, you know, I have no doubt that that kind of helped
恰好在对的时间出现了一本对的书，如果遵循普通市场经济规律本该只存在于学术图书馆里的书，突然变成了如此巨大的轰动之作。对于这样一本书来说，部分原因肯定是因为它内容如此丰富，我认为它是一本非常满足的读物。但确实如此。这真是一件有趣的事情，正如你所说，在当时，不仅人们喜欢罗伯特·摩西，甚至人们根本连想都不会想到他。它甚至都不是一个有趣的话题，你知道吗？
accelerate the uptake of the book. But you know, it's also remarkable that he just, you know, he pretty much just had written it. And then he's like, Hey, I need an agent. Hey, I need an editor. And then he, you know, kind of got the best of the best on both counts. And, you know, that also feels like, on the one hand, like, yes, this work totally deserves that, that rare purchase in the industry, but also feels very serendipitous, like, could it just not happened? Yeah. And a good reminder, too, that it's for all Robert Caro is responsible for this book, that how many other people were involved in that making it
是的，我的意思是，我只能想象这得到了极大的助推。如果罗伯特·摩西发生在洛杉矶、芝加哥或其他伟大、庞大、重要的城市，但也许不是出版业的心脏地带。是的，人们会说：“等等，这就是为什么我没有游乐场的原因吗？”或者“这就是为什么我不能坐地铁去机场的原因吗？”所以我认为，毫无疑问，这种环境有助于加速人们对这本书的接受。但你知道，同样值得注意的是，他基本上就是把它写完了。然后他说：“嘿，我需要一个经纪人。嘿，我需要一个编辑。”然后他（你知道的）在这两方面都找到了最好中的最好。而且，你知道的，这感觉也充满了巧合，一方面，是的，这项工作完全配得上行业里那种罕有的赏识，但另一方面也感觉非常机缘巧合——难道它本可能不会发生吗？是的。这也很好地提醒了我们，尽管罗伯特·摩西是……不对，尽管罗伯特·卡罗对这本书负有责任，但还有多少其他人参与了它的创作
and bringing it to fruition, his agent, his editor, his wife, how many people were necessary to then lift up this book that Robert Caro's name is on the cover of, you know, because he wrote it, but it was not a one person job to get a book like this off the ground, not just because it's enormous, you know, it's very hard to lift a book like this by yourself. You know? Well, I think it's really notable. I just want to highlight that for a whole bunch of reasons, like feminism and the need for two incomes,
并使其终究问世——他的经纪人、他的编辑、他的妻子，有多少人是必不可少的，才能托举起这本封面上写着罗伯特·卡罗名字的书，你知道的，因为是他写的，但要让这样一本书脱胎换骨绝不是一个人的工作，不仅因为它体量巨大（你知道的，独自一人很难抬起这样一本书），你懂我的意思吗？嗯，我认为这非常值得注意。我只想为了各种各样的原因强调这一点，比如女权主义和对双收入的需求，
like having your wife be your research assistant, not, and maybe they figured out a way to pay her directly through the contract, but like that is a thing that wouldn't happen today for mostly good reasons, but who knows how that would have ended up without such a steady research partner who literally knew him better than anyone and could go, because it doesn't seem like he's a guy who trusts a lot
比如让你的妻子担任你的研究助理，而不是……也许他们想办法通过合同直接支付给她报酬，但这在今天是不会发生的事情，大部分是出于正当理由。但谁知道如果没有这样一个坚定的研究伙伴——她字面意义上比任何人都更了解他，并且能够去……因为他看起来不是那种会信任很多
of people to go figure something out for him. So it literally took being married to a, you know, presumably world-class researcher to kind of help get this over the line and the LBJ books as well. Very much so. Along the lines of how of changing people's minds, basically, Robert Carrow, you feel it in The Power Broker, how hard he's pushing to at least bring to the attention of the people reading this book what Robert Moses was responsible for and to change the general myth about him. And Mother Jones is often, if it's like doing kind of similar work of trying to push people so that their assumptions aren't taken for granted as assumptions, but instead question
人去帮他查明某些事情的人。所以字面意义上，这需要娶一位（你知道的）堪称世界级的研究员为妻，才能帮助推动这一切越过终点线，LBJ的传记也是如此。确实如此。顺着改变人们想法的思路来看，基本上，罗伯特·卡罗，你在《权力的掮客》中能感受到，他为了至少让阅读这本书的人注意到罗伯特·摩西应负的责任、并改变关于他的普遍神话，是多么努力地在推动。而《琼斯母亲》杂志也经常这样做，如果它像是在做类似的工作，试图推动人们，让他们的假设不被视为理所当然的假设，而是去质疑
them, what does it feel like to be doing that work? Because it's not just a work of reporting, but a work of trying to kind of move the reader to a place beyond being informed to understanding something in a different way. And do you feel a kinship with the book in that way? Or what's that kind of work like? Yeah, I think, you know, the work that we do, the work that Kara does, and, you know, many other journalists, but like, you know, we were into systemic stuff before systemic was a buzzword. So it's not, you know, it's not just the, it's not just looking at the sort of individual, like, how did this contract come about? How did this person become the underling that helped him push this through? But, you know, and I think Caro is very insistent in a way
它们，那么做这项工作是什么感觉？因为这不仅仅是一项报道工作，而是一项试图引导读者超越仅仅获取信息、走向以不同方式理解某事的工作。你是否在某种程度上对这本书感到一种亲近感？或者那种工作是怎样的？是的，我认为，你知道的，我们所做的工作，卡罗所做的工作，以及（你知道的）许多其他记者，但是，你知道的，我们在“系统性”成为流行词之前就已经在关注系统性问题了。所以它不是，你知道的，它不只是那种局部的、不只是审视诸如“这个合同是怎么出炉的？这个人是怎么成为帮他强推这一切的手下”之类的个体，而是（你知道的），而且我认为卡罗非常坚持，
that because it was sort of, you know, it wasn't the first book they'd ever done. I mean, Upton Sinclair is right there however many years earlier. But there is a way that he's just really insistent that not only that you know what happened, but why it happens and the sort of failings of other bodies and people to stop this person from doing all the harm that he did do.
因为这并非他们做过的第一本书。（我的意思是，不论多少年前，厄普顿·辛克莱就摆在那里。）但他的那种坚持不仅在于让你知道发生了什么，还在于为什么会发生，以及其他机构和个人未能阻止这个人做出他所犯下的所有恶行的种种过失。
And not that he only did harm. You know, I think that that's important. And, you know, you get this incredible Shakespearean arc of his temperament and his kind of ego. And that really helps draw you through like if he were just a supervillain at the beginning of the book, I think a lot of people wouldn't be as interested because more complicated villains are better villains, generally. So in that sense, I think, to
并不是说他只做了坏事。你知道的，我认为这一点很重要。而且，你知道的，你从中得到了他那暴躁脾气和某种自我膨胀的不可思议的莎士比亚式人生悲剧弧光。这真的有助于引导你读下去，如果他从书的一开始就只是个超级大反派，我想很多人就不会那么感兴趣了，因为更复杂 反派通常才是更好的反派。所以从这个意义上说，我认为，
again, like weave that sort of psychological profile together with the incredible investigative reporting. He's not the only one who has done it, but does it incredibly well. Yeah. In the section that we're talking about in this episode, there's a lot, and actually it's throughout the book, but there's a lot of the New York Times in particular
再次将这种心理侧写与不可思议的调查报道交织在一起——他不是唯一一个做到这一点的人，但他做得好得不可思议。是的。在我们这集节目讨论的这个章节中，有很多内容——实际上整本书都是如此——其中有很多关于《纽约时报》尤其
failing to hold Robert Moses into account. And I mean, this is a time period where there was maybe like 27 local New York newspapers. You know what I mean? Like, you know, there's a lot of newspapers back then. And still, the degree to which one, you know, big news entity, not sort of seeing the story here or not valuing it or not agreeing with the criticism really set the agenda for what the city did. And it strikes me that today, it's like in terms of the news media, it's even worse.
未能追究罗伯特·摩西责任的记载。我的意思是，那是一个可能大约有27家纽约本地报纸的时期。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你知道，当时有很多报纸。即便如此，某家大型新闻实体（没有看到这里的故事，或者不重视它，或者不同意批评意见）在多大程度上真正主导了这座城市的议程。这让我想起，在当今的新闻媒体方面，情况甚至更糟。
There's just like fewer people doing the work. When you hear, like I'm not one of these new jerk, like the media gets it wrong type of people at all. I'm a big supporter, like tons of people who make news and who write the news, investigate the news. But could you reflect on this idea of like what it means to not have a diverse sort of body of work or people working to hold power know, hold power accountable.
做这项工作的人变得更少了。当你听到……我绝对不是那种一听到媒体弄错就膝跳反应似地指责的人。我是个坚定的支持者，有成千上万的人在创造新闻、撰写新闻、调查新闻。但你能反思一下这个想法吗：没有一个多元化的作品群体或致力于追究当权者责任的人，意味着什么？
Yeah. I mean, let's, let's first start with the failings of the media back then about Caro. And, and as you say, sorry about Moses. Yes. Um, that as you say, the Times was probably the worst offender, maybe mostly because it then as now was the most important of the papers. You know, and it seems like this really started with, uh, if a Jenny, am I pronouncing her name right? Um, Salzburg, who like, see, I say if, if a gene and you say something, but Elliott says it differently too.
是的。我的意思是，让我们首先从当年媒体对卡罗的失职说起。而且，正如你所说，对不起，是关于摩西的。是的。嗯，正如你所说，《时报》可能是最糟糕的罪魁祸首，也许主要是因为它当时和现在一样都是最重要的报纸。你知道的，这似乎真的始于，呃，珍妮（Genia），我发音对了吗？嗯，萨尔茨堡（Salzburg），就像，你看我说Genia，而你说的是……但埃利奥特的发音也不一样。
I remember like, well, too I remember like I looked up also the Greek pronunciation I'm like I'm not touching that like I'm completely mangled out if I try but I'm I say I say if EG which was her record EG is a great it's like yeah it's a great rap name the owner of the times and I'm sitting out rhymes that kind kind of stuff. Yeah, she's, you know, it was early. It was early. It was primitive hip hop, but she was on the forefront. Yeah. That she, you know, she was a great Parks lover and booster and so really admired not
我记得，好极了，我也查过希腊语的发音，我想我还是别碰了，如果我试着读的话，绝对会把发音完全搞砸。但我说的是，我说的是Ifeg，这也是一个很棒的饶舌歌手名字，就像……这是一个很棒的说唱歌手名字，时报的老板，我正坐在这里即兴押韵呢。是的，她，你知道的，那还很早。那是早期。那是原始嘻哈，但她走在前沿。是的，她，你知道的，她是一个伟大的公园爱好者和支持者，所以她真的很崇拜（不仅是
everything, but mostly what he did with the Parks stuff. And then that just set the glide path to being blind or throwing her hands up at everything else because both that work was so important to her. And then once the Times, I think, had kind of got into this, you know, my view about him, I was thinking about how different actually reporting was back then. Because say you were even a reporter who got on a story about Moses, you know, 10, 20 years into his power. If you're a Times reporter, the place that you go look for what to think about him, what to know about him, would have been your own clip archives that would have been brought
一切），主要是他在公园方面所做的事情。然后这直接铺平了道路，使她对其他一切视而不见，或者束手无策，因为这项工作对她来说太重要了。一旦《时报》陷入这种状态，我认为，我对于他当年的实际报道方式有这样一番思考：因为哪怕你是一个在摩西掌权10年、20年后才开始追踪他的报道的记者，如果你是《时报》的记者，你去寻找关于他的看法、了解关于他的信息的第一个地方，就会是你自己的剪报档案，这些档案会由那些在资料室（他们称之为剪报室）工作的人用某种文件夹送到你面前，
up to you in some kind of folder by like the people who work in the morgue, what they call the clip room. front that they would be kind of relying on their past work. And so, you know, once there's a bias or a blind spot, that just gets reinforced. And, you know, I think we we see that time and again by the media in general and specifically. And then, you know, and then there's a sort of listening to the money men, right? I mean, that's always been a problem, just like, well, these are the people who have the money and the power and they say this is good. And so we're all for it.
而他们会依赖自己过去的工作。所以，一旦存在偏见或盲点，就会不断得到强化。而且，你知道的，我想我们一次又一次地看到媒体普遍如此，具体也是如此。然后，你知道的，还有一种听从有钱人的情况，对吧？我的意思是，这一直是个问题，就像，“好吧，这些是有钱有势的人，他们说这很好，所以我们全力支持。”
I think what was interesting about these chapters is These are the people who have the money and the power, and they say this is good, and so we're all for it. I think what was interesting about these chapters is, it was the women's, the women's, WWC, right, the Women's Council. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That did the investigating in the sort of, the low income areas, yeah. The Women's City Club, yeah.
我觉得这些章节有趣的地方在于，这些是有钱有势的人，他们说这很好，所以我们全力支持。我觉得这些章节有趣的地方在于，是妇女组织，妇女组织，WWC，对吧，妇女市政俱乐部。对，对，对。她们在低收入地区进行了调查，是的。妇女市政俱乐部，是的。
Women's City Club, there you go. Who went out and did their own investigation, and not journalists, like, but did their own investigation, and not journalists, like, but did their own investigation to track down what happened to the tenants of the various Title I housing projects that were being displaced. They were told they were going to get, you know, some kind of new housing that would be as good or better
妇女市政俱乐部，这就对了。她们走出去进行自己的调查，而且她们不是记者，但是她们进行了自己的调查，以追踪那些因被置换而流离失所的各种第一章（Title I）住房项目的租户们的遭遇。她们被告知将会得到某种跟她们被赶出来的住房一样好甚至更好的新住房，但实际情况呢？这些女性确实做了一项英勇的工作，再次强调，她们不是专业记者，在当代的社会风气下，这大概也不是很多女性会经常外出去做的事情，而她们却发现了这些了不起的东西。然后她们去了所有的报纸，
than the housing that they had booted from, what actually happened. And these women really did like a heroic job, again, not professional journalists, not, you know, in the mores of the times, probably not a thing that a lot of women went out to do that often, and found this great stuff. And then they went to all the papers,
而报纸只是零星地报道了一点，但似乎大多不以为然。所以，再次像……在现在，她们可能会有其他渠道来，但似乎大多不以为然。所以，再次强调，现在她们会有其他渠道来利用这些信息，她们会拍个TikTok（抖音），我不知道她们会做什么。她们会想方设法把这些信息传播出去，希望如此。但在当时，情况差不多就是这样。
and the papers did a little bit here and there, but seemed to mostly shrug it off. And so again, like in, you know, now they would have kind of other venues bit here and there, but seemed to mostly shrug it off. And so again, now they would have other venues to maybe take that, they'd make a TikTok, I don't know what they do. They'd get that information out somehow, hopefully. But at the time, that was sort of it.
你可以去找那些几乎全都是男性的记者，把你们准备好的档案交给他们，而他们可能会也可能不会严肃对待你，如果在那里遇到了阻力，他们可能会也可能不会愿意顶撞他们的编辑。所以这在某种程度上就是当时的体制结构。我的意思是，老实说，今天我所担心的是，当人们（当然是在社交媒体上）为一则时机糟糕的头条新闻或其他诸如此类的事情而情绪激昂、自我煽动时。
You could go to the reporters, almost all of whom were men, and give them the dossier that you had prepared, and they would take you seriously or not, reporters, almost all of whom were men, and give them the dossier that you had prepared and they would take you seriously or not and be willing to run up against their editors or not if they found interference there. So that sort of impart the structure back then. I mean today, honestly, what I'm worried about when people get, certainly on social media, spin themselves up about a terrible timed headline or this, that, or the other.
你可以去找记者，几乎全都是男性，把准备好的资料交给他们，他们会认真对待或者不予理睬，几乎全都是男性，把准备好的资料交给他们，他们会认真对待或不予理睬，如果遇到阻挠，他们可能愿意与编辑抗争，也可能不愿抗争。所以这就是当时的大致结构。我的意思是，说实话，今天我所担心的是，当人们在社交媒体上，当然是在社交媒体上，因为一个时间糟糕的标题或其他乱七八糟的事情而情绪激动时。
Robert Carroll first got into this, he's like a reporter at Newsday, and some day where everybody else was out the company picnic and he was the only guy like left on the city desk and someone's like, I got a big dossier on some, you know, regional airport situation. And he tried to call the like investigative editors and reporters and everyone was at the picnic. And so like, eventually, he just goes and looks through all this stuff. And that's, you know, in his telling, that's how he got this bug. And there aren't there aren't a lot of reporters out there in the world who And there aren't a lot of reporters out there in the world who get to spend days and weeks combing through papers. I mean, a lot of places, nobody's going to city council meetings, nobody's going to zoning board meetings, there's just nothing.
罗伯特·卡罗刚入行时，在《纽约新闻报》当记者。有一天，公司举行野餐，所有人都去了，只有他一个人留在城市新闻台。有人说：“我这有一份关于某个地区机场情况的大厚档案。”他试图给调查编辑和记者打电话，但大家都去野餐了。所以最后，他干脆自己把这些资料全翻了一遍。按他自己的说法，他就是这样染上“记者瘾”的。在这个世界上，没有多少记者能有幸花上几天甚至几周的时间去梳理成堆的文件。我的意思是，在很多地方，没人去参加市议会会议，没人去参加区划委员会会议，简直什么都没有。
And so I'm much more worried about the, in the broadest view, that the problem with the media right now is that it's sort of like, if you imagine a marine food web or something, and you might be focused on the tuna or the whale or whatever, but if there's no plankton, all of that stuff eventually runs into real trouble. And that, I think, is the largest problem. Yes, there's still biased and blindspots. You know, journalists are humans, but it's just, you know, I mean, it's hundreds of thousands of jobs
因此，从最宏观的角度来看，我更担心的是，现在媒体的问题有点像——如果你想象一个海洋食物网什么的，你可能会把注意力放在金枪鱼、鲸鱼或其他什么上面，但如果没有浮游生物，所有这些东西最终都会陷入真正的麻烦。我认为，这才是最大的问题。是的，偏见和盲区依然存在。你知道的，记者也是人，但这就好比，过去十年里，
in the last decade alone all across the country. Yeah. I mean, that's what I read into this when he has these criticisms of the New York Times is not so much that the fix was in or some kind of thing. It is about that sort of institutional legacy, the trust of institutions. So when Robert Moses says something, a few rabble rousers doesn't really merit. And the fact that all this information is funneled towards a couple people with their biases and
仅在全美范围内就有成千上万个工作岗位消失。是的。我的意思是，当他对《纽约时报》提出这些批评时，我读出的并不是说黑幕已经内定或类似的事情。而是关于那种制度性的传承，对机构的信任。所以当罗伯特·摩西说些什么时，几个煽动者根本不值得一提。而且所有这些信息都被汇聚到少数带有偏见的人手中，
therefore the best remedy for that is having a lot of people with a lot of different biases. Like you're not going to eliminate the biases, but it's nice to have a bunch of people who they're, you know, cause other biases like mine would be like, Oh yeah, let's take that fucker down. I mean, that would be my instinct is to not believe them rather than to believe him.
因此，解决这个问题的最好办法是拥有许多带有各种不同偏见的人。就像你无法消除偏见一样，但如果能有一群人，他们会……你知道的，产生其他的偏见，比如我的偏见可能会是：“哦，对，让我们把那个混蛋搞垮。”我的直觉可能是去怀疑他们，而不是相信他们。
And I wouldn't be a responsible steward of a paper if I always acted on that impulse either, but there's enough papers that it doesn't, that it sort of all comes out in the wash, you know. But the idea that there was that choke point then and now so much of our like, you know, the New York Times is there to defend our democracy is like the last one on the wall type of thing is really scares the crap out of me. Yeah, I mean, again, it's, you know, I think mostly what the Times does is great.
如果我总是凭这种冲动行事，我也算不上报纸的负责任的管理者，但报纸数量足够多，最后总能各方妥协、水落石出，你知道的。但是一想到过去存在那样的信息扼杀点，而现在我们的许多观念——比如《纽约时报》是为了捍卫我们的民主，就像是最后的守城人一样——这种想法真的把我吓坏了。是的，我的意思是，话说回来，我认为《时报》做的大多数事情都很棒。
And it's just that we need more than just the Times. And whether it's just the Times there, nothing is a check on the Times. And, you know, they're so much bigger than even the next biggest paper in both reach and influence. That it's, you know, it's also an ecosystem where everyone's trying to get to the Times. I mean, not everyone, but like, you know, that's where the career paths go.
只是我们需要的不止是《时报》。如果只有《时报》在那里，就没有人能对《时报》形成制衡。而且，你知道的，无论是在覆盖范围还是影响力上，它甚至比第二大报纸还要大得多。所以，你知道的，这也是一个生态系统，每个人都想进入《时报》。我的意思是，也不是每个人，但你知道的，那是职业发展的必经之路。
And that also really has a sort of punishing effect on really important, you know, journalism that isn't based in New York, that, you know, requires a different type of person to go out and report it different life experiences. So yeah, it's, it's a little grim out there for the media. Yeah, it feels a little bit like the New York Times is like the United States of America of newspapers, where it's the it's much bigger than any of the other ones. It feels a little bit like the New York Times is like the United States of America of newspapers, where it's much bigger than any of the other ones. It's much more powerful than the other ones,
这也对那些真正重要、不由纽约本土驱动、需要不同类型的人去实地报道、拥有不同生活经历的新闻工作产生了一种惩罚性的效果。所以，是的，媒体的现状确实有点惨淡。是的，感觉《纽约时报》就像是报纸界的美利坚合众国，它比其他任何报纸都要大得多。感觉《纽约时报》就像是报纸界的美利坚合众国，它比其他任何报纸都要大得多。它比其他报纸更有权势，
but it's imperfect. Like the idea that there should be a perfect paper that does everything you want it to do is an insane notion. Especially when you look back in The Power Broker and you're like, oh, they've kind of always been like this. Like it's always been a flawed newspaper. And I remember 20 years ago,
但它并不完美。那种认为应该有一份完美的报纸能满足你所有要求的想法，简直是个疯狂的概念。尤其是当你回看《权力掮客》时，你会发现：“哦，他们一直以来差不多就是这样。”它一直是一份有瑕疵的报纸。我记得20年
coming out of college and reading the Times' coverage of whether there were weapons of mass destruction in Iraq and at the time being like, how could the Times do this? And it's frustrating to feel like it's 50 years after the fact. And I'm still kind of frustrated with the New York Times for the same things back then. But again, it's only, they're only people, you know, I shouldn't expect so much of them just because they have the word New York in their name. But I do, you know. Yeah, and I think there was a line in there that was like, the fate of poor people had never been a subject of news in New York City. And it wasn't now. And I, I, I think that
刚大学毕业时，读到《时报》关于伊拉克是否存在大规模杀伤性武器的报道，当时我就想：“《时报》怎么能这样？”现在感觉已经过去了50年，这种心情依然让人沮丧。对于《纽约时报》当年做的那些事，我到现在还是觉得有点沮丧。但话说回来，他们也只是凡人，你知道的，我不该对他们抱有太高的期望，仅仅因为他们的名字里带有“纽约”两个字。但我确实抱有期望，你知道的。是的，我觉得里面有一句台词是这样的：穷人的命运从来都不是纽约市新闻的主题。现在也不是。而且，我认为
that is still true. Again, in part because they're, you know, even with a time, there's just not enough people going out and covering all these little things that would lead you to the big story necessarily. But also that, you know, those aren't the stories that are going to get you a lot of attention most of the time. Yes, if you produce the power broker, you'll get some attention, but the individual stories that might lead you there if you're a beat reporter, are probably not the most well read,
这种情况现在依然存在。同样，部分原因在于，你知道的，即使在《时报》，也没有足够的人去实地采访所有这些细小的事情，而这些事情原本可能会引领你找到重大新闻。但另一方面，你知道的，在大多数情况下，这些也不是能为你赢得大量关注的故事。是的，如果你写出了《权力掮客》，你会获得一些关注，但如果你是一个跑口记者，那些可能会引领你走向那里的个别故事，可能并不是阅读量最高、
well regarded, well shared. And that those amplification incentive factors are even greater in social media era, for sure. When I think about the qualities that are like the hallmarks of a Mother Jones, a Big Mother Jones story, it shares a lot of the DNA of the power broker. Like it has a sort of a humanist point of view. It's about systems and trying to get an investigation
最受推崇、分享最多的。在社交媒体时代，这种放大效应和激励因素无疑更加强烈。当我思考那些堪称《琼斯母亲》杂志标志的特质时——一篇典型的《琼斯母亲》重磅报道，它包含了《权力掮客》的大量基因。比如它有一种人道主义的视角。它关乎体制，并试图通过调查
to get the facts and sort of reveal the system. But that is a rarer and rarer position that magazines occupy. How do you keep that going? You know, what is the underlying principle that keeps that, you know, to be the forefront of what Mother Jones does? I mean, it's really interesting.
来获取事实并揭示体制的运作。但杂志占据这种立场的位置却越来越罕见。你该如何将这种风格维系下去？你知道的，支撑这种风格的核心原则是什么，让它成为《琼斯母亲》的核心工作？我的意思是，这真的很有趣。
In some ways, I think it's almost driven by the products that you have. For, you know, we have a magazine, and that's, you know, been a staple, and now we have a long-form radio show that does, you know, in a very different way, I think it's almost driven by the products that you have. We have a magazine, and that's been a staple, and now we have a long-form radio show that does in very different way, but same sort of intensive investigative journalism. And because we have those things, we have the muscle memory, We do a lot of short video. We do a lot of daily news reporting. But it's harder and harder to access workplaces
在某些方面，我认为它几乎是由你们拥有的产品所驱动的。比如，我们有一本杂志，这是我们的主打产品，现在我们还有一个长篇广播节目，它以一种非常不同的方式……我认为它几乎是由你们拥有的产品所驱动的。我们有一本杂志，这是我们的主打产品，现在我们还有一个长篇广播节目，它以非常不同但同样深入的调查性新闻方式进行。正因为我们拥有这些，我们才有了肌肉记忆。我们做很多短视频。我们做很多日常新闻报道。但要接触到那些
that kind of operate in longer form, more in-depth work. There are just, again, fewer of them. So I think that that's part of it. And then I think Mother Jones has always held up as his mission, like looking out know, looking out for the little guy, like looking out for the people that are getting quashed by whatever it is. Sometimes it's government, sometimes it's private industry,
以长篇、更深入的方式运作的工作场所却越来越难。同样，这样的地方越来越少了。所以我觉得这也是原因之一。然后我认为《琼斯母亲》一直将它的使命坚守为：关照小人物，关照那些被某种力量压榨的人。有时是政府，有时是私人企业，
but like a lot of the great work that we do comes from just asking like, what's happening to these people or why, you know, why are we hearing about this amazing thing and what's the underside to that? You know, for example, we did a few years ago, Shane Bauer, um, did this fantastic piece where he went again, undercover in a private prison and we had done a lot of private prison reporting.
但我们做的很多伟大的工作都源于这样一个问题：这些人的遭遇是什么？或者为什么，你知道的，为什么我们会听到这个了不起的事情，而它的阴暗面是什么？你知道，例如，几年前，肖恩·鲍尔（Shane Bauer）做了一篇精彩绝伦的报道，他再次卧底进入了一家私人监狱，而我们之前已经做过很多关于私人监狱的报道。
And, um, he is a delightful madman who wanted to do this. And, um, there were many nights for more than a year, But I was going to say that seems like the scariest possible, or one of the two or three scariest possible assignments I can imagine. Yes. Unless it was like you're going to live in a den of tigers for like a year. And he also went undercover with a militia. So, you know, it wasn't his only piece like that for us. Every now and then you hear about a job and you're like, I am not cut out to do that job.
而且，他是一个想要做这件事的可爱疯子。而且，在一年多的时间里有许多个夜晚……我本来想说，这听起来像是我想象中最可怕的任务，或者两三个最可怕的任务之一。确实如此。除非任务是去老虎洞里住上一年。他还曾卧底加入民兵组织。所以，你知道的，这并不是他为我们做的唯一此类报道。你偶尔会听到某种工作，然后觉得：我可干不了那种工作。
I'm glad somebody else is. Yeah. Yeah. And I think one of the most interesting things about that work, for example, was that Shane had been held in captivity by Iran for more than a year. So he had been in solitary confinement. He had his own personal crazy journey through one of the worst prisons in the world. But that said, he brought a real sense of humanity to the guards who he realized are all earning nine bucks an hour and are really not that much different
我很高兴别人去干。是的。是的。我认为这项工作最有趣的地方之一，例如，肖恩曾被伊朗关押了一年多。所以他经历过禁闭。他在世界上最糟糕的监狱之一经历了自己疯狂的个人历程。即便如此，他还是给那些看守展现了一种真正的人性，他意识到这些看守每小时只挣九块钱，其实和他们看守的囚犯并没有太大区别。
than the prisoners that are guarding. Their economic circumstances aren't that different. These are the only jobs around. What does it mean to have to do that kind of a job, and especially in a facility that's so under-resourced, as many of them are? And I think that, too, is really having that kind of eye for the humanity, even in the things that you find to be suspect or corrupt in some way, which I think Caro is also really good at.
他们的经济状况没有多大区别。这些是周围仅有的工作。必须要做那种工作意味着什么，尤其是在一个资源如此匮乏的设施里——许多设施都是如此。我认为，这也是那种对人性的洞察力的体现，即使在你发现那些可疑或某种程度上腐败的事物时也是如此，我认为卡罗在这方面也非常擅长。
I mean, Moses himself, I think, becomes an increasingly remote figure when it comes to sympathy from the reader. But we get to know him better and better. And that is just so important to this kind of work. Yeah. And you know the human he was when he started, which makes the whole narrative arc so, so compelling is that you sense his idealism and his vision for seeing things that no one
我的意思是，我认为摩西本人在赢得读者的同情方面，成了一个越来越疏离的人物。但我们对他的了解越来越深入。对于这类作品来说，这一点至关重要。是的。而且你知道他刚开始时是一个什么样的人，这使得整个叙事弧线变得如此引人入胜，你能感受到他的理想主义，以及他看到别人看不到的
else can see. And it's one of the things that I think when people are craving a modern day Moses in terms of they're like people who can get stuff done and who can dream big and build big things and create their megopolises. Libertarian sea studs. I think that's what they're drawn to. If it was just the latter part,
事物的远见。这就是为什么当人们渴望出现一个当代的罗伯特·摩西时——在他们看来，那是能把事情办成、敢于做大梦、建造大工程并创造大都市的人。自由意志主义的海上家园派。我想这就是吸引他们的地方。如果只有后半部分，
I don't know if they would be quite as drawn to it. But I am struck by this idea, you know, like, one of the things I've been trying to articulate to people, I've been interviewed a lot about this sort of anniversary. I've noticed, Roman, I'll get a lot of Google alerts that are like, oh, Roman Mars is talking about this thing. And I'm like, oh, okay, interesting.
我不知道他们是否还会如此被吸引。但我对这个想法深有感触，你知道的，我一直在试图向人们阐述的一点是——关于这个周年纪念日，我接受了很多采访。我注意到，罗曼，我会收到很多谷歌快讯，内容都是“哦，罗曼·马斯在谈论这件事”，然后我就想：“哦，好吧，很有意思。”
I was involved in that podcast. I'm just kidding, mostly. But one of the things I've said in every one of them that's never been picked up on, because it's not a very good sound bite, is I think one of the underlying benefits to people reading this book is not learning how studies are built or how power is done or this sort of deep exploration of this man, Robert Moses.
我参与了那个 podcast。我开玩笑的，大部分是开玩笑。但我在每次采访中都说过的一点，却从未被媒体关注，因为这并不是一个很好的爆点，那就是我认为人们阅读这本书的潜在好处之一，并不是学习如何建设城市、权力是如何运作的，也不是对罗伯特·摩西这个人的这种深入探索。
It's actually sitting in the company of this really thoughtful humanist in the form of Robert Caro and the way he sees the world and that that is what is so uplifting and profound about the book when so much of it can be dire and and very devastating to read. I think one of the things I love most about this book is that he does center the little people he does a great job at finding you know, I don't know if it was really women who again and again were like the people kind of jumping in
而是实际上与这位非常体贴的人道主义者——也就是罗伯特·卡罗——以及他看待世界的方式共处，正是这种视角，在全书许多内容可能显得沉闷和毁灭性的时候，给这本书带来了如此令人振奋和深邃的色彩。我认为我最喜欢这本书的一点，是他确实以小人物为中心，他非常擅长寻找……你知道的，我不知道是不是真的是那些女性一次又一次地
Robert Moses' way, but he does a great job of, of, you know, whether it's the Women's City Club or the, yeah, the Tremont folks who are, you know, housewives kind of leading the charge there. And, you know, really goes out and leading the charge there and, you know, really goes out and finds them and treats them with dignity and respect and does the careful work of taking them seriously and really understanding their circumstances and I, you know, there's a version of this book that would still be
挡在罗伯特·摩西的路上，但他把她们写得非常出色，无论是城市妇女俱乐部，还是特里蒙特的那些家庭主妇们在带头冲锋，你知道的，他确实走出去寻找她们，给予她们尊严和尊重，认真对待她们，真正理解她们的处境，并且做好了细致的工作。你知道，这本书完全可以有另一个版本，
very good but didn't accomplish that and And I think that is the difference maker, honestly, in this. I mean, the majesty of it all, for sure. But it's those small, intimate details and stories and the sort of sympathy and empathy that he brings to folks that he may not have had all that much in common with before or known much about, but he's going to go spend eight months on that avenue to figure out who everybody was involved in that movement, and he manages to pull that off so well.
依然非常优秀，但却没有做到这一点。老实说，我认为这正是其中的胜负手。当然，整部作品的宏大叙事也是原因之一。但正是那些细小的、私密的细节和故事，以及他对他可能原本并不熟悉、也没有太多共同点的人所怀有的同情和共情，让他能够花八个月时间去那条大道上弄清楚所有参与这场运动的人都是谁，而他居然把这一切写得如此出色。
Yeah, there's a lot of the retrospectives that have been coming out, especially now there's also a lot of articles coming out that are like 50 years on, the power broker doesn't do everything right, and it's like, well, yeah, of course, it's a book and also it's 50, it's a half a century old. So, but I've seen a number of times and also in the contemporary reviews of it, they accuse it of pushing the kind of great man view of history that Moses is this great world changer and everyone else is just kind of in his wake. And it feels like that's such a misreading to me of so much of the book because he does highlight so many other human beings. They don't get the same amount of space as Robert Moses does.
是的，有很多回顾性文章不断涌现，尤其是现在也有很多文章指出，50年过去了，《权力掮客》并没有把所有事情都做对。这就好：嗯，是的，当然，它是一本书，而且已经有50年历史了，半个世纪了。但是，我多次看到——包括在当年的书评中——人们指责它推崇了一种历史的“伟大人物史观”，即摩西是伟大的世界改变者，而其他人只是顺应他的潮流。在我看来，这种观点对书中很大一部分内容产生了极其严重的误读，因为他确实突出了那么多其他的人。他们没有获得和罗伯特·摩西等同的篇幅，
And each of these people is someone who is striving to accomplish something, is fighting for either their own livelihood or to get some kind of truth out. And we've seen them a number of times in the series, these like little biographies of these kind of heroes that that Carol is clearly bringing up who are usually people who do a lot of research and a lot of investigation. He likes people who go and look up answers to questions or talk to people to get the answers to questions, but that it is such a hidden beneath this kind of argument about why this way of running a city and constructing a city isn't there. There's this kind of hidden celebration of and constructing a city isn't there. There's this kind of hidden celebration
但这些人中的每一个人都在努力完成某项事业，都在为自己的生计或揭露某种真相而战。我们在这一系列节目中多次看到这些英雄的小传，卡罗显然是在颂扬他们，他们通常是那些做了大量研究和调查的人。他喜欢那些去寻找问题答案或与人交谈以获取问题答案的人，但在这种关于为什么管理和建设城市的方式不应该那样的争论背后，隐藏着一种对
of ordinary people who are either doing a job that is trying to make a difference or forced out of their normal lives in order to end making a difference in that way. And there's something very exciting about it that it makes it feel so much more like the portrait of a city, you know, than just this one guy and the clay that he's working with.
普通人的隐秘赞颂。他们要么在做一份试图带来改变的工作，要么被逼离开正常生活，从而以这种方式带来改变。这其中有一种非常令人兴奋的东西，它让这本书更像是一座城市的肖像，你知道的，而不仅仅是一个家伙和他手中的泥巴。
You know, it's something that Carol does so well that now reading other biographies, I do miss it. If there's like a three sentence sketch of some person, I'm like, what about, you know, what about that person's dreams? What about the rest of their life? You know? Yeah. I mean, this book really contains multitudes. Like they're, you know, full on, you know, profile worthy books in there's certainly of LaGuardia and L. Smith, but others along the way. And it's just like, wow, that's, I really felt I learned more about,
你知道，这是卡罗非常擅长的一点，以至于现在读其他传记时，我真的会怀念这一点。如果书里只有对某个人三句话的速写，我就会想：那那个人的梦想呢？他剩下的生活呢？你知道的？是的。我的意思是，这本书真的包罗万象。比如，里面有完全值得为其写一篇人物专访的人物，当然有拉瓜迪亚和阿尔·史密斯，还有沿途的其他人。这就像是，哇，我真的觉得自己对
you know, many, many mayors, even the really, uh, even, I've come, I've come to really love him for all the wrong reasons, I guess. Um, then I, you know, then I, then I had known even when I lived in New York. So I think that's really rewarding. I'm curious what you guys think if the kind of critique of Moses and everything that Moses stood for kind of set the country and maybe particularly sort of more progressive folks down a path
许多许多市长有了更多了解，甚至对那些……即使我有了很多出于错误理由而喜欢上他的地方，我也因此而真正喜欢上了他，比我住在纽约时了解得还要多。所以我觉得这真的很有收获。我很想听听你们的看法，摩西以及摩西所代表的一切所受到的这种批判，是否让整个国家、尤其是更倾向于进步主义的人们走上了一条这样的道路：
where they're so suspicious of any development, any massive projects, be they public, private, a hybrid, that that's part of why we kind of find ourselves where we are, which is stuff is crumbling, nothing's getting built, you know, everything is being held up in a community meeting, which of course, even though Jane Jacobs isn't mentioned in this book, that ultimately this sort of, you know, city is a collection of neighborhoods that all need to be listened to. If you think that that, you know, we're in a weird moment where it's not like anyone wants a Moses, but we also don't want paralysis.
他们对任何开发项目、任何大规模项目（无论是公共的、私人的还是混合的）都抱有极大的怀疑，这是否正是我们发现自己陷入当前困境的部分原因——即基础设施在崩溃，什么都建不成，你知道的，一切都被社区会议拖延。当然，尽管简·雅各布斯并没有在这本书中被提及，但最终这种“城市是由需要被倾听的街区组成的集合”的理念……如果你认为，我们正处于一个奇怪的时刻：没有人想要一个摩西，但我们也不想要瘫痪。
I, Roman may disagree with me, but I am going to draw a parallel between We've so we clashed so many times on this show the I'm gonna draw parallel between the way people talk about Robert Caro's critique of Moses that it's elevating him in too much importance And it's making him too much that the single the single thing the single source of it all and I think that that criticism of the book commits the same sin when you look at the history of the United States since this book was written, and it's like, it's not like America didn't need Robert Caro to make it distrust authority, you know, like Watergate and the Vietnam War and so forth did that. And America didn't need Robert Caro to make it dislike large spending on public works projects, because Ronald Reagan did plenty of that. It feels like it is the same way people will make the criticism. They'll say Robert Moses is a symptom. He's an avatar
罗曼可能会不同意我的看法，但我打算做一个类比。我们在节目中已经交锋了这么多次，我要把人们对罗伯特·卡罗对摩西批判的讨论方式——即认为它过分夸大了摩西的重要性，把他塑造成唯一的、一切问题的唯一根源——与这种看法做个类比。我认为对这本书的这种批判犯了同样的错误：当你回顾这本书写成以来美国的历史时，并不是美国需要罗伯特·摩西来让它不信任权威，你知道的，水门事件、越南战争等事情已经造成了这一点。美国也不需要罗伯特·摩西来让它厌恶在公共工程项目上的巨额开支，因为罗纳德·里根做了足够多的这方面工作。这就好像人们批评的方式一样。他们会说摩西是一个症状，他是时代宏大思维的化身，
of the larger thinking of the time rather than the source of it. I think you could look at the book kind of the same way in some ways, and that to elevate, maybe it has an outsized proportional importance to urban planners, you know, but that kind of work would only be in this state if America had been driving in that direction to a certain amount anyway. So as much as I love this book, I feel like I can't give it all the credit or nor blame for what's going on. Roman, what do you think about that? I think that's similar to my reaction to that, which is it wasn't Carol pointed it out that caused the problem.
而不是这种思维的根源。在某种程度上，你也可以用同样的眼光看待这本书。或许它对城市规划者有着不相称的重要影响，但如果美国本来就一直朝着那个方向发展到一定程度，那么这种工作也只会处于这种状态。所以，尽管我深爱这本书，我觉得我不能把当前发生的一切全部归功于它，也不能归咎于它。罗曼，你怎么看？我觉得这和我的反应类似，问题不在于卡罗指出了这一点从而引发了问题，
It's that Robert Moses built shitty public housing and didn't maintain it. And that is the part that's being kind of over-corrected for, that the bad actors who literally built the things and did not care for them and designed these really tight closed systems that had no fault tolerance whatsoever, like a real community does, are the people that failed in this scenario.
而是罗伯特·摩西建造了糟糕的公共住房却没有进行维护。这正是人们正在矫枉过正的部分，那些真正建造了这些建筑、不关心它们、设计出没有任何容错能力的狭隘封闭系统（就像真正的社区所具备的那样）的糟糕决策者，才是这个剧本中失败的人。
And pulling it out is not really the issue. You know what I mean? And I don't think people are overcorrecting for the power broker. I think they're overcorrecting for the sins that these people committed. And they were bad. I mean, they really did not serve the communities they were supposed to serve. And we've had to deal with that failure
而把它挖出来并不是真正的问题所在。你知道我的意思吗？我不认为人们是在对《权力掮客》进行矫枉过正。我认为他们是在对这些人犯下的罪孽进行矫枉过正。他们真的很糟糕。我的意思是，他们真的没有服务好他们理应服务的社区。我们不得不处理这种失败，
for a long, long time. But what I think was powerful about The Power Broker is it teaches you kind of indirectly the method to which to make it better. I'm really struck by the fact that the book is called The Power Broker. It's not called The City Builder. It's not called The Master Builder or whatever other things you might think of as a moniker for Robert Moses.
已经很长很长一段时间了。但我认为《权力掮客》厉害的地方在于，它间接地教给你了把它变好的方法。我印象最深的是，这本书叫《权力掮客》。它不叫《城市建设者》。它不叫《造山大师》或者你可能会用来称呼罗伯特·摩西的其他任何头衔。
He's really focused on power and the human here. In a way, he's not really trying to explain all cities, you know, but what he's saying is that the root rot of this problem is the lack of democracy. That's what Caro really holds onto. And to me, you know, these projects are things that fail. Is that same problem, a kind of lack of input, a lack of care, a lack of like not having enough influences
他真正关注的是权力和这里的凡人。从某种程度上说，他并不是真的在试图解释所有的城市，你知道的，但他所说的是，这个问题的根源是缺乏民主。这才是卡罗真正抓住不放的东西。对我来说，你知道的，这些项目的失败也是同样的问题——缺乏民众意见的输入，缺乏关怀，缺乏足够的影响力、
and expertise and material and it all being top down. A public housing system is great when everything works. It's just that it can handle failure so, so poorly. Like it has to have a diversity of incomes and races. It has to have working lights and safety and stuff. And when one of those things fall apart, like when Prude Igo fell apart in St. Louis, it crumbles dramatically. But in the beginning, it works really well. And that's just the problem of an idea in your head versus a thing in action.
专业知识和物质条件，这一切都是自上而下的。一个公共住房系统在一切运转顺利时是很棒的。只是它承受失败的能力太差太差了。就像它必须具备收入和种族的多元化一样。它必须有正常运转的灯光、安全设施等等。当其中一个环节崩溃时——比如圣路易斯的普鲁伊特-伊戈大厦崩溃时——它就会急剧瓦解。但在最初，它运作得非常顺利。这正是一个头脑中的理念与实际行动中的事物之间的矛盾。
And it just so happens that the Robert Moses types of the world who make things have much more fealty to the idea in their head than the actual thing that's created. And that would all be worked out through iteration and input and all sorts of other things that would make things good. So I would say that Robert Moses ruined it for all of us, not the knee-jerk reaction that the power broker brings. It is the lived reality of the failure of public housing, the failure to the community it's supposed to serve most of all, that I think people are reacting to
而恰巧世界上罗伯特·摩西这类搞建设的人，对他们脑子里的理念的忠诚度，远高于对实际创造出来的东西的忠诚度。这一切本可以通过反复迭代、收集意见以及各种其他能让事情变好的方式来解决。所以我要说的是，是世界上形形色色的罗伯特·摩西毁了我们所有人，而不是《权力掮客》带来的膝跳反应。人们做出反应的，是公共住房失败的现实生活，是对其本应服务的社区的最大程度的辜负，我认为人们对此的反应，
more than just its criticisms. Yeah, for sure. I guess what I was sort of driving at is that there's a critique now voiced by among others, Ezra Klein and so forth that like, we have gotten into this dynamic where any objector to any project can stop many, certainly in California, many projects for any reason. Sometimes those reasons are valid.
远多于对书中批判本身的反应。是的，确实如此。我想我刚才想表达的是，现在有一种由以兹拉·克莱因（Ezra Klein）等人为代表的批判声音，即我们已经陷入了这样一种动态：任何项目遭到任何反对者的反对，都可以阻止许多项目——在加利福尼亚州尤其如此——可以出于任何原因阻止许多项目。有时这些理由是正当的。
Sometimes they're not that valid. And this in part is a system that sort of grew up as a corrective to the many projects for any reason. Sometimes those reasons are valid, sometimes they're not that valid. And this in part is a system that sort of grew up as a corrective to the absence of that. Yes. And I think that that's a really, I just had that in my head a lot while I was reading this book about where are we going to hit that balance correctly? And I think that's a good criticism of the state of the world, is that we've probably overcorrected for, and a kind of knee-jerk nimbism is just a part of our modern progressive DNA.
有时这些理由并不是那么正当。这在某种程度上是一个为了纠正缺乏这种机制而生长出来的系统。有时这些理由是正当的，有时这些理由并不是那么正当。这在某种程度上是一个为了纠正过去缺乏这种机制而生长出来的系统。是的。我认为这是一个非常……我在读这本书时脑子里一直盘旋着这个问题：我们将在哪里正确地找到这种平衡？我认为这是对世界现状的一个很好的批判，即我们可能对某种倾向进行了矫枉过正，而一种膝跳反射般的邻避主义（NIMB_yism）已经成为我们现代进步主义DNA的一部分。
And that's one of the reasons why it's like, it's a disappointing aspect of a branch of progressivism to not embrace imperfect solutions that will help a lot of people. But I do get a sense that it's beginning to turn a little bit, and the sense that, okay, well, maybe we are too reactionary about change and we have to serve as many people as possible. And I do think that these things come in waves and they come in fashion and go down again. And the truth is, it's going to be a case by case on every single issue of this. Like it's really gonna have to be decided based off of the merit of every single development
这也是为什么，进步主义的一个分支不愿意拥抱能够帮助许多人的不完美解决方案，这是一个令人失望的方面。但我确实感觉到这种风向开始有点转变了，人们开始意识到：好吧，也许我们对变革过于反动了，我们必须尽可能服务更多的人。我确实认为这些事情是一波接一波的，它们流行一阵然后又消退。事实是，这将在每一个单一议题上都需要个案处理。就像它真的必须根据每个开发的价值
and what the cost is. And it just so happens that in the Robert Moses era, it was only up to him. And that's the huge mistake. And we don't have that same problem today because there's not one person. But I do feel that sense of like people have a default sense that a certain type of development
以及成本来决定一样。恰巧在罗伯特·摩西时代，一切都由他一个人说了算。这就是巨大的错误。而我们今天没有那个相同的问题，因为不再只有一个人了。但我确实有这种感觉：人们有一种默认的心态，认为某种特定类型的开发
is bad. And we have to stop because there's bigger problems to solve and we need to take in as much information. The biggest sin that Robert Moses had was that he could take in no new information his entire life. Cars were leisure vehicles. Cars were just going to be for fun.
是坏事。我们必须停下来，因为有更大的问题需要解决，我们需要尽可能多地吸收信息。罗伯特·摩西最大的罪过在于，他一生中无法吸收任何新信息。汽车是休闲工具。汽车本来就只是为了好玩。
We can't move the road. I already drew the line on the map. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And also just like, I don't care if I'm in traffic for two hours because I'm sitting in the backseat working and somebody is driving me. Sounds pretty nice actually. And so what I hope is that the leaders of today and the people who support them will accept a kind of thoughtful ambivalence about things. Like not being just a diehard about one thing or another and just like, in this case, this makes sense, in this case, this makes sense.
我们不能移动这条路。我已经在地图上画好了线。是的，正好。而且还有，我不在乎我在交通里堵车两个小时，因为我坐在后座上工作，有人在开车。听起来其实挺不错的。所以我希望的是，今天的领导者和支持他们的人能够接受一种对事物深思熟虑的矛盾心理——不是对某一种事物死板固执，而是觉得：在这种情况下，这说得通；在那种情况下，那说得通。
And I would love if we all just got behind people like that. Yeah, and I do feel a great sense of optimism on that front that I think just, you know, Californians at least who probably are everywhere in the country just kind of got so sick of the sclerosis that they just individually dug up their, dug in and started to like figure out zoning codes and go to hearings and so forth because it just wasn't, it wasn't kind of breaking out of the, the the the you know the dynamics that it had been in for a long time and and that is super encouraging and I think you know shows that really explain this kind of thing as yours does also help us
如果大家都能支持这样的人，我真的会很高兴。是的，在这方面我确实感到了极大的乐观，我认为，至少加州人——可能全美各地都一样——只是对这种僵化状态感到太厌倦了，以至于他们开始各自行动、扎根基层，开始研究区划法、去听证会等等，因为现状实在无法打破过去长期处于的那种动态，
hopefully it feels like if anything we're getting across in this show I hope it's that the the one correct and true reading of the power broker which is in my in my opinion it's not that he's saying this is the way to build and this is not the way to build, but that every project is a series of choices and decisions, and you have to make those choices and decisions as judiciously as you can based on the best information. And it feels like you could go through that book, Project with Robert Carroll, and you might say, this, they did okay.
这超级令人鼓舞，而且我认为，正如你的作品一样，真正解释这种事情的著作也有助于我们……
This one, maybe they should do, should have done differently. This one was good. You know, he never says he continues to go back to Jones Beach because clearly he sees Jones Beach as an unalloyed good, maybe not in the way it was managed necessarily, but in its construction.
希望如此，如果说我们在节目中传达了什么的话，我希望是关于《权力掮客》唯一正确和真实的解读——在我看来，它不是在说“这是建造的方式，这不是建造的方式”，而是每一个项目都是一系列的选择和决定，你必须根据掌握的最佳信息，尽可能明智地做出这些选择和决定。感觉你可以跟着罗伯特·卡罗一起过一遍书中的项目，你可能会说：“这个，他们做得还可以。”
And so the idea that people read it, this huge book, which has so much stuff in it, so much, so many ideas in it. And they come out and they're like, well, bad to do big things. It feels like that's people refusing to pick up what Robert Caro is really saying, which is like, hey, let's not rush things, but let's do them.
“这个，也许他们应该、本该用不同方式做。”“这个挺好。”你知道的，他从未说过……他继续回到琼斯海滩，因为很明显他将琼斯海滩视为一件纯粹的好事，也许不一定是在管理方式上，而是在其建造上。
It's funny, as much as I love this book and it's become the center of my personality for now many, many years at this point, how much I love big plants. Like I love, love big plants. It is not, it's not dissuading me from big plants at all. Big plants are great. I mean, Roman, reading this book, every time they mentioned that elevated expressway
所以，人们读了这本包含如此多内容、如此多思想的巨著之后，得出的结论居然是“做大事是件坏事”，这感觉就像人们拒绝接受罗伯特·卡罗真正想说的话——也就是：“嘿，我们不要操之过急，但我们要把事情做成。”
through mid Manhattan that would go through buildings, I'm like, that would be bad. Everything about is bad, but you imagine it, you're like, that sounds amazing. It sounds so cool. Knowing it would be terrible, but it still sounds cool. You can't, you can't deny it. Some sort of Jetsons situation where you can just carve
有趣的是，尽管我如此喜爱这本书，它甚至在不知不觉中成了我多年来核心人格的一部分，但它丝毫没有打消我对比大型基建的喜爱。我就是喜欢、极度喜欢大型基建。大型基建太棒了。我的意思是，罗曼，读这本书时，每次他们提到曼哈顿中城那个会穿过建筑的高架高速公路，我都会想：那太糟糕了。一切都很糟糕，但你想象一下，你会觉得：听起来太棒了。听起来太酷了。
a tunnel right through the Empire State Building. Yeah. It would be fun to see. So one thing I wanna get to is, it strikes me that you have been in a position where you're about to publish something that is going to piss someone off. And I think about this book about to come out and Robert Caro's state of mind. Could you put us in that head space of
明知它会很糟糕，但听起来还是那么酷。你无法否认这一点。某种杰特逊一家的场景，你可以在帝国大厦中间直接凿出一个隧道。是的。那看起来会很有趣。所以我想讨论的一点是，我觉得你曾处于这样一种境地：你即将发表一些会惹恼某些人的东西。我想到了这本即将出版的书以及罗伯特·卡罗的心态。你能把我们带入那种心境吗？
you're about to put out your reporting, you are confident in it, but you're always nervous that you're going to get little bits wrong. It's going to make people mad. They're very, very powerful that have a lot of money. What does that feel like right before you publish it? Sheer terror. I think when you've done your best to report something out and, you know, it would be very different manner in which Kara reporting over many years and going back to
你即将发表你的报道，你对此充满信心，但你总是担心会搞错一些小细节。这会让那些非常有权有势、很有钱的人抓狂。在发表之前的那一刻，那种感觉是什么样的？纯粹的恐惧。我认为，当你尽了最大努力去报道一件事时，你知道的，这与卡罗多年来不断报道摩西、多次去找摩西（当然摩西在某个时候把他拉黑了，不过你知道的）的方式非常不同，你拿着问题心想：“好吧，这是你最后的机会。这是我的最后几个问题。”我还是……你知道的，仍然没有得到回答。
Moses many times and at some point Moses cut him off, of course, but like, you know, has the questions you're like, okay, this is your last chance. Like these are my last questions. I still don't, you know, still didn't get an answer. And to really do that early and often and to make sure that you kind of go back at the end, particularly in a long involved project and give people that space and real deadlines. But you know, it is terrifying and also you could have everything right and people, you know, will of course, disingenuously describe your reporting or maybe really just not see your point of view at all about it.
并且要尽早且经常地这样做，确保在最后（特别是在一个漫长而复杂的项目中）回顾时，给人们留出空间和真正的截止日期。但你知道的，这太可怕了，而且你可能把所有事情都弄对了，而人们当然会恶意曲解你的报道，或者可能根本看不到你对这件事的观点。
So it's not like you're ever going to get the people that you're reporting critically on to agree with you. That said, we often have people say, all right, this was, you know, I didn't like it, but it was fair. Yeah. And, you know, I think that that's what you hope for when you can get it for sure. Yeah, yeah. You know, when I think about this book,
所以你永远不可能让那些成为你批判性报道对象的人去同意你的观点。话虽如此，我们经常听到人们说：“好吧，这……你知道的，我虽然不喜欢，但它很公平。”是的。而且，你知道的，我认为当你能争取到这一点时，这就是你所期望的。是的，是的。你知道，当我想起这本书时，
I think of how important it is to explain in New York an important biography of a person. And Kero has admitted we probably wouldn't think about Robert Moses at all if it weren't for his book. So he's both presented them and changed people's minds about him. But it makes me wonder, if you were to write your power broker, if I were to write my power broker, are there a thousand more books like this to write? Is this kind of a singular there a thousand more books like this to write? Is this kind of a singular like subject and style and achievement? Or if you dig deep enough, are there equally profound and interesting biographies out there for cities all over the world?
我想到了在纽约解释一个重要人物的传记是多么重要。卡罗也承认，如果没有他的书，我们可能根本不会想到罗伯特·摩西。所以他既呈现了这个人，又改变了人们对他的看法。但这让我好奇，如果你来写你的《权力掮客》，如果我来写我的《权力掮客》，是否还有成千上万本这样的书等着去写？这只是一种单一的、孤立的题材、风格和成就？还是说，如果你深入挖掘，在世界各地都会有同样深刻且有趣的城市传记？
There's at least one of Lyndon Johnson. Well, that's kind of it. It's like the things those two things have in common, it's caro. But maybe there's way more people that explain the 20th century in their own ways. I don't know. I honestly don't know the answer to this question. I think that there are, if you have the right, the sort of serendipity of the right reporter and project with the
至少还有一本关于林登·约翰逊的。嗯，差不多就是这样。这两件事的共同点在于它们都是卡罗写的。但也许还有更多的人以他们自己的方式诠释着20世纪。我不知道。我老实说不知道这个问题的答案。我认为，如果你拥有合适的人选，即正确的记者和项目，搭配上
right subject. I mean, I'm thinking of a book that I thought was a truly excellent biography, George Packer's biography of Richard Holbrook was called Our Man. And I, you know, I had studied like Vietnam a little bit in college and whatever, but that was a book that in a similar and a much shorter, even though it also was a door stopper, just sort of makes you feel like, my God, this person was at the nexus of everything
合适的题材……我的意思是，我想起了一本我认为堪称杰作的传记——乔治·帕克（George Packer）写的理查德·霍尔布鲁克（Richard Holbrooke）的传记《我们的人》（Our Man）。我，你知道的，在大学里稍微学过一点越南战争之类的东西，但那本书以一种类似但篇幅短得多（尽管它也是一本大厚书）的方式，让你觉得：天哪，这个人处于一切事物的核心交汇点，
and I had never really thought about them at all and now I kind of see the world in a different way. Obviously he's a great writer, but I do think that the works out there are possible, that the sort of time and even if you have a writer that's predisposed to spend years and years and years on one subject, which a lot of people, that would not be a healthy decision for them. But again, back to the support, just like how many people are going to get that level of institutional support or, you know, have, you know, maybe they're independently wealthy or
而我以前从来没有真正关注过他，现在我以一种不同的方式看待世界了。显然他是个伟大的作家，但我确实认为这样的作品是有可能实现的，只要有愿意花好几年时间在一个主题上的作家——尽管对许多人来说，这可能不是一个健康的决定。但话说回来，还是要看支持力度，就像到底有多少人能获得那种级别的机构支持，或者，你知道的，也许他们本身就很有钱。
whatever it is, and they can just plug away at a book for, you know, seven years in the case of this one. And, you know, the LBJ stuff is what, like another 40 or something, we're on 40 years now. And that's just, you know, that's just, that's incredibly rare. I think in order to do the rest of the lives justice that you need to explain the world, you need this kind of like Borgesian library where there's a biography of every single person who's ever lived that has been given the treatment that Robert Carroll was able to give to Robert Moses because everyone is the nexus of everything in their own lives. And it's just like that the power broker is like like this it's like a little portal into what that
不管是什么，他们都可以潜心创作一本书，你知道的，就这本而言花了七年时间。而且，你知道的，关于林登·约翰逊（LBJ）的材料大概又是40年左右的成果，我们现在已经写了40年了。你知道的，这真的是，这真的是，极其罕见。我认为，为了公正地展现他们的一生，你需要解释这个世界，你需要这种博尔赫斯式的图书馆，里面有每一个曾经活过的人的传记，他们都得到了罗伯特·卡罗能够给予罗伯特·摩西的待遇，因为每个人都是他们自己生活中的一切的交汇点。就像《权力掮客》就像这个一样，它就像是一个通往那个
library would be like but unfortunately it's beautifully impossible Roman unfortunately. Well that that can't think that's kind of my point like is there a power broker to be written about a lot I mean obviously there's some people that don't have as much influence in the world as this but there probably is more than we think because I didn't you know, we wouldn't know of this one if it wasn't for this book. And so I'm just, it makes me think that there's just a world out there to investigate and explore in a way that gets me kind of excited, you know, like I like that idea, you know. I mean, the other thing I think, Elliot, you and I talked about it a little bit before Roman came on, but this sort of the one, you know, and I mean, maybe somebody should get
图书馆的小型门户，但不幸的是，罗曼，它美得令人难以置信地不可能实现。好吧，那——我不禁认为，这正是我的观点——难道还有一本关于权力的书有待撰写吗？我的意思是，显而易见，有些人对世界的影响没有这么大，但可能这种影响比我们想象的还要多，因为我——你知道的，如果没有这本书，我们就不会知道这个人物。所以我在想，外面还有一个广阔的世界等待我们去调查和探索，这种方式让我感到有点兴奋，你知道的，我喜欢这个想法，你知道的。我的意思是，还有一件事，埃利奥特，在你加入之前，你和我稍微聊过一点，那就是这个，你知道的，我的意思是，也许应该有人
around to doing this project, but the sort of examining the climate impact from what Moses and the Moses imitators or contemporaries did, you know, it's the it's super enraging to be like, why can't I get to the airport via the subway? Or like, why does it take three hours when it should take an hour to get out to wherever in Long Island? But then when you sort of sit back and you realize, my God, you know, just the lack of a good railway system on Long Island, the lack of certain things that have really became obvious even at the time, but not with the
着手去做这个项目，那就是审视摩西以及摩西的模仿者或同代人所造成的气候影响，你知道的，这真的是超级让人火大，比如：为什么我不能坐地铁去机场？或者，为什么去长岛的某个地方本来应该花一个小时，却花了三个小时？但当你静下心来意识到，天哪，你知道的，仅仅是长岛缺乏一个良好的铁路系统，缺乏某些甚至在当时就已经变得显而易见的事物，尽管当时还没有使用
same vocabulary because of course they weren't worried about CO2 that was stuff locked deep in the memorandum of ExxonMobil and wherever. Nobody else kind of understood that or was talking about it, but they did start to understand the traffic and the more tangible pollution part of it. And that's the part that just enrages me. Yeah, and even more than wanting to see his work on Jane Jacobs, that feels like the missing piece. I had not thought about it too much until you had mentioned it before we started the interview,
相同的词汇，因为他们当然不担心二氧化碳，那些东西都被深深锁在埃克森美孚和其他地方的备忘录里。没有人真正理解这一点或者在谈论它，但他们确实开始理解交通以及其中更具体的污染部分。这就是让我感到愤怒的部分。是的，甚至比想看到他关于简·雅各布斯的著作还要强烈，这感觉像是缺失的一块。在我们开始采访之前你提到它之前，我并没有想太多，
but exactly the idea that he's so focused on the effect of the people in an area where this road exists, where people have to use this road. And now we know that the emphasis on cars affects billions of people that are not even living near the road, who have nothing to do with that road. And it's such an amazingly massive scale compared to what Kara was talking about in this book. That being said, when you live in New York, it's pretty inconvenient to get to the airport. You know, let's not forget about that. No, it's one of its least attractive features.
但确实，他是如此专注于这条公路存在这个地区的居民受到的影响，那些不得不使用这条公路的人。而现在我们知道，对汽车的重视影响了数十亿甚至不住在公路附近、与那条公路毫无关系的人。与卡罗在这本书中讨论的内容相比，这是一个惊人的巨大规模。话虽如此，当你住在纽约时，去机场确实很不方便。你知道的，我们不要忘记这一点。不，这是它最没有吸引力的特点之一。
It's how hard it is to get to the airport. It's not really his to do, but like I do wish somebody could do it. It's a really good question. There could be just a Moses report that's just like this person is responsible to this many metric tons of CO2. I mean, in our atmosphere, it strikes me as a doable or at least a teachable metric to come up with. Yeah, sort of back of the napkin way. Yeah. Yeah. And I'm just, since I have
去机场有多难。这其实不归他管，但我确实希望有人能去研究一下。这是一个非常好的问题。可能只需要一份“摩西报告”，上面写着这个人要为这么多公吨的二氧化碳负责。我的意思是，在我们的气氛中，这让我觉得是一个可行或至少是可以教授的衡量标准。是的，有点像信封背面的粗略估算方式。是的。是的。而且我只是，既然我有
you guys in the, I'm also curious, do you guys think that he directly influenced tons of projects and planners elsewhere in the country? This book is so, we know that he goes out there and he brings them in and he has them to Jones Beach and Guy Lombardo plays and all this stuff, but what part of this was really he was the stone thrown in the pond and the ripples go out from him versus LA was turned out that saw the trolley system and the Eisenhower Express out from him versus, you know, LA was tearing out the stop trolley system and the Eisenhower Expressway project was underway. But that part, I feel like,
你们在这里，我也很好奇，你们觉得他直接影响了国内其他地方的大量项目和规划师吗？这本书太……我们知道他走出去把他们请过来，让他们去琼斯海滩，还有盖伊·隆巴多（Guy Lombardo）的乐队演奏等等，但其中有多少比例真正是因为他像一块石头被扔进池塘，涟漪从他身上扩散出去，相比之下，洛杉矶当时拆除了有轨电车系统，艾森豪威尔高速公路项目也在进行中，而洛杉矶正在拆除有轨电车系统，艾森豪威尔高速公路项目也在进行中。但那部分，我觉得，
Caro had not, at least so far in my reading, had not kind of gotten to yet. Yeah, and he doesn't get to it. And I think this is one of the mistakes people, when they criticize the book, they talk about how, well, this was happening everywhere, Robert Moses wasn't all that important. And I think that what Robert Moses was great at
卡罗——至少在我目前的阅读中——还没有写到这一点。是的，他没有写到。我认为这就是人们在批评这本书时犯的错误之一，他们会说，好吧，这在各地都在发生，罗伯特·摩西并没有那么重要。而我认为罗伯特·摩西真正擅长的是
was being at the lead of the popular sentiment that was already happening. So he was an effective warrior in this idea of complete mobility, freedom through cars, and the interstate system. And it was out there, but he was truly effective and pushed it. And when he was successful at generating money and generating his own projects and them all building on each other, that also was an example that people followed. So I think it's a little bit of both.
顺应当时已经正在发生的公众情绪。因此，他是这种彻底流动性、通过汽车获得自由以及洲际公路系统理念的有效斗士。这个理念本来就在那里，但他确实非常有效并推动了它。当他在创造资金和自己的项目、让它们相互促进方面取得成功时，这也成为了人们效仿的榜样。所以我认为两者兼而有之。
And again, this gets to one of the criticism in the book that I kind of bristle against is people try to take it down but they go, well, it doesn't explain LA. I was like, well, it wasn't trying to explain LA. Yeah, LA's, New York is in the subtitle. Like, come on. Yeah. Or the criticism that says, it's 50 years,
再说一次，这就谈到了我对本书的一条批评感到有些扎心的地方，人们试图否定它，但他们会说，嗯，它没有解释洛杉矶。我就想，好吧，它本来就不是为了解释洛杉矶。是的，洛杉矶的……纽约就在副标题里呢。拜托。是的。或者那种批评说，已经过去50年了，
and New York has bounced back. How does he explain that? And it's like, well, it's been 50 years. Like, it's half a century. I hope New York has bounced. I hope that the greatest city in America and the world has bounced back, you know? Yeah, so I think it was a little bit of both,
而纽约已经复苏了。他对此怎么解释？这就好比，嗯，这已经过去50年了。这可是半个世纪。我希望纽约已经复苏了。我希望美国乃至世界上最伟大的城市能够复苏，你知道的？是的，所以我认为两者兼而有之，
but he was definitely like,, he exported like his, his self, you know, he went to other other cities, people came to study it. Um, and, you know, and he had the legacy in the ear of like the agenda setting people in the federal government who were like putting all this money into highways, you know, and he just tapped into it. Like he just had a way of just being a little bit ahead of everyone else, but knowing where it was all going so that he had very little friction. It feels unfair that sometimes a criticism the book gets is, yeah, but it doesn't explain everything.
但他绝对就像是，他输出了他的，他自己，你知道的，他去了其他城市，人们来研究他。嗯，而且，你知道的，他在联邦政府那些制定议程、将所有资金投入高速公路的人中间有着遗产和影响力，你知道的，他只是顺应了这一点。他只是有一种方式，比其他人领先一点点，但又清楚这一切将走向何方，所以他遇到的阻力非常小。有时候人们对这本书的批评让人觉得很不公平，那就是“是的，但它没有解释一切”。
And I guess it's the risk you run when you create an amazing, enormous book is that people want to find everything in it and have it easily explain everything. But But sometimes you got to read a second book. Yeah. You can't just rely on the one book. And you know, and everyone should and no one's saying that you should only read the power broker. No one's ever said that. Yeah. You know. But I think that's like it goes right down to again, like its title. It's like it is not the city builder. It is not the master builder. It is the power broker. He wasn't trying to explain all cities. And in a way, he wasn't necessarily trying to explain everything about New York City,
我想当你创作了一本宏大惊人的书时，你所面临的风险就是人们希望在其中找到所有东西，并让它轻而易举地解释一切。但是，有时候你得读第二本书。是的。你不能只依赖一本书。而且你知道，每个人都应该读，也没有人说过你只应该读《权力掮客》。从来没人说过。是的。你知道。但我认为这其实又回到了它的标题本身。这就好像它不是“城市建造者”。它不是“大师建造者”。它是“权力掮客”。他并不是在尝试解释所有的城市。在某种程度上，他也不一定在尝试解释关于纽约市的一切，
even though people have taken it on as the perfect, the history of a city. He was really focusing on a human and the effects of this human and what he got out of it, even though he wasn't a quote unquote corrupt in the way that we normally think of. And that's his focus. What other people try to imbue into the text
尽管人们把它当作一本完美的城市历史来接受。他真正聚焦的是一个人、这个人所产生的影响以及他从中得到了什么，尽管他并不是我们通常意义上的那种“腐烂”的贪腐分子。这就是他的焦点。其他人试图灌输进文本中的内容，
is kind of their own problem. But when I find criticisms, mostly it's those things that are these distal things that people have created around the book than the book itself. Right, it's a mistake to think the story here is just how did he make the atlas of New York look different when it's really like how did he sort of gather and exploit power in a way that had not been documented on this scale. Absolutely.
某种程度上是他们自己的问题。但当我发现批评意见时，大多是那些人们围绕这本书创造出来的边缘性东西，而不是这本书本身。没错，如果以为这里的故事仅仅是“他是如何让纽约的地图看起来与众不同”那就大错特错了，真正的故事其实是“他是如何以这种前所未有的规模来汇聚和利用权力的”。绝对如此。
But a credit in its own way to Moses, you know, sheer force and power to do all that. But then to Caro to showing it and really explaining how this has a material impact on everyday people both then and now. Yeah, that was Caro's mission. And to me, you know, he fulfilled it and then some. I don't think he was even trying to explain everything about New York City. He clearly thought there was something more to say when he was gonna do a LaGuardia biography, for example,
但这也是对摩西本身的一种赞誉，你知道的，他拥有完成这一切的纯粹力量和权力。然后是卡罗将其展示出来，并真正解释了这对过去和现在的普通人产生了怎样的实质性影响。是的，那是卡罗的使命。对我而言，你知道的，他不仅完成了，而且超额完成了。我不认为他甚至试图解释关于纽约市的一切。很明显，当他打算写一本关于拉瓜迪亚的传记时，他觉得还有更多的话要说，
or something else. Like there's definitely more to say even about New York. He doesn't even try to say everything about Robert Moses. He barely talks about that power dam that he built at Niagara. Exactly, exactly. Which is by any, shouldn't be the biggest term. He has a sister.
或者别的什么。比如，即使关于纽约，也绝对还有更多的话要说。他甚至没有试图说清关于罗伯特·摩西的一切。他几乎没有提到他在尼亚加拉建造的那座功勋卓著的水电大坝。没错，没错。这按理说不应该成为最大的……他还有一个姐姐。
Yeah, children. Children. That's right, that's right. Well, Clara Jeffery, thank you so much for being on the 99% visible breakdown of The Power Broker. It was a real pleasure to have you. Well, thank you so much. I just wanna say again, what a fan I am of your show
对，孩子们。孩子们。没错，没错。好吧，克拉拉·杰弗里（Clara Jeffery），非常感谢你来到《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的深度解析节目。很高兴你能来。好的，非常感谢。我只想再次表达，我是你们节目的超级粉丝，
and also that I got my mom to start reading The Power Broker and she's already caught up to where we are. I only talked to her about it a few weeks ago about this and she's 86 caught up to where we are. You know, I only talked to her about a few weeks ago about this and she's 86. She's getting through it. Mom's a beast, man. She's like, she's a big reader. She's a big reader. So, well, it's a real pleasure to have you.
而且我还让我妈妈开始读《权力掮客》，她已经追上我们的进度了。我几周前才跟她聊起这个，她今年86岁了，已经追上我们的进度了。你知道的，我几周前才跟她聊起这个，她今年86岁了。她正在努力读完。妈妈真是个狠人，天哪。她是个狂热的读者。她是个狂热的读者。所以，能邀请你来真是太高兴了。
Thanks so much for having me on. Next month, we continue our journey through part seven, the final part of the book, The Loss of Power. We'll be covering chapters 42 through 46. That's pages 984 through 1,081. That's right, we're crossing the 1,000 page mark. We did it, quadruple digits of pages. And we couldn't have done it without you. Now, if you can't wait that long
非常感谢邀请我来。下个月，我们将继续我们的旅程，进入第七部分，也就是全书的最后一部分——《权力的丧失》。我们将涵盖第42章到第46章。也就是第984页到第1081页。没错，我们要跨过1000页大关了。我们做到了，四位数的页数。没有你们，我们是无法做到这一点的。现在，如果你等不了那么长时间
to hear me summarize something, then I direct you over to the Flophouse podcast on the Maximum Fund Network. That is my bad movie podcast, which is a lot less informative than this one, but it does have roughly the same amount of me talking during it. I cannot believe we have only two episodes left.
来听我总结内容，那么我建议你去Maximum Fun网络收听《烂片播客》（The Flophouse）。那是我的烂片播客，虽然比这个节目informative（涨知识）少得多，但在节目中我说话的量大致是差不多的。我真不敢相信我们只剩下两集了。
So make sure to commemorate this incredible journey that we've all taken together this year with some 99PI Power Broker merch. We've got t-shirts, we've got bags, we've got bookmarks. Head over to 99PI.org slash store to get yours. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Real, mixed by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director.
所以请确保用一些99PI《权力掮客》周边商品来纪念我们今年一起经历的这段不可思议的旅程。我们有T恤、有包袋、有书签。前往 99PI.org 斜杠 store 获取你的专属周边。《99%隐形：权力掮客解析》由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔（Isabel Angel）制作，科米蒂（Comiti）剪辑，天鹅真实（Swan Real）配乐，达拉·希尔施（Dara Hirsch）混音。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯茜·图（Cathy Tu），我们的资深编辑是德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall），库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars. The 9% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, Californiaia you can find the show on all the usual social
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁韦（Chris Berube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriella Gladney）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·雷（Vivian Ley）、拉什马·唐（Lashma Dawn）、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado-Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，目前总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。你可以在所有常规社交
media sites as well as our own discord server where we have fun discussions about the power broker and architecture and movies and music and all that kind of good stuff it's where i'm hanging out most these days you can find a link to that discord server as well as every past episode of 99 pi at 99 pi.org episode of 99 PI at 99 PI.org. Um, what's the word I'm looking for? It's open. It's not the one I'm talking about. Hold on a second.
媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到这个节目，我们在那里就《权力掮客》、建筑、电影、音乐以及所有这些好东西进行有趣的讨论。最近我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。你可以在 99pi.org 找到通往该Discord服务器的链接以及 99 pi 的每一期往期节目。在 99pi.org。嗯，我要找的词是什么来着？它是开放的。不是我在说的那个。等一下。
Uh, again, I can't think of the word I'm looking for. That's fine. Uh, is about keep all this. This is all gold. Me trying to struggling to find this word. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
呃，再说一次，我想不起来我要找的词了。没关系。呃，伊莎贝尔，把这些都保留下来。这全都是宝藏。我在这里努力寻找这个词。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。